CALL THE MEETING TO ORDER FOR
SELF FIVE A PUBLIC SAFETY AND
WANT TO WELCOME YOU ALL HERE
I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHIRLEY
WEBER THE CHAIR OF SUB FIVE OF
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE. I'M WE
NORMALLY LIKE TO. AT LEAST HAVE
A CAN YOU HEAR ME. OKAY GOOD
OKAY WE NORMALLY LIKE TO HAVE-
AT LEAST ONE OF OUR MEMBERS
FROM ACROSS THE AISLE PRESENT
BUT UP WE HAVE SOME EMERGENCIES
GOING ON AT THIS TIME THAT
PREVENT FROM HAPPENING AS WELL
AS ONE MEMBER WHO'S IN ANOTHER
COMMITTEE SO THEY UNDERSTAND-
AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
INFORMATION HEARING TODAY AT.
WAS A LINDA JOINT WHEN SHE
CAN'T SHE'S IN A ANOTHER
MEETING AT THIS TIME WE'RE
GOING TO UP AND HAVE TO HAVE A
QUORUM BECAUSE IT'S AN
INFORMATION AND WHATNOT VOTING
ON ANY. OF DOUBT INTO. POLICE
HAVE WOMAN MISSED. TôI ARRIVES
AT WHICH POINT WE WILL TAKE
ROLE. SO WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
THE HEARING BECAUSE I KNOW MANY
OF YOU ON A TIME SCHEDULE AND
YOU KNOW I LIKE TO RUN A VERY
QUICK AND- EFFICIENT MEETING-
AND- YOU WANT TO GET IN AND-
OUT AND SOLD WHY. US SO BUT
THAT WE ALL THE HAITIAN. BY
EVERYONE HERE AND MAKE SURE
THAT OUR RECORDS ARE CLEAR. ON
IT TODAY HAVE TO AS OUR ONE
ISSUE TODAY. DEPARTMENT OVER
VIEW AND- THE PART JUSTICE AND
WERE ON A HAVE WITH THE OUR-
GENERAL. OF HABIA BUT SERRA
WHO'S HERE WITH US TODAY WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH HIM AS AND
I'M ONE PANELIST TO COME AND
GIVE US AN OVERVIEW. THE
PRIORITY FOR THE DEPARTMENT
CHEN THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
FOR. MAKING IT HERE TO AVIS I
THINK YOU HAVE A PERFECT UP
ATTENDANCE RECORD WITH US. AND
I APPRECIATE THAT. THEN THE
VERY. LET'S SEE HOW BOUT NOW NO.
TESTING ONE TWO THREE ONE THAT.
NO IDEA. HI BUT THIS. RIGHT
CHRIS RYAN TARA JUSTICE OF.
TESTING ONE TWO THREE TRY IT
NOW ONE TWO THREE ONE TWO THREE
TEST. NO CAN YOU HEAR. FOLKS IN
THE VERY VERY BACK CAN YOU HEAR
ALL THE WAY IN THE BACK THEY
SAID THEY CAN'T. OKAY. I THINK
YOU HAVE. IS IT WORKING. YES SO
NOW IT'S WAS THE THING ON THE
FLOOR DOES THAT TURN ON. YEAH.
RIGHT WILLOWS ONE THAT'S INSANE
AGAIN TESTING ONE TWO THREE
TESTING ONE TWO THREE. ONE TWO
THREE TESTING ONE TWO THREE. IS
THAT STUFF PLUGGED IN DOWN
THERE WHATEVER THAT IS. BUT IT
LOOKS LIKE. ARE YOU GUYS THINGS
ON. I THINK ANY OF OUR- NO
ONE'S ON. TESTING DOES NOT
HELLO HELLO. YOU CAN HEAR ME
RIGHT BECAUSE I'M TALKING ABOUT
BUT IF I TALKS OFF CAN YOU HEAR
ME. NO. OKAY WHO'S BUT IN A
ROOM WITH. I'M THEY'RE TRYING
TO WITH THE WORKING NOW. IT'S
WORKING NOW WORKING NOW. ONE
TWO THREE ONE TWO THREE.
TESTING ONE TWO THREE ONE TWO
THREE. THINKING HERE NOW THE- I
THINK THEY JUST WANT TO GET IT
OVER WITH. WELL NONE OF ROLE
IT'S AVAILABLE WEBER HERE JONES
SAWYER LACKEY MELENDEZ STONE
OBERNOLTE TING. MA'AM JEREMY
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE WITH YOU
AGAIN I'M JOINED BY CHRIS RYAN
WHO IS THE- THE CHIEF OF OUR
DIVISION ARE ON OPERATE SO
BETWEEN THE TWO OF US WE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE GOT SOME OF MY
OTHER TEAM MEMBERS HERE AS
WELL. IF YOU TO PARTICULAR
TIONS THAT WE- SIR. I'D IN BY
THANK YOU A COUPLE OF THINGS
AND TAKE ONE. FOR BEATS. OF
THIS DEPARTMENT AS WE HAVE
CONTINUED TO EXPAND THE REACH.
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
BEAT THE NEEDS THAT YOU OF. UP
PRESS. TWO FOR HAVING APPROVED
A THE- REQUESTED MONIES FOR
INCREASE OUT FOR SOME OF OUR-
THAT AND THROUGH THE-
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR SIGNING OFF ON
THE FUNDS THAT WERE NEEDED TO
IMPLEMENT THAT DAD THAT HELPED
US TREMENDOUSLY IN OUR
DEPARTMENT. I BELIEVE OUR
BUDGET. TRANSFERRING I BELIEVE
OUR BUDGET IS A REFLECTION OF
OUR VALUES AT THE PARTY TO
JUSTICE SO I MAY TRY TO FOCUS
ON A FEW THINGS. AND I SUSPECT
YOU HAVE SOME QUESTIONS. ABOUT
OTHERS. OUR WHILE MOST THE
ATTENTION I THINK IT'S TAKEN UP
IN THE NEWSPAPER AND MEDIA BY
THE WORK THAT HAS TO BE DONE IN
REGARDS TO THE- ACTIONS THAT
WE'VE TAKEN. AGAINST THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. UP QUITE
HONESTLY THAT CONSTITUTES ABOUT
1% OF EVERYTHING DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE HERE CALIFORNIA DOES.
OP THAT 1% IS IMPORTANT
OBVIOUSLY THE LOS THAT. WE
FILED. AT THE CENSUS TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT WAS DONE IN A WAY
THAT WOULD ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO
PURCHASE. PARTICIPATE WITH
PORTENT. ENDS A BILLION DOLLARS
AS YOU KNOW IS AT STAKE AS A
RESULT OF A CENSUS COUNT.
UNDERCOUNT WE LOSE. ARE WE
GONNA THE ISSUE PROTECTING HE
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND OR SO.
CALLED DREAMERS AND RIGHT NOW
WE'RE IN THE SPRING COURT WAIT
FOR DECISION ON THAT CASE. ARE
WE ARE LEAD AND USED BEING THE-
CORRECT JUST FOR. THE
CALIFORNIA. MANAGER THE A. C.
H. HERE BUT ALSO FOR THE RIVER
THAT. AS WELL AND CASE NOW
HEADING BEFORE THE SUPREME
COURT. BUT AS I SAID 99% THE
WORK THAT WE DO. HAVE NOTHING
YOU. WITH ANY ACTIONS. HE TO
FACT. CONTEST SEGREGATION WAS
STILL OCCURRING IN OURS
DISTRICTS SAID IN THIS CASE IN
MARIN SOUTH LEGAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT WHERE WE- WERE ABLE TO
GET THE SCHOOL DISTRICT TO MOVE
AWAY FROM- SEGREGATION PROGRAM
THEY HAD WHICH KEPT MOSTLY
MINORITY CHILDREN SEPARATED
FROM- WHITE MAGIC IT'S BY THAT
IS UNDER WAY RIGHT NOW AS WE
SPEAK UP WE- IN THE PAST. A
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE MISSING
PEOPLE AS A RESULT OF THE WORK
THAT OUR FRIENDS X. UNIX DOES.
WE COLLECTED SOME TWO POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
SETTLEMENTS OVER THIS LAST
YEAR- AND SOME OF THEM YOU'RE
FAMILIAR WITH THE ACT- THE CASE
AGAINST EQUIFAX THE CASE THAT
WE GET A CASE AGAINST AETNA. WE
RECENTLY DID TO MEDICATE
MENTIONS WELL BUT ALL THOSE
COME TOGETHER TO SHOW THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING THEM. PRETTY
TOUGH TO GET INTO SOME
PARTICULAR. ON THE HEALTHCARE
SIDE WOULD BECOME VERY VERY
ACTIVE A PLACE WHERE THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE DIDN'T
USUALLY FOCUS. ITS ENERGIES
DIRECTLY WE DID NOT HAVE A
SEPARATE UNIT. DEALING WITH
HEALTH CARE ISSUES BUT SO MUCH
OF AS A RESULT OF THE AC AND
OTHER THINGS. HAS MADE THIS IS
NECESSARY. SUTTER HEALTH I
THINK YOU NOW KNOW THAT THE
LARGEST HEALTH CARE THE- IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA REACHED A
SETTLEMENT WITH US. AND OTHER
PLAYERS AT WHERE. YOUR
MICROPHONE AN- OUT WHERE. THEY
HAVE AGREED TO PAY FIVE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY FOR OUR
PURPOSES THEY'VE AGREED TO MEN
JUMPED OF TERMS WHICH WILL
PREVENT FROM ENGAGING IN WHAT
WE BELIEVE IS VERY. THANK
BETTER BEHAVIOR AND THE RESULT
WILL BE THAT. OUR EMPLOYERS ANY.
ALL THEIR CUSTER AND THEIR
EMPLOYEES FAR BETTER. WHEN IT
COMES TO THE INSURANCE THEY GET
FROM THE LARGEST HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
ARE JOHNSON AND JOHNSON- WE
RECENTLY SECURED A THREE
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLAR JUDGMENT AGAINST JOHNSON
JOHNSON FOR MARKETING. A OUT
PUBLIC MASH IMPLANT IN WOMEN
WHO HAD. INCONTINENCE ISSUES
AND THAT WAS THE CASE JUST TO
GIVE YOU A QUICK EXAMPLE FORTY
TWO OTHER STATES THAT SETTLED
WITH J. AND J. ON THAT SAME
ISSUE FOR TOTAL OF A HUNDRED
FORTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS. WE
GOT JUST FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THREE HUNDRED FORTY
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS BECAUSE WE
WERE UNWILLING TO SETTLE THE
CASE. ARE THAT THE WHATEVER
PHARMACEUTICAL CASE WHERE WE
GOT CLOSE TO SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR BECAUSE THEY WERE
THE WHAT WE CALL IT PAY FOR
DELAY WITH THEY WOULD GENERIC
PERSONABLE COMPANY NOT PRODUCE.
OVER OF BRAND NAME. WHICH GAVE
THE MIX CITY TO SELL JULY AND
TO MAKE MUCH MONEY OFF ITS-
WOULD THEN GIVE A CALL. BROUGHT
TO THAT. ERIC WE WERE ABLE TO
GET SOME SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FROM TELE FOR HAVING
DONE THAT THAT'S ANTI
COMPETITIVE ALL THOSE THINGS
ARE WHY USE D. A. B. C. P. FROM
OUR APARTMENT TRY TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR- UNIT THAT DEALS WITH
HEALTHCARE HEALTH RIGHT AXIS-
UNITY. FOR TO DO THAT WORK
ALONG WITH THE WORK GOING AFTER
ANTI COMPETITIVE ACTIVITIES
TOTAL REQUEST THERE FOR TEN TEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS.
CCB A- INTERNET PRIVACY
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
RIGHTS IN THE IN OUR OVER THE
INTERNET SOMETHING THAT NO
OTHER STATE OR THE PHOTOGRAPH
IT HAS DONE TO DATE. OUR THAT
LAW IS NOW IN EFFECT WE IN
PREPARATIONS TO START OUR
ENFORCEMENT COME JULY FIRST
WHEN OUR RIGS ALIVE. AND I WANT
TO THANK- THIS LEGISLATURE FOR
GIVING US SOME OF THE RESOURCES
NEED OPERA GIVE YOU. BLURB BASS
I WE'VE BEEN HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH A NUMBER OF
OTHER STATE ACTORS WHO ARE IN
THIS BASED PRINCIPALLY IN
EUROPE WHERE THEY HAVE G. P. R.
A SIMILAR. I REACHED MOVED THE-
DINNER PRIVACY THEM I WROTE.
SHE HAD HIM OF A ROOM FORTY
PEOPLE. SHE HAD POPULAR IN THE-
EIGHT THREE MILLION PEOPLE THE
P. IS THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
THREE. BILLION DOLLARS. I SAT
DOWN WITH THE U. CASE
COMMISSIONER. YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT SIXTY SIX MILLION PEOPLE
THERE. I'D BE A TWO POINT SIX
TWO TRILLION DOLLARS. HE HAS A
100% T. CALIFORNIA HAS A LARGER
D. E. P. THAN EITHER ONE OF
THOSE TWO NATIONS ARE OUR GDP
IS TWO POINT NINE TRILLION
BIGGER THAN YOU CASE. WE HAVE
FORTY MILLION PEOPLE. WE HAVE A
TEAM OF TWENTY PEOPLE ENDS YOU
CAN SEE THE HURDLES THAT WE
WILL CONFRONT IN TRYING TO
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF ALL OF
OUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOW ARE YOU
OF ALL OF OUR- CITIES WHEN IT
COMES TO UP. THE INTERNET
PRIVACY THAT THEY'RE NOW GOING
TO EXPECT ANSWER TO EVERYTHING
WE CAN OUR REGULATIONS AS A
CENTER CLOSE TO GOING LIFE AND
WE'LL DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
ITEM FORCE GIVEN THAT UNDER THE
STATUTE WE ARE THE ONLY AGENCY
THAT HAS THE- POWER. OF THOR TO
DO THE FOUR K. AS JUST A QUICK
WORD I WILL TELL YOU WHAT YOU
PROBABLY ARE HEARING BACK HOME
WITH BEHIND. I SPECIAL AND FOR
I WANT TO DO WITH THE WAY BY
GETTING A PAIN PAYING TAXES IS
FEELING THE BURDEN OF THE
MAJORITY OF PLAYERS OUT THERE
THAT ARE NOT AND IF YOU TALK TO
MANY WOMEN IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
ON THE GROUND AND THEY'LL TELL
YOU THEY'RE THEY'RE OVERWHELMED
AT SOME CASES OUTGUNNED
ESPECIALLY THE RURAL COUNTIES
AND I THINK WE REALLY HAVE TO
PLAY STATE TO HELP THEM LOOK.
TO MAKE SURE HAVE A WAY FOR NAY
WITH SO WE AFTER THOSE WERE
TRYING TO DO WITH THE WRONG WAY
IF WE IF WE REALLY MET THAT WE
WANTED TO. A LOT CRIMINAL BASIC
CAN BUT REYES. THE WE SHOULD DO
A THE RIGHT WAY. DID YOU SEE
THE BUREAU OF GAMBLING CONTROL.
THERE WAS A LONG STANDING
BACKLOG OF SOME. ELEVEN HUNDRED
OR SO CASES THE STATE AUDITOR
WROTE A REPORT ON THAT- YOU ALL
GAVE US THE TASK AT HAND THANK
YOU FOR SOME RESOURCES ON THAT.
TODAY THE OF THE ELEVEN HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE CASES WE REPORTED
LAST YEAR THAT WE'RE BACK LIVE.
A HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE ARE
LEFT. NOW AT THE SAME TIME WE
CONTINUE TO GET CASES COMING
IN. AND OF THE HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE CASES ADD TO THAT ANOTHER
TWO HUNDRED OR SO THAT ARE
CURRENTLY BACK WHAT FROM THE
NEW LOW THAT IS COMMON. AND SO
RIGHT NOW WE ARE TRYING TO
PROCESS ALL THOSE THAT ARE
WORKING THROUGH BUT- WE HAVE
PROCESS SOME. OF FORTY THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO CASES.
THIS YEAR. ALONE BUT WE
RECEIVED FORTY FIVE HUNDRED AND
NINETY FOUR CASES IN THIS YEAR
OF THEM SO IT'S A IT'S A
CONSTANT ISSUE OF. NOT ONLY
TREAD WATER TRYING TO GET
AHEAD. WE ARE TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO.
GO AFTER THAT AND HERE'S WHAT
WERE YOU ARE I'M HOPING THAT
YOU WILL HELP US BECAUSE- WHAT
WE'RE FINDING IS THAT RATHER
THAN JUST TRY TO DAY CARE THIS
BACKLOG OF. CASES WHERE
LICENSES ARE DOING. AND THE
WORK BEING AND TO TRY TO. FIND
OUT IF THESE FOLKS THESE AIR-
GIMLI SHOPS ARE ABLE TO GET
RELICENSED. IS IT'S THAT WAY TO
LAST MOMENT WHEN THEY'RE UP
AFTER TWO YEARS TO GET THEIR
LICENSE RENEWED. WE SHOULD BE
DOING WORK RIGHT NOW OF
OVERSIGHT. AND SO WHEN WE GET
TO THEM IT'S NOT THE LAST
MOMENT THAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
THE OVERSIGHT. AND SO IT'S LIKE
GOING TO RESTAURANTS. YOU WOULD
NOT EXPECT IF THE COUNTY
SUPPOSED TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
RESTAURANT IS CLEAN. ONLY
GOING. ONCE EVERY TWO YEARS
WHEN IT'S TIME FOR THAT
RESTAURANT TO GET RELICENSED.
YOU KNOW WHO KNOWS WHAT THE-
YOU KNOW IF THEY GET CAUGHT
JUST ADVISE ALL THE WAY THROUGH
THAT AND THEY WANT CLEAN IT UP
RIGHT BEFORE IT'S TIME TO GET
LICENSE. AS YOU WANT TO GET AN-
AMBITIOUS AND HOW WE DO THIS IS
THAT A WAY TO THE VERY END. SO
WHEN I JUST TAKE CARE BACK
WHAT. THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE- BCP
QUEST. THERE IS THE ARE
GAMBLING CONTROL FUND THAT'S
USED FOR THIS PURPOSE. IT HAS
RIGHT NOW NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS WERE AT FOR FIVE
MILLION FIVE POINT FORM.
DOLLARS FROM THAT FUND. SO WE
CAN ACTUALLY DO MORE WORK.
EARLY SAID WAIT TO THE END. AND
THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT. CLARK OR- THE APP. THE
OPERATIVE PERSON AND PROGRAM
AGAIN FOR YOU FOR HELP IN
ADDRESSING THAT. THE HISTORICAL
BACK WHAT THAT EXISTED FROM.
SOME MORE THAN TEN YEARS AGO.
THAT'S ESSENTIALLY GONE NOW AND
WE TRY TO REDEFINE WITH YOUR
HELP IN FACT BY STATUTE WE'VE
SORTED REDEFINED THE BACKLOG SO
EVERYONE. IS ON THE SAME PAGE
OF WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ON
THE ARE PROHIBITED PERSON
SYSTEM AND SO WHAT I CAN TELL
YOU IS THAT. BOB THIS YEAR WE
HAVE CONTINUE THE PROGRESS
WE'RE EXPANDING TO REACH OUT TO
WORK WITH LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
A BIT MORE WE'RE FINDING THAT
IT'S OF IT'S FAR MORE EFFECTIVE
IF WE TRY TO GET WEAPONS AT THE
VERY BEGINNING OF WHEN WE FIND
OUT SOMEONE IS PROHIBITED. THE
WAITING TO TRY TO CATCH AFTER
THEY GOT INTO THE EXTENDED CAP
AND- RE JEFF. YEAH
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY NINE
HUNDRED CASES COMMITTEE IN
TWENTY NINETEEN AND WE REMOVED
APPROXIMATELY NINETY SEVEN
HUNDRED CASES FROM THE LIST SO
WERE AS I SAID WE WILL REMOVE
THE BACKLOG WE'RE TRYING TO
KEEP PACE THE COMMUNITY BUT
HERE'S THE REAL ISSUE THAT WE
HAVE THAT I WANTED TO MENTION
TO YOU. ARE WE HAVE FORTY KIDS
TO DO THIS WORK. WE USED TO
HAVE FIFTY OUR OUR OUR AGENTS
ARE BEING PAID SUBSTANTIALLY
LESS THAN- A SEAT P. OFFICER
FOR EXAMPLE IS PAY OUR AGES
WHEN THEY GET OPEN MORNING THEY
KNOW WHAT THEY'RE GONNA DO
THEY'RE GONNA GO TRIED REMOVED
WEAPON FROM SOME PROHIBITED
THAT MEANS YOU'RE EITHER
FELONS. OR DANGEROUS THAT'S
WHAT THEY DO EVERY DAY AND
UNTIL THEY GO TO BED THAT'S
WHAT THEY DO YET THEY GET PAID
AB MARK RATE BELOW BUT AS HE HI.
AS PER KEEP UP BUT OUR AGENTS
DO SOME IMPORTANT WORK FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO PUT IT
IN CONTEXT THOSE FORTY FIVE
AGENTS. THAT MEANS GIVEN THE
SIZE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. EACH AGENT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THIRTY SIX
HUNDRED SQUARE MILES. EACH
AGENT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR RAIN
EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE
THOUSAND PEOPLE. JADE IS
RESPONSIBLE BECOMING MORE THAN
AND COUNTY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IT'S NOT DOABLE
WITH FORTY FIVE AGENTS WE CAN'T
DO IT WITH THE PAY THAT THEY
RECEIVE AND SO WHAT I'M HOPING
IS THAT WERE ABLE TO CONTINUE
TO SEE. RECOGNITION BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I KNOW THE
LEGISLATURE DOES HAVE DIRECT
CONTROL OVER CLICK BARGAINING.
BUT THAT WE CANNOT COME WE HAVE
A FOR. VACANCY VACANCY RATE WE
USED TO HAVE FIFTY EIGHT SINCE
WE'RE DOWN OUT TO FORTY FIVE-
AND STOP PAY IT'S NEAR
IMPOSSIBLE TO COMPETE WITH LONG
SPENT ELSEWHERE. YET THESE
FOLKS MANY WOMEN ARE EIGHT DO.
VERY DIFFICULT WORK. OF ONE OR
TWO MORE FRIENDS X. WHICH WANT
TO. MAKE SURE EVERY WITH CLEAR
WHAT WE MEAN MY FRIEND. OF WHEN
YOU SEE THAT KIND OF A PAIN IN
THE NEAR. CALIFORNIA FATHERS
CHARGED WITH MURDER FIVE OF HIS
IT FINCH. NEW DNA TECHNOLOGY
HELPED OFFICIALS CRACK A CASE
THAT ITS STAR FOR A DOZEN
YEARS. THAT'S THE WORK THAT WE
DO AT OUR IN OUR FRIDGE FRIENDS
X. BUREAU- IN A EVIDENCE
EXONERATES HIM OF MURDER AFTER
TWENTY YEARS IN THE- THAT'S THE
WORK THAT OUR FRIENDS SIX. DOES
ODD THESE ARE THINGS REDDING
EDGE IN FACT OUR FORENSICS UNIT.
IS ONE OF ONLY THREE SHOTS IN
THE ENTIRE NATION AND THE OTHER
TWO ARE THE FBI AND THE ARMY
WHO ACTUALLY CAN NOW DO
MITOCHONDRIAL- DNA FULL GENOME
SEQUENCING THAT WHEN WE TRY TO
GET INTO WHAT THAT IS OTHER
THAN TO SAY TO BREAK THROUGH.
IT LETS US GO AFTER BUT INSTEAD
MAYBE BILL OR BE DONE BY OTHERS
AND THE RESULT OR THINK LIKE
WHAT SEE REPORTED IN THE
NEWSPAPERS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY AND THAT IS THAT ARE
LIGHT LAUGHTER DOING THINGS
THAT OTHERS CAN'T. PRIVATE LABS
CANNOT DO WHAT WE DO PUBLIC
LABS DON'T DO THE MISSING
PERSONS IN FACT FAMILIAL
DATABASE WORK THAT WE DO- WE
PROVIDE EXTENSIVE FORENSIC
CONTESTING FOR FORTY SIX OF THE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THAT'S
APPROX WE FOUR HUNDRED AGENCIES
IN TWENTY NINETEEN WE RESEARCH
PROX BUT THE SEVEN THOUSANDTH
QUEST FOR NOW. HUNDRED TALK
ABOUT DATA THANK SAMPLES.
THERE'S TALK THESE DAYS THAT WE
BE CHARGING. OUR PARTNERS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL THE POLICE
DEPARTMENTS THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENTS. OTHERS AT RISK THE
DA'S. FOR THE SERVICE THAT WE
PROVIDE. WILL TELL YOU THAT IF
WE DO THAT THE FIRST QUESTION
THAT EACH OF THESE AGENCIES
BASKETS. SO WHICH CASE DO YOU
NOT WANT ME TO SEND TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. FOR
ANALYSIS BECAUSE WE ONLY
LIMITED. SO IF YOU WANT ME A I
TELL ALLEN ANALYZE THE STE A
SEXUAL ASSAULT CASE. YOU WANT
ME TO PUT A PROPERTY OR GIVING
YOU THE EVIDENCE ON THE MURDER
CASE OR VICE VERSA. NOW THEY
DON'T HAVE TO MAKE JUDGMENTS
THEY GIVE US THE EGGS. BUT IT'S
FOR BOTH. WE DO THE- I JUST I
RIGHT NOW IN THE ATTACK ON
RETIREMENT GIVING. OUR PARTNERS
IN LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
RESOURCES I THINK THE BE UNFAIR
FOR THEM TO HAVE TO. TRY TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT EVIDENCE IS
MOST IMPORTANT AND SO I URGE
YOU TO. CONTINUE O SUPPORT OUR
FRIENDS EXPERIMENTALLY BECAUSE
IT'S THE BEST ONE OF THE BEST
THE NATION. BUT ALSO BECAUSE IT
CONTINUES TO SHOW THAT WE HELP
OUR PARTNERS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
TO THE- THEY MUST. HAVE AN
EARLY I WANT TO MENTION
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
FORENSICS WE'RE HOPING TO
CONSOLIDATE OUR LAB. FOR THREE
PRINCIPLE REASONS. WE CAN
EXPAND OUR LAB IN RICHMOND. OUR
SPACE IS LIMITED. OUR RENT FOR
RENTING FROM THE PRIVATE DATA-
AT LAMBERT IS EXPENSIVE. AND WE
JUST SIMPLY CAN'T HIGHER IN THE
BAY AREA FOR WHAT WE PAY. AND
SO WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY RIGHT
NOW TO COME IN SACRAMENTO SAC
STATE IS LOOKING TO PARTNER
WITH THEY'D LIKE US TO LOCATE
ALONGSIDE THEM BECAUSE THEY
WANTED THEY WANT KIDS. TO GO
INTO FORENSIC IN THIS THAT
FORENSIC SCIENCE AND THEY WOULD
PROVIDE US WITH THE PERSONNEL
THAT WE NEED MOVING INTO THE
FUTURE. MOST OF FOR. LEON WHY
BECAUSE THE WE END UP TRAINING
THEM PROFESSIONAL EYES IN THE
THAN THE GO GET MORE MONEY OUT
IN THE AND THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
THE AVERAGE HIGHER AB AVERAGE
AGE OF THE HIGHER IN IN OUR
RICHMOND LAB IS TWENTY SIX
YEARS OF AGE. WHEN DO THEY
LEAVE THEY LEAVE RIGHT WHEN
THEY'RE THIRTY SEVEN IN THEIR
PRIME. THEY'RE VERY SKILLED AND
THEY MAKE A GOOD AMOUNT OF
MONEY OUR PAY DIFFERENTIAL
DIFFERENTIALS ABOUT TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS WITH OUR
PUBLIC LAPS. AT THE PRIVATE
LABS AND SO. WHAT I'D LIKE TO
DO IS FIGURE OUT A WAY TO BE
MORE EFFICIENT WITH THE
RESOURCES WE HAVE IT BE EASIER
TO RECRUIT HERE IN. NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY IF WE GOT
A PARTNER AND CAL STATE LOOKING
TO WORK WITH US SO. WITH THAT
SAID I WANTED TO STEP BY STEP.
I WANT TO. UNDERSTAND I SAID I
THANK YOU FOR THE HELP IN
RATIFY. THE CONTRACTS. OR
AGENTS. THE ALARM FOR. BUT THAT
CARD A SEAT THAT WAS A CENTER
FOR OPERATIONS. IN I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL OF COULD. TO SEE
THE WORK OF THE DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE SOMETHING AND IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN TWENTY SEVENTEEN YOU
ALL GAVE US. NEW ASSIGNMENTS
THAT TOTALED FOUR BCP'S. I DID
IN THIS TIME AROUND WE'RE
HAVING TO REQUEST TWENTY ONE
BCP'S BECAUSE F THE WORK THAT
THE LEGISLATURE'S ASK
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO DO AS
A WE'RE READY TO DO IT WE JUST
NEED THE RESOURCES AND I COULD
TELL YOU THAT THE MEN AND WOMEN
OF THIS DEPARTMENT. EVEN THOUGH
THEY LOVE TO BE PAID A LITTLE
BIT MORE- HARD ARE DOING A
SUCCESSFUL- JOB AT THIRD AT
THEIR OPPOSITION TO THANK YOU
ALL VERY MUCH FOR THE TIME.
QUESTIONS OKAY YES. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- SO I JUST. FIRST
WANT TO SAY THAT I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOUR
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN DOING IN
TRYING TO GET THE- WEAPONS OUT
OF THE HANDS OF PROHIBITED
PERSONS HOWEVER- RIGHT I STILL
HAVE SOME CONCERNS AND IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN- AJ ASKED
TWENTY. MILLION DOLLARS TO TAKE
CARE THAT BACKLOG AND WE SAID
YES YOU MAY HAVE TWENTY FOUR
MILLION BECAUSE WE ALL CARE
ABOUT THESE GUNS BEING PICKED
UP. THE BACKLOG IS STILL AT
ABOUT NINE THOUSAND. SO I
UNDERSTAND AND I HI BUT I IT
SEEMS. YEAH YOU GOT RID OF
SADDAM BUT NOW YOU HAVE NEW
ONES ADDED AND I'M JUST TRYING
TO FOLLOW. THE RATIONALE HERE
IN. THE INCREASE IN EXPENDITURE
BECAUSE THE AT THE FIRST TIME
WE HAD THIS CONVERSATION WE
WEREN'T TOLD WELL IT'S BECAUSE
WE CAN'T PAY PEOPLE ENOUGH IT'S
WE JUST NEED MORE BODIES NOW
WE'RE BEING TOLD WHAT WE CAN'T.
AND I'M- THING OBVIOUSLY BUT
THAT THE JOB IS NOT BEING
COMPLETED BECAUSE WE NEED TO
PAY PEOPLE MORE AND I. I
CERTAINLY AGREE THAT- THAT'S
TOUGH JOB IN THE SHOULD BE PAID
WELL TO DO IT BUT IT JUST SEEMS
LIKE WE'RE A LITTLE DISJOINTED
AND WHY WE AREN'T ABLE. TO GET
THIS JOB DONE AND I RECOGNIZE
THAT. IT'S NOT A STATIC
ENVIRONMENT THAT PEOPLE ARE
ADDED TO THIS LIST EVERY DAY
BUT I. I THINK EVERYBODY ON.
THE WEATHER YOU'RE SO I'M AND
PARKS INTERN MY YOU. KNOW WANT
AND IN THE HANDS OF PEOPLE HAS
TO HAVE THEM SO COULD YOU SPEAK
TO THAT BUT PLEASE. REMEMBER
THIS THANK YOU FOR THE ARE. AND
I THINK OVER THE LAST YEAR AND
A HALF WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO.
SORT OF. MMHM COMPARTMENTALIZE
PEOPLE COULD UNDERSTAND BECAUSE
TODAY'S APPS PROGRAM IS VERY
DIFFERENT FROM THE TWENTY
THIRTEEN APPS PROGRAM SO FOR A
FOR EXAMPLE. THE BACKLOG THAT
EXISTED THAT. OF MONEY WAS
PROVIDED FOR TWENTY THIRTEEN
THAT'S GONNA. THAT WAS
ADDRESSED BUT AS YOU MENTIONED.
ALWAYS GETTING CASES AND ON TOP
OF THOSE THAT EXISTED IN WERE
PART OF A BACKLOG. AND AS I
MENTIONED- OUT WE HAD ABOUT
EIGHTY NINE HUNDRED NEW CASES
COME IN THIS. WEEK CLEARED SOME
NINETY SEVEN HUNDRED OF THEM.
BUT HERE'S THE OTHER THING WE
TRY TO DO FOR OF TRANSPARENCY.
A LOT OF THOSE CASES THE
THOUSANDS THAT YOU MENTIONED.
ARE GONNA BE DIFFICULT
EVERCLEAR. BECAUSE THERE'S A
CATEGORY AND WE TRY TO READ
READ TO FIND THE CATEGORY SO
IT'S NOT CONSIDERED AT THE
BACKLOG BACK WHAT MAKES IT LOOK
LIKE A CASES THEIR STOCK HAS ME
WORK IT HAS BEEN. CLEARED THE
CASES THAT WORKED. BUT WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO CLEAR OR
WILL NEVER BE ABLE TO CLICK THE
ME GIVE YOU A QUICK EXAMPLE.
OUR SOMEONE MOVED OUT OF STATE.
IF THEY MOVED A STATEMENT
BEFORE WE CLEAR THE WE CAN'T
TAKE HIM OFF THE LIST EVEN
THOUGH WE HAVE NO JURISDICTION
TO GO AFTER THEM GO OUTSIDE
CALIFORNIA THAT PERSON WE
PROBABLY WOULD NEVER GET THE
CLEARS THROAT A CALIFORNIA THEY
READ SOME OF THE BEST STE THEY
ALONG WITH COUNTLESS OTHER NOW
STATE. MAIN ON THAT LIST AND
LIKE THEY'RE SITTING THERE NOT
UP THERE SOME PEOPLE WHO FROM
WEAPON FOR PERCENT. OF THE
FEDERAL PROBE MISSION WE DON'T
THE JURISDICTION TO IT IN FOR.
THAT LAW TO REMOVE. SO EVEN
THOUGH THEY HAVE THE WEAPON WE
DO THAT WITHOUT OUR FOR PARTNER
GOING INTO THE WORK AND SO THAT
PERSON MAY SHOW UP BUT WE CAN'T
DO ANYTHING ABOUT THAT SOMEONE
I'D- HAVE THE IN. THERE'S A
DIFFICULT PLACE WE THAT PERSON
AND IN FACT ABOUT A HUNDRED
EIGHTY EIGHT PEOPLE THIS TAX
YEAR WERE. THE FACT. THAT DO
YOU HAPPEN TO KNOW HOW MANY
PEOPLE HAVE MOVED OUT OF STATE
THAT ARE STILL ON YOUR LIST WE
CAN GET THAT NUMBER I DON'T
HAVE IT WITH ME RIGHT NOW BUT
WE COULD PROBABLY GET OUT AND
I'D BE INTERESTED IN CHECK OUT
OF COURSE YOU'RE NOT GONNA
EVERY OF THEM BUT- I THINK.
THEY SAY I JUST. AS SOME MORE
QUESTIONS COME TO MIND IT
PLEASE CONTINUE EXCEED ONE OF
THE THINGS. WE'RE HOPING IT
TOO. AND BY THE- I THINK
COMMITTEE REQUEST WAS FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE BE IS THE SYSTEM
THE DATABASE SYSTEM THAT WE'RE
USING IS SO ANTIQUATED THAT I
WE SOMETIMES CAN'T SPIT OUT
NUMBERS TO EXPLAIN SOME OF
THESE THINGS BECAUSE WE CAN'T
GET THE WAY THE SYSTEM. IT TO
FIFTY OF. TO DO IS MAKE IT SO
IT'S- WHEN WE SAY A BACKLOG
WHAT IS IT REFER TO WOMEN CASES
PENDING WHAT WE FOR IT WHEN WE
SAY CASES ACTIVE. BUT WE
REFERRING TO BECAUSE THE CLEAN
ACTIVE CASEWOULD. BRING TO
SOMEONE'S MIND THAT WE ARE
WORKING. AND THAT'S WHAT WE
THAT'S WHAT WE TRY TO. IS AN
ACTIVE CASE TODAY SO RATHER
THAN USING BACKLOG AND ALL THE
REST WAIT WAS IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN. WE'RE NOW TALKING
ABOUT CASES ACTIVE. OR PENDING
ENDING A LOT OF THE SPACES THAT
WE MAY NEVER GET TO TOUCH. AND
IT'S ALL IT SEVERAL. PENDING
BUT- JUST HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
CLEAR THE CASES ARE THE ONES
THAT WE THINK WE MAY BE ABLE TO
GET TO EVEN THOUGH THEY MAY BE
SOMEWHAT OLD BUT WE THE REASON
TO BELIEVE THAT THE PERSON MAY
COME BACK INTO THE STATE. TO
WORK THEM. BUT YOU THE-
CONSTANT. THE NEW CASES EVERY
YEAR WHAT THE CASE IS GOING OUT
BUT YOU'RE STILL THAT BIG MASS
IN THE MIDDLE. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS MR OBERNOLTE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MISTER SERRA IN
YOUR TESTIMONY YOU MENTIONED
THE WHAT'S THAT TO CALIFORNIA'S
BEEN FIRST AGAINST THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION IN VARIOUS
VENUES AND- I KNOW ONE OF THOSE
LAWSUITS HAS BEEN AN ATTEMPT TO
PREVENT THE CREATION FOR
WITHHOLDING FEDERAL FUNDS FROM
STE TO CLEAR SANCTUARY CITIES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO LAST WEEK
WE HAD A RIPPLING FOR SECOND
CIRCUIT APPEALS STEP THAT THE-
RUSSIAN DID. THIRTY TWO. A
RULING FROM THE NINTH CIRCUIT
THAT APPLIES TO CALIFORNIA-
THAT HELD THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DID NOT HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO WITHHOLD IN THIS
CASE IT WAS JAG GRANT MONEY FOR
OUR LOCAL LAW. AGENCIES NINE
MILLION FOR THE- YOUR SOAP
BECAUSE TO SIXTY MILLION. WE
ONE THAT THAT CASE BOTH IN THE
LOWER COURTS IN IN THE
APPELLATE COURTS SO THE SECOND
QUARTER BUT- ONLY. APPLY IN THE
SECOND CIRCUIT COURT. THAT IS
IT NEW YORK AREA BUT WHAT RENTS
FOR CALIFORNICUM IT THANKS IT'S
RULING SO THAT FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CANNOT WITHHOLD. THE
MONEY CAL. BECAUSE. HAVE A
CLASH IN RULINGS CHANCES ARE WE
WILL SEE THIS REACH THE SUPREME
COURT TO MAKE IT. ON WHETHER
NOT THE ADMINISTRATION FEDERAL
MINISTRATION COULD TRY TO
WITHHOLD SOME OF THOSE FUNDS
AND- OKAY THANK YOU BUT- THIS
IS A LARGER ISSUE THAT I'VE
BEEN HEARING A LOT OF FEEDBACK
FROM THE PEOPLE THAT I
REPRESENT ON. WHICH IS THAT.
LOTS OF OUR LOCAL OFFICIALS
FEEL LIKE THE CAUGHT THE
CROSSFIRE HERE BECAUSE WE'VE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS FILE
TO ME NOT AS OF LAST FALL'S
OVER SIXTY LAWSUIT-
PARTICIPATED ON A WHAT THE
CURRENT NUMBER SEVEN OUTLINES.
I PRESENT SEVEN CITIES AND A
YEAR OF MY CITY ARE SAYING HEY
LOOK YOU KNOW WE ARE IN A NET
TAX TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO GET OUR
FAIR SHARE OF THAT MONEY BACK
YET DID YOU GUYS KNOW THAT ALL
OF US. I'M SORRY BRING OUR
RELATIONSHIP. GOVERNMENT
BECAUSE- EVERY TIME WHICH OUR
EUROPE. AT ODDS THEM IF I. LOS
OR IN CORD AND IN YOU KNOW THIS
IS A NEED TO HAVE A BETTER.
WITH THE FOR. MINISTER NOT AWAY
REALLY. RESPOND TO THEIR
CRITICISM. THAT THE POINT THAT.
WE DO NEED TO HAVE A GOOD
RELATE. IN FACT. WE SPEAK. MY
AGING ARE. WORKING I. WITH THE
FBI. D. E. A. NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT PROJECTS. IF WE DO A
GREAT DEAL WORK WITH THEM
WHETHER IT'S- GOING AFTER.
HUMAN TRAFFICKERS. OR TAKING.
GANGS WHETHER THE- WE'RE DOING
ON. DRUG ENTERED. YOU DO THE-
FEDERAL. AND IT'S WORKING. A
VERY. AS WE ARE GOING TO SEND
YOU. LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
BECAUSE WANT YOU TO ENFORCEMENT
LAWS WITH US. AND WHAT WE'VE IS.
WITHOUT EVER. YOU HAVE EVERY IN
FOR IMMIGRATION LAWS THAT'S
VERY PART PRIVATE. BUT UNDER
THE TO THE MEMBER YOU CAN TELL
US DO YOUR FOR A- AND SO WILL
CONTINUE TO SAY. YOU DO
IMMIGRATION AND WE WON'T GET
YOUR WAY IT JUST EXPECT US TO
DO FOR. AND THAT'S WHAT WOULD
POOR BECAUSE WE'RE NOT WE'RE
NOT STOPPING THEM FROM DOING
THE WORK. WE JUST SAID YOU
CAN'T FORCES TO DO YOUR WORK
WITH YOU AND- AS WE GO THROUGH
THE PROCESS. I MEAN OUR OUR MEN
AND WOMEN WHO DO THIS WORK.
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT THEIR
COURT FIGHTS GOING ON AND ALL
THE REST. BUT I COULD TELL YOU
RIGHT NOW THE PARTNERSHIP THEY
HAVE WITH THE MEN AND WOMEN IN
LAW FORCED AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
THAT COULD DO THE STATE DAY IN
DAY OUT. AND THAT'S WHY WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO DO A NUMBER OF
GANG TAKE DOWNS BECAUSE THOSE
ARE MULTI JURISDICTIONAL
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL- THE
CANNABIS WORK WE DO THAT. DAILY
WITH OUR OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS-
AND THAT WON'T STOP AND I HOPE.%
I THINK ALL OF US WOULD HOPE
THAT WE COULD RESOLVE THE LEGAL
TENSIONS THAT. BUT I HAVE TO
FLY DEBATE. THAT'S BILLION
DOLLARS THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
TRY TO TAKE AWAY FROM AS THE
GOES DIRECTLY TO OUR- LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. THAT'S
BEEN A BIG HURT. WE PROVED IN
COURT THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
DID HAVE A RIGHT TO TAKE. MONEY
FROM US SURE. I WILL. CERTAINLY
THAT IS TRUE IN THE SENSE OF
COOPERATION FLOP PURSUANT
AGENTS. BUT WHAT WHAT I'M
TELLING YOU IS THAT. MY ELECTED
OFFICIALS FEEL LIKE. THEY'RE
VERY MUCH. OF BESIEGED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE- THEIR
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT GETS COLOR BY THE
THINGS THAT GET DONE HERE. AND
CHECK. ON THAT GOES WAY BEYOND.
JUST IMMIGRATION I'M- OCT ABOUT
THE FOR. WITH I LOST COVER WIDE
VARIETY TOP SO IF I JUST WANT
TO PASS ON THAT FEEDBACK BACK
YOU THAT YOU ARE THE MUCH FEEL.
THEY'RE REALLY WITH GOVERNMENT
ABILITY TO BRING THEM BACK TO
QUE IS BE IMPACTED BY THOSE TO
SAY BUT HEY I AM YOU FOR
DAUGHTER AT FARM ANALYST I. WE
TRY TO BE WHERE WE LOCAL
PARTNERS IT'S GOING ON RIGHT
THANK THANK YOU STONE.
GOVERNMENT REGARDLESS
ABSOLUTELY APPRECIATES. THE
FACT THAT YOU ARE STANDING UP
FOR CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIANS. AND WE CERTAINLY
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING. TO
BE THAT STRONG ADVOCATE AND
ENSURING THAT THAT OUR VALUES
ARE PROGRAMS. ARE BEING. OF
HELD IN AN APPROPRIATE WAY SO.
THAT I THINK YOU'RE DOING A
GREAT JOB IN THAT STANDPOINT A
WRECK. REALLY RECOGNIZING
CALIFORNIA'S VALUES OVER ALL
THE IF EN AB STONE IF I COULD
JUST COMMENT BRIEFLY- GO BACK
TO WIN. SO NUMBER. THE IT. IS
NOT QUE. WE DON'T REACH OUT TO
THE GOVERNMENT BEFORE WE SU IN
EVERY CASE WE ENGAGE IN
CONVERSATION WITH WHAT WE TRY
TO GET RESEARCH PUT IN RIGHT.
IS DEALING WITH FRANCE FOR A
LAW ENFORCEMENT WHETHER IT'S
BEEN THE CASE IS BARB INVOLVING
THE ENVIRONMENT- WE HAVE ALWAYS.
COMMUNICATED OUR CONCERNS TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BEFORE
WE TAKE AN ACTION FACT WE'RE
ALMOST REQUIRED TO BECAUSE MOST
OF THE ACTIONS ARE BASED ON
ADMINISTRATIVE ACTIONS BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. WHERE
THERE'S A LEGAL COMMENT PERIOD
AND SO WE REACHED OUT TO THEM
WE'VE ALSO DURING THE COMMENT
PERIOD PROVIDED OUR COMMENTS IN
WRITING SO IT'S NOT AS IF
WE'RE- WE'RE AT TRYING TO YOU
KNOW DO AN END RUN- BROADSIDE
ANYBODY THEY KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
OUR CONCERT. THEN IF THE- TIMES
THAT. CAN ACT AS WELL NOT BEEN
ABLE TO. IT'S FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. THAT PROTECTS THE
INTERESTS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ALTHOUGH THERE CAN
BE DISAGREEMENT ABOUT. WHICH
TRULY IN THE INTEREST OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I
RESPECT THAT BECAUSE-
ESPECIALLY FOLKS DON'T GET
INFORMATION. ON THESE CASES
THEY MAY NOT UNDERSTAND ALL THE
SUBTLETIES ESPECIALLY THE LEGAL
SUBTLETIES. OF THE CASE BUT WE
DO OUR BEST TO TRY TO BOTH IN.
FEDERAL OUR LOW. BECOMING DOWN.
LET'S SEE. ENGINE THE- THAT THE
WASHINGTON DC SENDING OUR WAY.
AND I- AN ABBEY WORK WITH YOU
FOR AWHILE AND I APPRECIATE NOT
ONLY A WORKING RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE LEGISLATURE- AND I.
COMMEND YOU ON COMING IN AND
HAVING SOME REALLY DIFFICULT
THINGS TO WORK ON- ONE OF
THINGS I WOULD. TO HELP YOU
WITH IF THE- INDIVIDUAL WORKED
IN THE MORTUARY INDUSTRY FOR
ABOUT TEN YEARS. AND HELP BUILD.
THE FORENSIC RELAPSE DAY HAS
BOTH THE MONEY IN THE CITY AND
CAL STATE LA. WHERE A LOT OF
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE LEARNING TO GO
INTO THE FORENSIC SCIENCE FROM
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES- I
CAN SEE HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN AND SO I WOULD
LOVE TO DISCUSS DO YOU. WHAT
DID IN LA SIR WE MIGHT BE ABLE
TO REPLICATE IT IN SACRAMENTO
BECAUSE THE VALUE. OF BRING IT
THE END. EDUCATE MODEL AND
THEIR HANDS REAPPLY EXPERIENCE.
I'M YOU YOU GET THAT IT. AND I
AB FIVE WHEN. SPOT FIRSTHAND-
REALLY IMPRESSED STUDENT BODY.
SOCOULD WORK TOGETHER TRY
CREATE. A GREAT MAY NOT WHAT
THE- DID YOU. THAT HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THE THING. TWO
MORE BOB I AND ALSO AND THE
RESIDENTS OF MY DISTRICT DID
DREAMERS AND WHAT YOU'RE DOING
THERE- AND RESOURCES THAT YOU
NEED HOPEFULLY I KNOW LAWSUIT.
JUST GO ON AND ON AND ON IN
HUGE YOU MAY HAVE TO DO A
ADJUSTMENTS TO GET MORE BUT I
THINK THIS IS ONE THAT'S REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT- REALLY
IMPORTANT A CALIFORNIA REALLY
IMPORTANT TO MY DISTRICT AND SO
WHAT RESOURCES DO YOU NEED TO
CONTINUE THAT. THAT DIALOGUE
AND BUT WITH THE COURT. AS YOU
KNOW WHAT WOULD IS IT'S THE
FUTURE. THIS FEATURE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE NEED TO STE
TO INVEST IN IT AND PROTECT
THEM- AND THEN- THE LAST THING
IS CANNABIS. WHAT I'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT HOW TO GET REALLY
THE ILLEGAL MARKET- I HAVE A
BILL WERE RIVER WE WANT TO
TAKE. FUNDING FOR WILL TAKE THE
PENALTIES FROM THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND TO MAYBE FIFTY
THOUSAND ON LANDLORDS. AND THEN
MAYBE USED TO LANDLORDS TO KICK
THESE PEOPLE OUT BECAUSE NOBODY
WANTS TO LOSE THEIR BUSINESS
AND MAYBE WE COULD WORK
TOGETHER. TO USE THAT IS AB
HOPEFULLY A VALUABLE TOOL TO
SHUT DOWN DALY CANNABIS AND IN
THE STATE LIKE IN A YOU KNOW A
LOT LA. IS MAYBE I CAN FORTY
FOUR LEGAL ONES IN OVER
FOURTEEN HUNDRED ILLEGAL ONES.
IT JUST NO WAY YOU CAN KEEP UP
WITH IT. BUT IF WE LAND. FORCED
HIM OUT BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT
THEIR BUILDING. ORGAN AND BEEN
BEING JUST PROPERTY OWNER
HONEST CAL. COULD BE. EFFECTIVE
AND HOPE. WE CAN WORK TOGETHER
TWO SIDED WITH THREE THINGS HI
ALL JUST COMMON. WE MATCH ON
THIS ON THE LAST ONE AND SAY-
WE'RE READY TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE IF THERE'S A IF THERE'S
A ROLE THAT WE COMPLY. AND I
WOULD ASK THAT WE INCLUDE. AS
WELL THE LAW. PARTNERSHIP HAVE
IT ALL LEVEL. NO THEY HAVE
SOME. VERY GOOD COUNSEL TO
PROVIDE AND THE LAW I KNOW THEY
WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE BE PART
OF ANY SOLUTIONS AND THEY'RE
GONNA BE THE ONE THAT ARE ASKED
TO RESPOND FIRST. THANK YEAH I
DID THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'M
JUST GOING BACK TO OUR- THE
DIALOGUE THAT YOU'VE BEEN
HAVING WITH FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
SO FROM WHAT I CAN SEE BETWEEN
FROM TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN TO
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE BILL
HAS BEEN ABOUT ROUGHLY TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEES AND
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH SUING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. SO. HOW
MANY MORE LAWSUITS ARE YOU
GONNA FILE AND HOW MUCH IS IT
GOING TO COST TAXPAYERS WHO SAW
HOW MANY MORE AT IT DEPENDS ON
MANY MORE TIMES THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S GONNA TRY TO DO
THAT WOULD BREAK OR THE
INTERESTS OF CALIFORNIA WHAT IT
COSTS WELL THANK YOU QUICK IDEA
THAT THOSE TWO LAWSUITS JAG
GRANT MONEY FOR LOCAL FORSMAN.
SAVES MILLION DOLLARS. I BUT IF
FOR A FOR A FACT A IT IS TWELVE
MILLION THAT'S A ONE FIFTH OF
THE COST OF TO THE LAWSUIT SAID
WE BEGIN WITH THAT I THINK
HOURS WOULD AGREE THAT IF WE
HAVE DECENT WITH THE CENSUS
THE- THAT. PERMITTED US TO GO
FOR WITH THAT. THE CITIZENSHIP
QUESTION ON THE SENSES COULD
SAVE US BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
YOUR QUESTION IS TO. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MISTER TRAJO JUST
WANTED TO FOLLOW UP ON FROM MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LAKE ELSINORE OR
QUESTIONS ROCK REGARDING CAPS
TO REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK- THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING ON
APPS I. SHARES THE SAME CONCERN
THAT IS REGARDING THE- WORK
THAT IS STILL PENDING CAN CAN
YOU GIVE US A SENSE OF HOW MANY.
IN THE DIFFERENT DEFINITIONS OF.
CASES ARE THE CASES THAT YOU
BELIEVE YOUHAVE THE ABILITY TO
CLEAR RIGHT NOT BUT THE ONES
THAT WITHOUT A STATE THAT THE
ONES THAT ARE FEDERAL
JURISDICTIONS NOT THE ONES
THAT. FOR LET ME TELL. HOW BIG
A NUMBERS ON THAT WOULD BE
SEVENTY SEVEN HUNDRED FORTY
SEVEN SO IT'S STILL SO STILL
FROM THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THE
LARGE THE MAJORITY OF NINE
THOUSAND THAT MY COLLEAGUE
REFERENCED SO TO ONE ISSUE THAT
WE TALKED TO YOU IN THE ISSUE
ARE ARE. BEING EQUAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT I. YOUR LAST YEAR
WE HAD. WHY NOT. A POTENTIALLY
INSTEAD OF TO TRY TO COMPETE
WITH LOCAL OFF OF PETITIONS WHY
NOT THANK YOU JUST DO A GRANT
PROGRAM WHICH GRANT MONEY TO
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT. THANK
YOU MISTER YOUR OFFICES ARE ARE
STATIONED HERE. IF WE WANT TO
GO TO LAKE ELSINORE TO GET
SOMEBODY'S GUNS THEY HAVE TO
FLY THERE RIGHT NOT FROM THERE
THEY'RE NOT ON THE GROUND- AND
IF THEY IN THE- THEY DON'T GET
THE- FLY BACK HERE. SO WHY NOT
GIVE IT. COUNTY OR THE CITY.
CAN WORK WITH THEM THE
RESOURCES TO ACTUALLY GO WHO
AND THEY'RE THEY'RE ALL DAY
LONG THAT'S WHERE THEY LIVE
THAT TO DETER PEOPLE THEY MAIN
WELL. WHY NOT. OR DOES IT THE
HUGE NUMBERS OF NOT HUGE
NUMBERS BUT THE LARGE SUMS OF
LOCAL LAW FOR THAT WE HAVE TO
REALLY- GO APPREHEND THESE
KINDS THAT WE THINK ARE THAT
PATENT THAT'S EXACTLY THE
GERMAN WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING AND
WE'VE BEEN. IS THE FIRST YEAR
WE HAD DONE A DEEP. IN THE
PROGRAM. ONE OF THE SUGGESTIONS
WE HAD WAS THAT WE ACTUALLY
START THE PARTNERSHIP UP WITH
OUR LOCAL LAW FORCED HER
PARTNERS. UP FORTY FIVE AGE
CAN'T COVER THE ENTIRE STATE
APPS THERE ARE THINKS SEVENTY
SEVEN BOB SWOPE. NOW YUP.
THAT'S THAT'S A BIG FORCE. TWO
THINGS WITH HAVE TO PROVIDE
THEM WITH RESOURCES UNDERSTOOD
RIGHT AND SECONDLY THE STILL
HAVE TO WORK WITH US BECAUSE-
EACH OF THOSE AGENTS. YOUR SIX
ONLY IN THEIR JURISDICTION. A
COUNTY SHERIFF CAN'T GO BEYOND
THE BORDERS OF THE COUNTY A
CITY POLICE DEPARTMENT KEPT
WILL BE ON THE BOARD SO SOON IS
THAT. ARM ARE PRETTY PRICES
THERE BUT- THEY CAN'T MATCH.
THEY HAVE TO CALL NEXT AGENCY
DASKA SO WE'D WE CAN WE CAN GO
ACROSS ALL THOSE JURISDICTIONAL
WHY. AND SO WE CAN PROVIDE THE
GLUE KEEP THE- THE WORK GOING
TOGETHER AT THE SAME TIME YOU
HAVE TO WORK UP THE CASE AT THE
BEGINNING. THE FIGURE OUT THIS
TO THAT IS ON THE- DO THEY LIVE
AT THE OLD DRESS HAVE BEEN
MOVED ON. ANY WEAPONS REGISTRY
YOU WORK ON. THAT OF COURSE YOU
START WITH THE FIELD WORK
PREPARING FOR THE FILL WORK TO
ACTUALLY GO OUT THERE TO- A CV
CAN APPREHEND THE WEAPON. AND
THEN IT'S THE RIVER. AFTER MUCH
BURKE OF FORTY AFTER. USED
LOCAL FORTUNE HASN'T BECAUSE A-
WIRED. KURD SO SOMETIMES WE
FELT WE ACTUALLY. WIELD THERE
WERE A- CHEN ON LIST WHO
APPARENTLY HAD BEEN WE WORK IT
UP GO OUT IN THE FIELD. PERSON
SAYS I TURN THAT INTO YEARS
AGO. AND WE'RE GOING TO FIND
OUT SURE ENOUGH THEY TURNED IT
IN IT'S IN THE- EVIDENCE LOCKER
OF THE LOCAL. LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY BUT THEY NEVER REPORTED
TO US SO IT'S MAKING SURE THAT
WE WORK UP THE CASE CORRECTLY.
MICHAEL SO THAT'S WHERE WE CAN
USE OUR PARTNER. THAT AND THEN
EVERYBODY THEN REPORT
AFTERWARDS THE RESULTS THIS WAY
OUR NUMBERS. ARE THEY THEY THEY
THEY CORRESPOND WELL. YOU LOOK
WE'RE WE'RE ALL- ALMOST AT WILL
I WILL I WILL SPEAK FOR MYSELF
I MEAN I'M I'M SUPPORTIVE OF
YOU CONTINUING TO. OKAY THIS
EFFORT BUT I THINK THE
SITUATION YOU DESCRIBED IS
THOSE FORTY ONE OF THOSE FORTY
FIVE AGENTS WOULD HAVE TO BE ON
THE GROUND. WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT I THINK THAT'S
WHERE. THE BOTTLENECK
ACCOUNTING BECAUSE AS YOU
MENTIONED. YEAH YOU JUST.
DIVIDE. SEVENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
FIVE FORTY FIVE AND IT'S A
FAIRLY. THE TICKET NUMBER LESS
ONE PERSON. THOUSAND GUNS STATE
OF SO I MEAN- HOW HOW DO YOU.
HOW DO WE GET THIS PROBLEM AND
YET STILL BE ABLE TO SCALE YOUR
FORTY FIVE. OFFICERS IN THE
SAME TIME BE ABLE TO LEVERAGE
LIKE YOU SAID THE SEVENTY
THOUSAND LOCAL OFFICERS THAT WE
HAVE. I THINK IF THE
LEGISLATURE THINKS OF APPS AS A
STATE WIDE PROGRAM. THAT
INVOLVES EVERYONE IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AS EVERYONE ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT KNOWS THAT THEY
HAVE A DUTY TO HELP RECOVER A
WEB. THEY'LL GET SOME RIGHT TO
THE DONE. THEN WHAT WE DO IS
TRY TO FIGURE TO COURTNEY
INNOCENT BY WAS NOT JUST LAW
ENFORCEMENT IF THE COURTS AS
WELL BECAUSE THE COURTS TO THE
ONE THAT ULTIMATELY CALLOUS
DISPERSED LONGER HAS. THE RIGHT
TO. AND SO WE- WERE NATIVE
BECAUSE IT IS FAR EASIER AS I
SAID EARLIER. TO RETRIEVE A
WEAPON. BEFORE THE PERSON GETS
LOOSE. AND ROAMS THE STATE.
THEN AFTERWARDS- THE BEST JOB
WE CAN DO IS AT. THE MOMENT THE
PERSON BECOMES. A NAME ON THE
APPS SYSTEM WE GET THE BEFORE
THEY GET LOOSE. SO IT'S MORE
MATTER COORDINATION THAT'S WHY
THINK WE ARE ENTERING A NEW.
STAGE WITHIN THE APPS PROGRAM.
I THINK FUN. AS MY COLLEAGUE
EARLIER MENTIONED. IN THE PAST.
POINT EN EN. APPROPRIATE THE
RESOURCES THAT WAS REQUESTED
AND IT WASN'T IT WASN'T WE NEED
TWENTY FOUR MILLION AND X. Y.
Z. WHICH IS WE NEED FOR MILLION
WE KIND OF ASSUME THAT WE WOULD
SEE- SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS MADE
ON THE BACKLOG I THINK THERE'S-
I THINK FRUSTRATION FROM THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY THAT WE'VE
DONE WE'VE DONE OUR PART. PORT
FOR DOESN'T. LIKE IT'S THE AS
MUCH PROGRESS AS WE HAD HOPED
AND SO I THINK THAT- I THINK
GOING TO STAND THERE NEEDS TO
BE. BETTER COORDINATION BUT
HERO I ITEM I DON'T KNOW THAT
MONEY BY ITSELF SOLVE THE
COORDINATION ISSUE THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ME YOU KNOW WE
CAN APPROPRIATE MONEY I CAN'T
FORCE PEOPLE TO PICK UP THE
PHONE OR GET A ROOM OR TO
DESIGN A PLAN- AND SORT OF.
WORKING ON THIS SEEMS LIKE YOU
KNOW WE- ALL THOUGHT THE SENSE
OF URGENCY THERE THERE IS NO. I
DON'T THIS IS A SINGLE PERSON
IN THE LEGISLATURE THAT AS
OPPOSED. TO INSURANCE YOU GET
THE ARE ADEQUATELY SAYS THAT-
LOCALLY GET THE ARE. AS WE'VE
SEEN A LITTLE BIT. ON THE AND
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WALL
WHEN DOES THE PUBLIC GET THEIR
GUTS. UP JIMMY BUT WHAT I WOULD
SAY IS AN ACT I CAN'T SPEAK FOR
MY PREDECESSORS IN THE WORK
THAT WAS DONE BUT THAT MONEY
THAT WAS ALLOCATED TWENTY
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN. I DO KNOW
THAT. IS WITH THE MONEY ONE WAS
IT WAS FOR THE- THERE'S JUST
WAY HIGHER. TO DO THIS WORK
WITH SO WHEN WE SAY SOME TO
SOMEONE YOU GETTING THIS JOB
FOR SIX MONTHS. YOU'RE NOT
GONNA PUT YOUR LIFE ON THE LINE
TO DO THIS FOR SIX MONTHS AND I
CAN GUARANTEE DO YOU JUST GET
TO STICK AROUND TO ONE OF THE
THINGS I NEED. TO BE THEN. THE
MONEY EVAPORATED IT WAS FOR
FIVE YEARS I BELIEVE SO IT BY
THE TIME I CAME IN IT WAS
ESSENTIALLY GONE- AND- I WANT
TO THANK YOU BECAUSE- WE
REQUESTED MONEY THIS LAST TIME
FOR áP. SECOND TELLS. IF YOU
ARE PERMANENTLY I CAN'T SEE
WHAT YOU WERE BUT I AT LEAST
KEEP YOU WANT PERMANENTLY
CANNOT NETWORK THE LOW TO YOU
POINT ASSEMBLY MEMBER I THINK
NOW LOCAL LAW SEE A FUTURE IN
AB FOR THEM. AND A MATTER OF.
THANK YOU IT A- THERE'S
ABSOLUTE NEED THOUSAND SWORN
PIECE OFF OUT IS OUT THEY CAN
DO WAY THAN FORTY FIVE AGENTS
AND IT'S MATTER OF SURE THAT WE
DO WE'RE ESSENTIALLY THE GLUE
YEAH THAT KEEPS EVERYONE
WORKING TO AND I THINK THE
SOONER WE GET TO THAT THE
BETTER OFF CAL. LOW. GREAT THE
BILL WITH. TO SEE. YOUR PROFITS
RIGHT I MEAN YOU'RE YOU'RE OFF
CAN TO BE ON THE CLOSE GOTTA BE
COORDINATOR FOR THE PROGRAM AND
I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE MORE
CONCERNED BECAUSE FOR WHATEVER
REASON HAS THE OP HASN'T REALLY
BEEN A TO. LEADERS WALLS
WITHOUT HI WOULD JUST TELL YOU
A WAS. IN TASK TASK TO GIVE. AT
OUR HIGH WILL ABOUT FIFTY EIGHT
THERE WAS NO WAY PLUS IN THE
TWENTY THIRD INTO. TWENTY I
SUSPECT EACH OF YOU COULD
PROBABLY NAME LEAST FOR DAY
LAWS THE YOU. THAT ACTUALLY
INCREASED IN OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
ON THE LIST. AND SO IT WASN'T
JUST THAT THE THAT LIST AT.
THERE I'M CATEGORIES WHO WHO
NOW FALLEN THE CAT INTO THIS
CLASS WHO THE RIGHT ACCESS WERE.
AND SOAK IT JUST. I THINK
ACKNOWLEDGE NOW I THINK
EVERYONE OF TO MAKE THE CSUS
WORK. AND PART OF IT IT'S ALL
OF A- NOT JUST LOCAL ON. THE
DIGITAL JERRY STILLER. IN IN
THEIR- SHE OR HER TEAM HAD MADE
SOME GOOD I THINK THAT'S
CONCERNING REMARKS REGARDING-
YO. DESPITE THE FACT THAT-
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WERE
GIVEN. THAT THERE SEEM TO BE A
REDUCTION IN THE EFFICIENCY OF
THOSE. INDIVIDUALS ARE JUST
WONDERING WHAT WHAT YOUR
THOUGHTS WERE ABOUT THE- SO.
AGAIN THIS WHICH I SORT OF
INHERITED THIS AGAIN- THIS IS
THAT WE'VE A MORE LONG TERM
ISSUE THAN EVEN APPS BECAUSE
WE'VE HAD THE- GAMING LAWS IN
PLACE FOR A LOT LONGER I'M I'M
TO BE HONEST WITH YOU. THEY
NEVER BEEN A AN AMBITIOUS THE
PAPER THIS AMBITIOUS EFFORT. TO
ENFORCE OUR GAMING LAWS IN THE
STATE. AND I THINK THE
STAKEHOLDERS KNOW THAT. I CAME
IN AND I TOLD ALL THE STICKLE.
FROM ALL PERSPECTIVES OF THIS.
AND SO HERE I'M TALKING TO BE
HONEST UP TO BE CLEAR WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT. THE CARD ROOM
OWNERS. INDIAN GAMING I SAID TO
THEM. I KNOW EVERYBODY'S BEEN
UNHAPPY WITH THE WAY IN FOR
SPENCE BEEN DONE. I'M GONNA
CHANGE THAT I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
LIKE OR NOT BUT I'M TO CHANGE
IT I NEED TO GET A NEW DIRECTOR
IN BECAUSE THERE WAS NO
DIRECTOR AND WE GET A NEW
DIRECTOR I GOT A NEW DIRECTORY.
WE'RE NOW MOVING FORWARD TO TRY
TO FORCE SOME PEOPLE LIKE SOME
PEOPLE HATE WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO BUT WHAT I WILL TELL YOU
THIS WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA
START DOING OVERSIGHT AND
ENFORCEMENT THAT'S WHY RECENTLY
WE WENT AFTER HAWAIIANS GARDEN
CASINO WE THEM THREE OVER THREE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR VIOLATING
THE GAMING LOST- WE GET IT THAT
EMERGENCY CLOSURE OF MEGA. SENA
WE FOUR CASES NOW PASS REPOSE
CASINO AND TINO MERS BILL ON
THEIR LICENSES AND WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO IS WE'RE GONNA START
TO ENFORCE. SO TELL ME WHAT
YOUR POINT WHAT I THINK WOULD
HAPPEN IS THAT WAS WE WENT WE
STILL THE RIGHT BEFORE THE
SINCE. ABOUT THE- NEW. AND WHAT.
DEVELOP AND THE THAN THE DEATH.
PRETTY MUCH DONE WITH THE BACK
BUT HE WHAT I TELL YOU WHAT ARE
MY STUMP BLOCK. WE WERE HAVING
ANALYST TO THE- OF IT MINISTRY
PERSONNEL BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH ADMINISTRATIVE PERSON OF
THAT THAT THE CLERKS THE CLERK
OF FOLKS. SO THE ALLIES WERE
THERE NOW SAYS AS MUCH AS THEY
SHOULD. YOU OF THE AUDITOR
REPORTS SO I TOLD BY TEAM
YOU'RE NOT GONNA HAVE SOMEONE
DO SOMEONE ELSE'S JOB DO YOUR
ANALYST DROP SO THAT THAT
THEY'RE DOING BUT BECAUSE YOU
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH.%
ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF I NOTICED
SUPERVISORS DOING THE WORK OF
SO WHEN IT'S IN SOME CASES FOR
CLASSES. CLASSIFICATIONS BELOW
THEM AND SO WE'VE AT RISK
REQUESTED DOLLARS FROM THE FROM
FUND THAT'S OF WHAT HAS NINETY
MILLION WE'VE REQUESTED FIVE
BILLION SO WE CAN ACTUALLY DO
THAT WORK BUT RATHER THAN JUST
WAIT TO THE LICENSE IS ABOUT TO
EXPIRE IN THERE NOW ASKING FOR
RENEWAL. THE CHECK. SINCE WE'RE
GONNA START CHECKING ALL THE
WAY. AND THIS WAY WE KEEP YOU
ON YOUR TOES ALL THE WAY
THROUGH THE PROCESS IN AT THE
SAME TIME WE'RE ALSO NOW DOING
REGULATIONS ON A NUMBER OF
ISSUES WHICH I SUSPECT YOU ALL
WILL HAVE TO DEAL WITH. BECAUSE
IT DEALS WITH WAY CAR I'M JOHN.
AND DEALER ROTATION ISSUE AND
ON WHETHER OR NOT THEY CAN KEEP
BE SO CALLED CROSS BANKING
BETWEEN. CASINOS THESE ARE ALL
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN AROUND
FOR A LONG TIME. SO MY
SUSPICION IS YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE- BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF. CHURNING
ABOUT. WHERE THIS WILL TAKE
THEM. AND QUITE HONESTLY I'M
LIMITED BY THE EXISTING
STATUTE. AND YOU ARE WILL BE
LIMITED UNTIL YOU MAKE CHANGES
TO THE STATUTES AND SO WE'RE
GOING TO DO. WE'RE SUPPOSED. TO
FIND OUT THERE TO TWO MILLION
DOLLARS. TO DO OVERSIGHT AND
ENFORCEMENT. WE'RE NOT GONNA.
BUT IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE
AUDITOR'S. FINDINGS I THINK
THAT'S WHERE THE CONCERNING
PART IS BECAUSE- ON IT FROM A
FROM A BUDGET COMMITTEE
STANDPOINT. IF WERE GIVING MORE
MONEY AND WE'RE SEEING LESS
EFFICIENCY. ARE SORT OF RAISES
A RED FLAG SOMEONE IF YOU COULD
JUST SPECIFICALLY COMMENT ON
THAT ONE CHICKEN FRIED YEAH AND
THAT I'M NOT I CAN. TO HAVE
THINGS WE HAD BEEN SENT TO THE
PAST. LAST YEAR I MENTION THE
NUMBERS I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
WERE HERE WHEN I MENTIONED
NUMBERS BUT- WE HAD. AT THE
TIME THE AUDIT THERE WERE. WHEN
THE- AND TWENTY NINE CASES THAT
WERE BACK. THAT WERE WAITING
FOR LICENSE. AND HAD NOT BEEN
PROCESSED- THAT WAS A YEAR AGO.
TODAY THAT NUMBER IS NOW DOWN
TO ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE. SO
WE CLEARED ALMOST ALL THAT BACK.
AND WE'RE DOING IT WITH THE AND
MY SUPERVISORS HAVING TO DO THE
WORK OF SOMEONE IS FOR THREE TO
FOUR CLASSIFICATIONS BELOW THEM
BECAUSE I'VE TOLD THEM YOU
DON'T USE ANALYST TO DO THAT
YOU USE ALICE TO START DOING
THE- THAT DOES IT FOR THE-
PROBLEM. A AND WHAT WE'RE
REQUESTING A MONEY IS A THAT WE
CAN FINALLY PUT MONEY INTO THE
AREAS WHERE WE NEED IT AND MIKE
MIKE MY COMMITMENT TO YOU IS IF
WE GET THE RESOURCE AB I WILL
SHOW YOU THE NUMBERS AND ADAM
BE TRANSPARENT WITH A NUMBER.
AND I HOPE. AGAIN AS WE DID.
YOUR SECOND SHOW YOU RESULTS
THE- OTHER ONE QUESTIONS MAKS.
COMPLETE SENSE TO ME THAT. THE
ENFORCEMENT. ARM OF THESE LAWS
IS IN YOUR AGENCY I WAS
WONDERING IF YOU HAD A SENSE OF
THE LICENSING PART OF IT
BECAUSE LICENSING TRADITIONALLY
WOULD BE SAY IN DCA WHEREAS YOU
KNOW JUST LIKE WE HAVE WITH
CANNABIS RIGHT THE ENFORCEMENT
PART IS IN YOUR AGENCY IT'S NOT
THAT'S NOT DCA BOTH ENFORCEMENT
BY SOMETHING. ARM WHICH WE YOUR
A HAS BOTH BEEN TAKEN AND IF
YOU HAVE THOUGHT TO WHAT THAT
THAT SHOULD BE SEPARATE OR
REMAIN TOGETHER- IT IT SEEMS
THE ONE AREA. WHERE HI YOU HAVE
BOTH. AND I JUST GIVE YOU
ANOTHER EXAMPLE WE'D TOTALLY
NON NON SEQUITUR BUT WE HAVE A
RECYCLING PROGRAM WHICH IS KIND
OF FAILING BECAUSE WE HAVE AN
AGENCY THAT DOES THE PROGRAM
BUT ALSO WAS IN CHARGE OF
ENFORCING THEN IN THAT OTHER
AGENCY WE ARE TAKING A HARD
LOOK WHAT AT THAT CONTINUES TO
MAKE SENSE. YET WE CAN. POINT
OUT A COUPLE OF OTHER. AND THAT
THE AREA OF. PROFESSIONAL
MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL LICENSING
THERE'S SOME ISSUES AND THERE'S
A MODEL THAT HE HASN'T TOTALLY
WORK- WHERE WE ARE INVOLVED
BECAUSE WE'RE THE ONES TO
PROSECUTE THE CASES ACT BUT
ANOTHER AGENCY ACTUALLY%
INVESTIGATIVE WORK AND TOO
OFTEN WE'RE FINDING THAT THE
SKIT WORK IS INCOMPLETE. AND WE
HAVE TO ASK NICKEL BACK BEFORE
WORK BETTER PROSECUTED CASE SO
AT THERE'S A VALUE IN HAVING
SOMEONE WHO COULD CONNECT ALL
THOSE. AND BY YOUR SITE AND THE
ENFORCEMENT CASE AND THIS IS A-
THIS IS A SENSITIVE AREA-
GAMBLING HAS TRACTORS AND A BAD
SUPPORTERS AND I MEET AT-
DETRACTORS AND WHAT I CAN TELL
YOU IS THAT I THINK IF SO LONG
AS- I CAN GET THE SHOP IN PLACE
WE HAVE THE PERSONNEL THAT WE
NEED. AND THAT YOU WILL. WITH
THE READ THIS. THAT AS LONG AS
I HAVE THIS WORK OUT WE WILL DO
RIGHT FROM A DIZZY AND WE WILL
PERFORM AND WE WILL SHOW YOU
THE NUMBERS AND HOPEFULLY
YOU'LL SEE THAT WE PERFORM IF
WE DON'T THEN CERTAINLY I THINK
YOU SHOULD. CONSIDER SOMETHING
ELSE BUT I WOULD HOPE YOU GIVE
US A CHANCE TO SHOW THAT WE CAN
PERFORM. OKAY BUT I'M SAYING
YOU MY FIRST YEAR I THINK IS
BUDGET CHAIR- WE GAVE THIRTY
TWO POSITIONS IT'S JUST PER THE
AUDITOR'S FINDINGS IN THE
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN FISCAL YEAR SO
THIS IS NOT AGAIN THE FIRST
TIME THAT THE DEPARTMENT AND
AGENCIES COMES AHEAD IT WAS
POSITIONS. THE MESSAGE WHICH
DAPSONE. IT A WEEK I DON'T
THINK WE PICKED. THE THIRTY TWO
POSITION THAT THE THAT THE
REQUEST OF THE- DEPARTMENT
LEAVE WITH A FEEL THAT REQUEST
I THINK THERE WAS A LOT OF
ENTHUSIASM KNOWING. THE BACKLOG
KNOWING- AGAIN THE WORK THAT
NEEDED TO BE THERE BUT THEN
AGAIN WHEN THE AUDITOR. FINDS A
LACK OF EFFICIENCY REGARDING A
PARTICULAR THOSE POSITIONS I
THINK THERE'S SOME CONCERN HAVE
FOR FUTURE POSITIONS IT IT IF I
HAD BEEN YOUR TWENTY FIFTEEN
TWENTY SIXTEEN. I'D BE RISK
ENDING AS BEST I COULD. NOT
HEAR THEN I LIKE IT'S HARD FOR
ME TO TELL YOU WHAT HAPPENED
THEN BOOK BUT I CAN DO IS
GERMANY'S. TELL YOU WHAT I WILL
MAKE SURE MY TEEN DIES AND ANY
PASTOR HAS DONE. AND I WOULD
HOPE THEN THAT YOU WOULD JUDGE
THE DEPARTMENT ARE OUR WORK. BY
WHAT WE'RE SAYING WE CAN DO I
WISH I COULD TELL YOU I COULD.
THIS IS A TO YOU WHAT HAPPENED
WITH APPS BACK IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN TWENTY FOURTEEN I
COULD TELL YOU WHAT. THEY WANT.
I CAN TELL. YOU RIGHT NOW. WITH
THE WHICH THERE WILL. WE CANNOT
YOU YOU. S. ATTACK HAD NOTHING
TO DO WITH GAME. AND AGAIN AN
AUDITOR REPORT CAME BACK AS IT
WAS A REAL TROUBLE. TO US TO DO.
STATION THE SEARCH. AND NOW NOT
ONLY RABBINIC UP WITH NEW RAGS
NOW WORLD DO INSPECTING THE LA
POLICE DEPARTMENT FOR SOME
REPORTS OF HOW THEY HAD
CONDUCTED THEMSELVES ALL I CAN
SAY IS THAT MY TEAM UNDERSTANDS
THAT WE GOT MARCHING OR WILL BE
THE BEST WE CAN AND I AM NO
PROBLEM WE CAN FORM. A STATE
GIVE IT TO SOMEBODY ELSE BUT
WHAT SO LONG AS WE GOT IT WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO THE BEST JOB WE
CAN. THANK YOU. OKAY ONE THANK
YOU- THANK ALL MY COLLEAGUES I
THINK PROBABLY THE QUESTIONS I
HAVE BEEN ANSWERED. I HOPE SO.
ONE OF ONE WANT TO THANK THE AG
I KNOW WHEN YOU COME- WE KEEP
YOU IN A LONG TIME ON HOW TO
SEE BECAUSE I DON'T SEE WHAT
ONCE A YEAR THAT'S OKAY THAT'S
ENOUGH. IT'S ENOUGH TO GET YOU
GOING FOR THE YEAR BUT UP
CLEARLY WE RAISE A NUMBER OF
ISSUES WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE THUS
FAR AND YOU HAVE SOMETIMES
INITIATED THINGS LIKE THE GATE
ISSUE THAT THAT THAT CAME OUT.
AND HAVE BEEN WORKING TO READ
TO BASICALLY ENFORCE MANY OF
THE REGULATIONS THAT WE HAVE.
WANT TO THANK YOU OBVIOUSLY FOR
THE DESCENT DISCRIMINATION QUE
THE CARD THAT THAT THE GAME
KATE THE CARD CALIFORNIA WE
OFTEN THINK ABOUT THAT THAT
THAT AREA IS. THE TO SEE IT WE
WILL IMPORTANT AND THE- SEE
SOME POP UPS FROM. FROM WHAT IT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN NUMBER. I.
CORD CLEARLY AYE AYE AYE WE ARE
ALL CONCERNED CAN SITUATION AS
BY SINCE BELIEVE THAT US NOW
BELIEVE CANNABIS IS GONNA SO
ALL THE FOR PROBLEMS OF THE
WORLD AND KIND OF LIKE THE
LOTTERY AND UP AND YOU KNOW
WE'RE ALWAYS LOOKING FOR THAT
MAGIC BRING THAT'S GONE SOLVE
EVERYTHING NOW WE- HAVING MORE.
PROBLEMS I AT ALL TO DO WITH
WITH WITH ALL THE LEGAL STUFF
I'VE I THINK SOMEONE'S WE MAY
WE SHOULD MAKE IT ALL THE LEGAL
AGAIN SO WE CAN STARTLED AND
THOUGH EVERYBODY OUT. AND START
A DIFFERENT WAY BUT- AB
HOPEFULLY THAT WILL HAPPEN AND
I KNOW WE'VE GOT A COMMISSION
IT'S GOT TO GET THE WORKING
THAT HASN'T WORKED YET. AND A
HOST OF OTHER THINGS IN ORDER
TO MAKE IT- THIS MAKES SENSE AT
THIS POINT BUT- AND I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF CONFUSION AND-
AND THAT HAPPENS WHEN THINGS
ARE. TO DO THE BALLOT AND DON'T
GIVE PEOPLE TIME TO. IMPLEMENT
AND- YOU KNOW BUT THAT'S OUR
FAULT BECAUSE WE SAW COMING AND
DIDN'T DOLE OF THINGS ANCE BUT-
PRAISE. UP I REALLY BELIEVE
THAT. THE WORK. STILL STUFF.
DONE ISSUE. YEAH PICKING UP THE
GUN AND THOSE THINGS THAT HAVE
BEEN PUT THERE WOULD BE NICE I
THINK FOR YOUR OFFICE TO PRY
GIVE US A REAL SO OF PROGRESS
AND YOU KNOW BECAUSE I HEAR
SEVEN THOUSAND BUT I ALSO HEARD
A NINE THOUSAND EARLIER AND
SOME OTHER EMBERS AND THEN
NUMBER COMING SO IT IF YOU.
THAT JACK WHAT WHERE HOW MUCH
WE DONE WHERE WILL WHAT NUMBER
WHERE WE NOW HOW MUCH WAS.
BASICALLY TAKEN OFF THE LIST SO
WE GET A SENSE OF PROGRESS
KNOWING THAT IF WE'RE FOR EVER-
TAKING PEOPLE'S GUNS AWAY. THAT
THERE WILL ALWAYS BE A LIST AND
LET'S WILL CONTINUE TO GROW.
AND SO I THINK MOST WAS WILL
FEEL LIKE THE LIST IS GROWING
WE UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR
GROWTH IN THE NUMBER. AND THE
STEM THOUSAND IS LISTED BUT- I
WOULD NOT KNOW WHETHER THE NINE
IN THE SEVEN TOGETHER. SIXTEEN
A WHAT WELL. IN WHERE WE ARE.
NICE IT ALSO THE WE GET SINCE
THE OKAY WE- GOT RID OF ALL THE-
AND WE- GOT ALMOST ALL THE
OTHER WAS DONE THEN SO- WOULD
BE HELPFUL BECAUSE AT. EVERY
YEAR I GET THE SAME WE GET THE
SAME QUESTIONS AND I'M NOT.
SURE MAYBE THERE'S SOME VITTLES
OR SOMETHING THAT WOULD HELP US
TO SEE WHAT'S COMING IN WHAT'S
GOING OUT. AND HOW MUCH
PROGRESS WE HAVE OR HAVE NOT
YET I THINK THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL. TO THOSE TWO SITTING
HERE. BUT THAT ONCE AGAIN THANK
YOU TEAM FOR BEING HERE- WILL
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THE OF THE-
REQUESTED TO HAVE. FOURTH AND
HOPEFULLY WILL. IN TWENTY
TWENTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. AFTER MY COULD DOES
A PRIEST ALL THE FIGHT YOU PUT
IN IN DEALING WITH WASHINGTON I
THINK SOMETIMES PEOPLE GET A
LITTLE WE GET CONCERNED BUT-
MOST OF MY FOLKS WOULD TELL YOU
FIGHT ALL. HERO BECAUSE THEY
FEEL VERY STRONGLY ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT IN THOSE KINDS OF
ISSUES THAT ARE THERE AND WE
ARE IN SOME DIFFICULT TIMES SO
I APPRECIATE. AND IT'S A
DELICATE THING TO ANOTHER TO
DEAL WITH AND- HOPEFULLY WE
WILL GET GET TO A POINT WHERE
WE DON'T HAVE SUCH CONTENTION
BETWEEN CALIFORNIAN THE REST OF
THE WORLD YOU KNOW. BUT I'M NOT
THAT OPTIMISTIC BUT THANK YOU
ANYWAY. OKAY I WANT TO THANK
THE- AG FOR BEING HERE- WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO OUR SECOND
ISSUE WHICH IS UPDATE ON CAL
GETTING REGISTRY. OF IT'S A
SECOND ITEM WE HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S ELLIE OLD
IT'S HERE. OKAY MADAM CHAIR ASM
STAFF FROM OUR DEPARTMENT JUST
AS THEY WILL PROVOKE SOME
DEPARTMENT JUST IS GOING TO BE
ON THE PANEL. AND LA ALL THOSE
OF THE TWO THAT HAVE A- TO DO
THIS AND SO WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO TALK ABOUT THE-
CARRYING. RETIREE HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CHRISTINE
SIGNED I'M A SPECIAL ASSISTANT
TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL- I HELP
OVERSEE HIS COUPLE JUSTICE
REFORM IN CIVIL RIGHTS. AGENDA
SO I'M HERE TO GIVE JUST A
BRIEF UPDATE ON CAL GOING OF
COURSE I'D BE HAPPY TO. ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE- SO OB I CAN NUMBER THIRTY
ONE. OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN-
THE DO YOU MAY ISSUE- REVISED
REGULATIONS ON CAL HANG UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. UP WITHIN. HAD
A SIXTEEN DAY PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD. UP THOSE RIGHT. ALL
REVIEWED BY THE- MINISTRY OF
LAW- IF THE- IT AWAY EL
APPROVES THOSE REGULATIONS-
THEIR SCHEDULE TO GO INTO
EFFECT. ON IN JULY TWENTY
TWENTY- SO THE REGULATIONS- IF
YOU'VE ALL HAD A CHANCE TO LOOK
AT THEM. TRY TO STRIKE THE
RIGHT BALANCE BETWEEN
LEGITIMATE NEEDS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND ALSO ON
STRENGTHENING. THE CRITERIA FOR
ENTRY INTO THE DATABASE AND
MAKING SURE THAT THERE IS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE- THERE
IS A MUCH MORE RIGOROUS. THREE
PONEN. THERE ARE ARE AUDIT
MECHANISMS A DIDN'T EXIST
BEFORE IN UNDER THE
REGULATIONS- DOJ IF IT FINDS
THAT. A LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
HAS NOT COMPLY WITH THE
REGULATIONS- THE DOJ HAS A
THREE RIGHT OF MEASURES THAT IT
CAN TAKE- ONE IS TO ISSUE A
LETTER UP AND THE OTHERS ARE
TO. SUSPEND OR REVOKE ACCESS TO
CAL KING. I SAW THAT YOU MADE
REFERENCE TO. THE DAY OF. OUR
LIVES THIS YEAR IT EVER A OF
ARE NOW THAT WE WERE CONDUCTING
A INDEPENDENT REVIEW OF THE
CASE. ENTRIES OF BY LAPD. GIVEN
THE ALLEGATIONS OF
FALSIFICATION OF RECORDS. ARE
WE I'M WEST PART PROCESS WE
HAVE BEEN IN. TUNE WITH. OF OUR-
IT'S STILL IN THE EARLY STAGES
BUT WE HAVE COMMITTED TO DOING
OUR OWN INDEPENDENT AUDIT-
SEPARATE AND APART FROM
WHATEVER LAPD IN THE POLICE
COMMISSIONER DOING- THAT WILL
INCLUDE NOT ONLY REVIEW OF
RECORDS FROM THE METRO
DIVISION- WHICH IS WHERE THESE
ALLEGATIONS AROSE FROM- BUT
OTHER PARTS OF LAPD AND WILL
INCLUDE REVIEW OF THE IN CAMERA
FOOTAGE- AT ARE THE STOCK. THE
ENTRIES INTO CAL GET- WE ARE
ALSO REVIEWING ALL OF THEIR
PROCEDURES AND POLICIES FOR-
HOW THEY ARE ADMINISTERING CAL
KING- WE HAVE A RIGHT I'M
OBSERVE TO THEIR RETRAINING OF
OFFICERS. IT OUT CAL- ONCE
REGULATIONS GOING TO AFFECT
THERE WILL BE A NEW ROUND OF
TRAINING AND SO WE WILL BE ABLE
TO. USE OUR OBSERVATIONS ABOUT
YOU KNOW WHAT WENT WELL WHAT
COULD HAVE BEEN IMPROVED THE
HELP- INFORM THOSE THOSE
TRAININGS AS WELL- OF COURSE-
THAT'S NOT- THAT'S NOT ALL THAT
WAS THAT WE MIGHT DO IF WE-
FIND OUT THROUGH OUR OWN. VIEW
OR WE HEAR FROM OR OR FROM THE
POLICE MISSION REALLY PD- WEEK
WE CAN WE WILL- TAKE ADDITIONAL
ACTION. ANY COMMENTS EMILIO
OKAY FINE ANY MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS. MANY QUESTIONS IN
INCOME QUESTIONS. I THE- OKAY
THANK YOU BOB ONE- WHAT FIRST I
WANT TO THANK YOU THE OFFICE
FOR TO OF FULL CONTINUE TO
FOLLOW UP WITH THE ISSUES DE
AND TERMS OF THE GANG OF THE
GANG LIST AND THE DATABASE
THAT'S THERE AND WHAT WHAT IS
DECIDED- CAN YOU. OF HOW MUCH%
HAS IT HAS TE LIST CHANGED
OVER THE YEARS- I MEAN- HAVE WE
ACTUALLY BEEN PURGING FOLKS
FROM THE LIST I GET SOME
INFORMATION FROM VARIOUS
SOURCES. SOME I'M CURIOUS IS
WHAT WE'LL SEEING AT THIS
OVERALL STATEWIDE LEVEL YEAH-
SO. FIRST OR IS A THE
REGULATIONS OF REPOSE ARE ARE
NOT YET INTO A FACT I DO
BELIEVE THAT ONCE THOSE
REGULATIONS ARE IN EFFECT THAT
WILL AFFECT- THE MEMBERSHIP OF
THE OF FOLKS IN THE BASE- I
WILL SAY THAT- BUT JUST. WITH
MOST CRITICS I'M AWARE OF IN
THE SAP TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN.
THERE ARE ABOUT EIGHTY THOUSAND
INDIVIDUAL AND THE DEBATE AND-
ABOUT THE ENTER PURGED FROM.
ABOUT TWENTY THOUSAND PURGED
EACH YEAR RIGHT TWENTY THE
ENTERED THE MEMBERSHIP CHANGES
BY AND NOT THAT I MEAN TWENTY
THOUSAND EITHER ENTER OR PURGED
AND TO STAND FOR OKAY OKAY SO
THE LIST REMAIN YEAH YEAH. I WE
WERE WE IN TERMS OF THE SOME OF
THE BILLS THAT WERE PASSED
THAT- SAID THAT PEOPLE HAD TO
BE NOTIFIED THAT THEY'RE ON THE
LIST AS SOMEONE DOING THAT BUT
IN ADDITION TO THAT THAT YOUNG
PARENTS HAD TO BE NOTIFIED AND
I KNOW IN ONE OF THE CLEARLY
CITY WOULD NOT GO TO FIVE. I AM
SO. UP TO NOT LOOK IS PLACED ON
THE LOCAL LAUNCH AGENCIES- I
DON'T HAVE ANY INFORMATION AT
THE TIP OF MY FINGER TIPS AS TO
WHETHER OF THE ELEAZAR ARE
COMPLYING WITH THOSE
NOTIFICATION OBLIGATIONS OF
COURSE- THE ALLEGATIONS AROUND
LAPD CAME OUT BECAUSE- IT WAS
NOTIFIED ABOUT. ON HER CHILD
SUSPECTED NOT SO WITH ANY
TOTALLY IN THAT STUDENTS THE
HOME THE NOTIFICATION
OBLIGATIONS WERE BEING COMPLIED
WITH. DO YOU HAVE A- OKAY I
WOULD ALSO ADD THAT IN THE IN
THE PROPOSED REGULATIONS THAT.
WE WILL WE WILL HAVE MUCH MORE
OVERSIGHT OVER ELLIE ETS
COMPLYING WITH THEIR
NOTIFICATION OBLIGATIONS. ONE
OF THE THINGS WE DID WAS WE
TOOK A OBVIOUSLY HE GANG GET
CAL GANGS OUT OF THE HANDS OF
LOCAL AND PUT IT INTO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. HAVE IT.
AND I'VE HEARD WE HAVE ANY.
NOTICE OF THE FACT THAT OUR
IDEA OF WHAT THE NET LOCALS ARE
STILL MAINTAINING THEIR OWN
LIST. AND I'M NOT AWARE OF THAT
HAPPENING OKAY THAT WAS A RUMOR
THAT OF MANY OF THE LOCAL STILL
HAVE THEIR OWN LIST AND AS THE
SCHOOL THEY DON'T SHARE IT
BEYOND THEIR JURISDICTION THEY
CAN KEEP THEIR OWN LIST. YEAH
I'D I'M NOT AWARE OF THAT OF
THAT HAPPENING- A I WAS AS YOU
WELL KNOW FOR AB NINETY PLIES
NOT ONLY TO CAL GANG BUT TO ALL
SHARED DATABASES INCLUDING
DATABASES AND WE HAVE
REGULATIONS AS AS RIGOROUS AS
THE REGULATIONS FOR AB FOR THE
ANY OTHER SHARED TO GAIN
DATABASE. NO SOME. THE PRESS IN
SIN EL AND I WAS VERY PLEASED
TO SEE YOU TAKING THE THAT THAT.
I WE CONTEMPLATING IT KIND OF.
ACTIONS AGAINST THOSE FOLKS WHO
FOUGHT WHO FABRICATED DATA THAT
WENT INTO THE GAME LIST. I MEAN
WHAT I KNOW IS THAT THAT IS
CERTAINLY BEING LOOKED AT- BY
THE LA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE MMHM- I ALSO
THAT- THE US ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
AS WE SPEND AND ACTED THAT
POSSIBILITY. SO I THINK WE WILL
KNOW WHERE TO SEE HAPPEN
WITHOUT THOSE EFFORTS BUT WE'RE
NOT CONSIDERING ANY ACCIDENTS
ARE AND NOT AT THIS TIME THE
WAY WE'RE IN COMMUNICATION.
OKAY OKAY. OKAY ANY OTHER
COMMENTS YES MISS JONES SAWYER
TONIGHT I WOULD LISTEN TO JUNE
I HAVE TALKED TO SEVERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT GROUPS. OF AND
OBVIOUSLY THEY DON'T WANT
ANYONE THAT'S- PREJUDICIAL TO
ANYONE OR ANY. AND BASICALLY
ANY BAD OFFICERS AND- I WAS
STRUCK BY YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT TRAINING MORE RETRAINING
AND- COULD SOME OF THIS BE AS A
RESULT OF THE POLICIES. THAT
WERE IMPLEMENTED. ARE WE
LOOKING AT THAT VERSUS WHAT WAS
TRULY IN YOUR HEART THAT
SOMEONE- TRULY WANTED TO PUT
SOMEONE ON A GANG LIST BUT THAT
SHOULDN'T BE ON THERE AS
OPPOSED TO BECAUSE OF THE
POLICIES IN A WAY ARE
STRUCTURED WITHIN US LAW MEANT.
GROUPTHAT THAT MORE YOU KNOW
WHAT HAPPENED OR COULD. IS THAT
WE BY REACH I MEAN IN AND
LOOKING THE- YES A RIGHT I
THINK YOU'RE THE VERY GOOD
POINT THAT NO SET OF POLICIES
OR REGULATIONS CAN PREVENT
PEOPLE FROM IF THEY REALLY WANT
TO BLATANTLY FIRE FALLS I
RECORDS YOU KNOW PUTTING
SOMEONE IN. AS A CAL GAME DAY.
ARE THE TRAINING OF. YOU KNOW
WHAT WILL THE STANDARDIZED
TRAINING THAT WOULD BE.
REQUIRED ONCE WE- ONCE
REGULATIONS ARE IN PLACE WILL
INCLUDE A COMPONENT ON. THE
IMPACT ON THE COMMUNITY AND
INDIVIDUALS BEING INCLUDED INTO
CAL GETTING SO. I THINK THAT
YOU KNOW TO THE EXTENT THAT
YOU'RE GETTING AT. IN THE
HEARTS AND MINDS. AS OPPOSED
POLICIES THAT THAT'S YEAH THAT
THAT WOULD BE ADDRESSED AS PART
OF THE TRAINING AROUND THE NEW
CAL GAME RAGS FIX OUR FOR
GOVERNMENT AND SOMETIMES. THE
PARTICULAR POLICY. WHICH
PROBABLY NOT GOOD. AND I FOLLOW
I HAD TO FOLLOW THE POLICY. AND
ENDED UP MAKING HUGE MISTAKES
AND AS OPPOSED TO WHAT I
PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE JUST DONE
WHICH WOULD HAVE BEEN OUT OF
POLICY PROBABLY GOT ME FIRED
BUT WOULD BEEN OUT OF POLICY-
AND SO I'M- JUST WONDERING
EFFORT WE'RE LOOKING AT. THE
POLICY. HAVE RABBIT. BUT
STATEMENT IS OR EVEN BECOME
PROBLEMATIC. IN A LAW
ENFORCEMENT GROUP MORE SO. THAN
MAYBE EVEN HEARTS AND MINDS
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I WAS
GETTING AT. RIGHT ONE LAST
THING UP YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
THINGS I THINK AS I STILL SEE
THIS HUGE NUMBER OF EIGHTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE ON THE LIST.
AND I'M NOT SURE IF THAT IS. A
GOOD REPRESENTATION OF ACTIVE
GANG MEMBERS AND CALIFORNIA THE
EIGHTY THOUSAND IT'S AN AWFUL
LOT OF PEOPLE ON A LIST. OF AND
SO I KNOW ONE OF OUR CONCERNS
WAS THAT WE JUST KEEP ADDING
PEOPLE TO THIS LAST OR YOU KNOW
FOR BECAUSE OF THE- VERY WEAK
STANDARDS THAT WE HAVE FOR
ADMISSION TO THE LIVE.
ADDITIONAL NOT CONSISTENTLY
**** QUESTION ARE THERE IN.
GROUPS OTHER THAN BLACK AND I'M
GROUPS THAT ARE ON THIS LIST
ARE THERE ANY SKINHEADS
CONSIDERED GANG MEMBERS ON THIS
LIST OF I KNOW OF ONE POINT
SOMEONE TOLD ME AND ON SENATOR
COUNTY SAID NO AND A LOT OF
THEM IN SAID COUNTY SO I'M JUST
KIND OF CURIOUS AS TO HAVE WE
DONE MUCH TO AT LEAST. BREAK
THIS SITE GANG MEMBER HAS BLACK.
BUT MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE
THE ALL WITHIN CAL GANG THERE
ARE MEMBERS OF WHITE
SUPREMACIST RIGHT SUPPORT THE
GROUPS THAT ARE THAT ARE
CLASSIFIED AS GANGS. OKAY WILL
BE INTERESTING TO KNOW THE
NUMBERS. IN TERMS OF THE
PERCENTAGE THIS THERE. YEAH IF
WE LOSE OVER REPRESENTED BUT IT
WOULD BE INTERESTING TO KNOW
THAT BECAUSE I KNOW THAT ARE IN
OUR OUR FOCUS ON ON GAINES IS
OFTEN BEEN THOSE TWO GROUPS AND
YET WE IGNORE A LOT OF THE
OTHER THINGS THAT RESULT IN
HATE CRIME. AND INJURY TO
PEOPLE THAT THAT. WE LOOK AT
JUST THE BEHAVIOR WITHOUT THE
FACES WOULD INDICATE THAT THIS
IS A KIND OF A- GANG MOB
MENTALITY. THAT IS EXISTING AND
YET WE DON'T REALLY HAVE. LEAST
MIGHT WHEN I ASKED MY FOLKS IN
SAN DIEGO THEY DON'T SEEM TO
HAVE A LIST. OF ALL OF THE
SKINHEADS AND OTHER INDIVIDUALS
LIKE THAT IN THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AREA. AND THEY MAY HAVE
A NO ONE NEED KNOW ABOUT IT BUT
THE HEY. THEY TO CLAIM THEY
DON'T HAVE ONE AND SO THAT'S
KIND OF A- A NARROW PERSPECTIVE
OF GANG ACTIVITY- ESPECIALLY
SINCE THOSE GANGS OFTENTIMES.
VIOLENCE AND THE KIND. OF THE
BEHAVIOR PRETTY. A DRAMATIC.
KAY THANK YOU WE HAVE A HEAR
PUBLIC COMMENTS OF FOLKS WITH A
CONCERNING THIS PARTICULAR
ITEM. ITEM TWO. LIST LIMIT YOU
TO ONE MINUTE TO A COMMENT TO
MAKE- ONE MINUTE. WE HAVE THREE
PEOPLE WHO DECIDED THIS. ONCE
WOULD FORM THE LIST. DON'T
PEOPLE PLEASE DON'T KEEP ADDING
TO THE LIST IF YOU WANT TO
SPEAK. ARE NOW IS YOUR MOMENT
TO GET IN LINE WE HAVE ONE
PERSON ANYONE ELSE. THIS HERE
TO CONCERNING THE GANG LIST.
ANYONE ELSE. IF YOU IN LINE AND
THAT THIS. OKAY THE LAST PERSON
I SEE IN LINE IS A GENTLEMAN
WITH A- WHY IT HAD ON. OR IS IT
THE BLACK CAT WHICH ONE WAIT AT
THE END ALL RIGHT WHITE THAT'S
THAT'S THAT'S THE LAST THIS THE
LAST PERSON IN THIS LINE OKAY
SO THOSE ARE THE FOLKS
LISTENING TO FOR ONE MINUTE
THANK YOU YES. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DAN AND I
AM HERE REPRESENTING THE PEOPLE
OF LA. I DON'T AGREE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA AGAIN DATABASE
BECAUSE IT IS JUST A WAY TO
TARGET PEOPLE PEOPLE. SIMPLY BY
THE WAY THEY LEAD THEY DRESS OR
WHERE THEY READ RECITE. COM WHY
DO YOU SEE HAVE THE FREE LEGAL
CLINIC ARE WE COAST EVERY
SECOND FOR SATURDAY OF THE
MONTH. AND WE HAVE HAD-
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE COMING AND
FOR MY COMMUNITY- ASKING TO BE
REMOVED AND HOW WE CAN HELP
THEM TO BE REMOVED FROM THIS
CAN BE BASS. AND WE HAVE HEARD
HUNDREDS OF STORIES OF HOW THIS
IS A FACT IN PEOPLE'S LIVES. I
WANT TO GIVE UP PERSONAL- STORY
FROM MY NEIGHBOR ARM HE WAS PUT
ON THE GAME DATA BASE WHEN HE
WAS ELEVEN- HE DIDN'T KNOW HE
WAS IN THE GANG DATABASE ON ONE
TIME HE WAS STOPPED. FOR A
TRAFFIC XIN THAT'S WHERE HE
FOUND EVERYTHING TOTALLY
ESCALATED. OUR IN. HERE HE HAD
NEVER COMMITTED ANY CRIME JUST
SIMPLY BECAUSE WHERE HE LIVED
ADAM THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF HOW
THE GAME DATABASE IS AFFECTING
PEOPLE'S LIVES THANK. WHO GOOD
AFTERNOON DOCTOR WEBER AND THE
COMMITTEE ON MY NAME'S KEN
MCGILL FROM YOUTH JUSTICE
COALITION WE WERE SPONSORS OF
SENATE BILL FOUR FIFTY EIGHT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO NINETY
EIGHT ASSEMBLY BILL NINETY AND
THE STATE AUDIT THAT REVEALED A
LOT OF THE INACCURACIES AND
PROBLEMS WITH THE DATABASE I
HAVE TO SAY AFTER WORKING WITH
DOCTOR WEAPON OTHER. TO CHECK
THIS IS YOUNG PEOPLE AND YOUNG
ADULTS ARE FIXING IN TERMS OF
GETTING OUT OF WERE AT A PLACE
NOW IS HUGE AS COALITION THAT
WE BELIEVE THE ENTIRE SHARE
DATABASE ESTAMOS WILL CAN AND
SHOULD BE SHUT. THE DEPARTMENT
OF ARGUE THAT THEY HAD HAD A
BALANCED APPROACH TO IT. THE
REGULATIONS BUT WE SAW
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE ENTIRE
PROCESS. THE COMMUNITY WOULD
COME IN WITH VALID CONCERNS.
THE REGULATIONS WOULD BE
SLIGHTLY ALTERED AND THEN BY
TIME LAW ENFORCEMENT HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH. THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. GET A
SENSE WOULD BE BACK. IN MOST OF
US HAVE- AGREED THAT NOW THE
RIGHT TIONS ARE EVEN WEAKER.
FOR AB NINETY WAS PASSED WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE
REGULATIONS PROCESS FOLLOW THE
SPIRIT OF THE LAW. WE URGE IF
THE DATABASE IS NOT MERELY SHUT
DOWN. THERE AT THE VERY LEAST
IT SHOULD BE TWO YEARS AND NOT
FROM. PURCHASE ALL THE- SUGGEST
THAT. WOULD LINK. PERCENT IS
GETTING INVOLVED IS INVOLVED.
IS BETWEEN ONE AND TWO YEARS.
THAT YOU HAVE TO REQUIRE
PROBABLE CAUSE FOR A STOP. NOT
REASONABLE SUSPICION WHICH IS
TOO WEAK OF A STANDARD. THAT WE
HAVE TO THAT THE DATABASE
CONTINUES TO BE VAGUE AN OVERLY
BROAD IN TERMS OF CRITERIA.
THAT ASSOCIATION- SCENE AND A
GANG- ADDRESS OR LOCATION. AND
SEEN WEARING GANG A TIRE OR
STYLE OF DRESS. TIED TO
SPECIFIC GANG IS TO BROUGHT. ON
THAT YOU HAVE TO ELIMINATE
GANG. HITS AS A CLASSIFICATION.
OF OVERLY BROAD AND BRINGS A
LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE- ARE NOT
GETTING INVOLVED. I'M SELF
ADMISSION IS SO OFTEN
INCRIMINATING AND RIDICULOUS
BECAUSE IT SOUNDS LIKE TO BE
THE MOST LOGICAL THING TO GO BY
BUT SO OFTEN PEOPLE ARE EITHER
TRYING TO CREATE A REPUTATION
OR COURSE IN THE SAME THING SO
I WOULD REQUIRE. ON THAT THAT
RIGHT TO BE LOOKED AT MORE
CLOSELY. ON THREE BEING
ARRESTED FOR AN OFFENSE
CONSISTENT WITH GANG ACTIVITY
IS ALSO INCLUDES THINGS THAT
MAY OR MAY NOT BE FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THE GANG BECAUSE-
THE STEP BACK HAS SO MANY
OFFENSES THAT. PRETTY MUCH
COVERS THE NOT NOT GOING TO SAY
COVERS THE WHOLE PENAL CODE BUT
IT'S A VERY EXTENSIVE LIST. SO
SHOULD COME WITH AN OFFICIAL
DOCUMENT YES OKAY WE'VE GOT ALL
YOU RENT DACIANS AND OTHERWISE
WE- WILL GET YOU WILL GET A
CHANCE TO TALK I APPRECIATE
THAT. THE LAST THING I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT THERE IS A
DECERTIFICATION FILM WITH WITH
LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR IF PEOPLE
PUT INCORRECT LANGUAGE IN QUITE
CLASSIFICATION THEY SHOULD BE
DECERTIFIED REMOVED FROM
OFFICE. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRIS RESPONSES WITH CHIRLA THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS. I THANK YOU FOR CHEN
DIES IN THIS ITEM WE ARE PROUD
SPONSOR OF AB NINETY AND HAVE
BEEN ENGAGED WITH THE DOJ
CONVERSATIONS. SENSE THE
PASSAGE OF AB NINETY WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED OF THE DIRECTION THAT
THE REGULATIONS CONTINUE TO GO
AND- SPECIFICALLY- WITH THE-
STATE'S SHARING IN FROM. OUR
NEIGHBORING STATES IF NEVADA
ARIZONA TO STATES THAT ANTI
IMMIGRANT. AND ALSO THAT ALLOW
THEIR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
COLLABORATE WITH ICE-
SPECIFICALLY A LOT OF THE
AGENCIES ARE. TWO EIGHTY SEVEN
G. CONTRACTS CITIES. MEANING
THERE LAW IN. SOME A OF. SO
OFTEN IN. IS TO BE APPREHENDED.
UNDER ONE OF THEIR AGENCIES.
THEY COULD. TAKE ANY. THAT'S
AND INSERTED INTO THE FEDERAL
RECORD WHICH WE GENTRY DE FROM.
CUPS FOR ICE HAVE INCREASED
SIGNIFICANTLY UNDER THIS
ADMINISTRATION. THAT MEANS THAT
IF AN INDIVIDUAL IS BEING
TARGETED AND BURN A JOINT
OPERATION- AND THAT TARGETS NOT
THERE. WHOEVER MIGHT BE AT THAT
HOUSE WILL BE PICKED UP BASED
ON IMMIGRATION STATUS. IT'S
UNCLEAR- WE HAVEN'T RECEIVED
ANY REPORTS FROM ANY OF THE
AGENCIES THAT HAVE DONE. JOINT
TASK FORCE ARE WITH- DHS OR
ICE. ABOUT ANY CLARA PICK UP SO
WE WOULD WANT TO ENSURE THAT.
THERE'S NO FEDERAL PICKUPS AND
ANY TIME. JOINT TASK FORCE.
THANK LAW. THE NEW. NAME IS
JOSEPH AND PARDEE JUST
COALITION. AND I GREW UP IN
FLOORS AND CRASH UP-
GRANDPARENTS HAD AS FAR ME
DONE. FLORA MEAN BROADWAY
SEVENTY THIRD STREET. AND MY
BROTHER HE WAS PUT IN THE GAME
DATABASE WHEN WAS TWELVE. AMONG
THEM DID NOT ELECTIONS SO SHE'S
SHE THOUGHT THE LAW FIRM WOULD
DO A BETTER SO. THE DEMAND JUNE
JUNE ALL. AND NOT THROUGH A
COUPLE MONTHS WHO. MONTHS LATER
HE GOT OUT HE WAS IN- GANG
DATABASE AS AN- ACTIVE GAME
EVER. RESULT SOLO WHO'S
PLAYING. ON BROADWAY SEVEN SIX
ACROSS THE STREET FROM. SIMS
SIX DIVISION AND JUST BEFORE. A
AND IS OPPOSE ME JUST BECAUSE
OF MY TYRONE MY SURE MY HAS AND
USE THE WAY PEAK. HE SAID AWAY
FROM WAS A GUN AND I JUST FOUND
OUT ONE. LOW BROTHER ASIDE
EIGHT VOICE WAS A GUN AWAY FROM.
HIS OUTGOING SO HE RUNS NAME HE
WHY LIVE YOU TO HIM. BEFORE
NORMAL BUT IT WAS LIKE THE
BEGIN ESSENTIAL JONAH HAAK
WOULD ON NO WE DO WRONG SO ON
ALLOWED THESE GANG DATABASES
HELPING THOSE. MY GRANDMA WAS
SIGNAL SCRATCH I'LL WAS AND SHE
SHE USED TO THE CAR LIKE. TWO
WEEKS LATER. SO JUST PLEASE
TELL ME HOW DOES HELP WAS GOOD
SEE NO NO NO HELP AT ALL AGES.
TURNS DOWN KEEPING IS LOCKED UP
AND- NOT BE ABLE TO TALK ABOUT
HOW WILL WE NEED AND WHAT WE
WANT THANK YOU SO THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON CHAIR MAN CHAIR
MEMBERS DENNIS CLOSE TOMORROW
WHAT THEY TELL YOU OF
CALIFORNIA JUST WANTED TO SHARE
OUR CONCERNS ABOUT THE-
DIRECTION OF THE RIGHT CURRENT
REGULATIONS. WE'VE CONSIDERED
WE CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THAT
THEIR- SOME OF THE LANGUAGES
OVER BROAD AND AMBIGUOUS IS TO
CONTAIN THE- INCLUSION UP. WHAT
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES IN
THIS DATABASE AND GOING TO
DIRECT A DIFFERENT DIRECTION
AND- THE LEGISLATION THAT THAT
AUTHORED THIS MEANT FOR THE
REGULATIONS AGO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON UP
ARBOR HECTOR SANCHEZ FLOOD IS
WITH THE NATIONAL COMPETITORS
NETWORK MEMBER THE NATIONAL
FEEL LEADERS ALLIANCE FOR BOYS
TO MEN OF COLOR HERE IT IS
SIMPLY SAY THAT. YOU NOT SPEAK
ON A PROFESSIONAL LEVEL OF WHY
THESE GANG DATABASES ARE.
DETRIMENTAL TO OUR COMMUNITIES
BUT AS A FATHER AND AS AN UNCLE
I ALWAYS THINK ABOUT HOW OTHER
PEOPLE YOU. THOSE CHILDREN THAT
ARE ATTACHED TO ME WHETHER BY
BLOOD OR BY AFFILIATION CAN
SHIP. AND I SIMPLY EIGHT EIGHT
Q. ABOUT THOSE CHILDREN. SEATED
AND WHAT LED YOU VIEW THEM-THROUGH. AND NOT LONG FOR SPENT.
CAN VIEWING THROUGH LENS AND SO
I INVITE YOU TO THINK ABOUT IT
NOT JUST FROM A LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. FROM A PARENT PARENTAL
PROCESS AN UNCLE OR ON TV. OR A
GRANDPARENT. AND THINK ABOUT
HOW IT IS THAT WE CAN PUT
CHILDREN ON DATABASES
FORGETTING AFFILIATION. PLACER
DATA BE SAID SAY THERE
EXCELLING IN SCHOOL. AND
THRIVING AND CONTRIBUTING TO
THEIR COMMUNITY SO LET'S TAKE A
BALANCED APPROACH IN OUR
COMMUNITY SAID MACOMB SAFE AND
ALLOW THE CHILDREN TO THRIVE.
THANK YOU. HI MY NAME THAT THE
ROAD IS IT JUST OF COALITION A
LITTLE UNDER THE WEATHER IS
ALWAYS KIND ALBUM. YEAH
SELECTED BUT AGAIN DATABASE-
ABOUT TEN YEARS AGO THERE ARE
SEVENTEEN VOTE I WAS. PULLED
OVER AND PUT IN THE BACK OF A
POLICE CAR AS THEY RAN MY NAME
UP FROM IT. WATCHING IT PULLED
UP I'LL OPEN THE COMPUTER AND
CAR AND NOTED THE SAID- GANG
ASSOCIATE ON RAMBLED LETTERS.
IN THE FILES SO THAT'S WHEN I
REALIZED IT PUT ME ON AGAIN
DATABASE AND HAD NO KNOWLEDGE
PRIOR TO IT. AND I STARTED
REALIZING WHILE WAS CONSTANTLY
STOP IN IN FRIST IN SEARCH.
MANY THOUGHT. EVERY DAY I WOULD
GETS UP FROM. AND EVERY. THAT
THIS IS WHY THAT THE HAD BEEN
SUSPECTED OF BEING A GANG
MEMBER. AND ELDER IN THE AB
NINETY PER DOES THE COOKING
WOULD VISOR COMMITTEE PAUSES WE
REPEATEDLY TOLD BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT. THE GAME
DATABASE JUST ASSEMBLY
APPOINTED SYSTEM. TO USE FOR
CRIME AND GAUGE AND- LITERALLY
IN THAT MEETING A FEW MINUTES
LATER THE SAME LOW VOICE OF
FEAR. SAID WELL YOU KNOW WHEN
WE SEE IT. IN WITH.
NEIGHBORHOOD THEN. TING IN
CLOSE. TO BE GETTING. IN THE IN
THE IN GAME THAT'S WILL PUT ON
THE- ON THE- AND AGAIN DOT.
WHAT HE DESCRIBED ACTUALLY
SURVEILLANCE IT'S NOT JUST USES
APPOINTED COMMITTEES AS IF A
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM OF.
BLOCKING YUP BUT PEOPLE- AND SO
JUST ON MARCH TWENTY FOURTH WE
WILL BE SPEAKING AT THE ALLEY.
AT THE ALLEY. BE THE MAN I'M
WITH OTHER. FROM COST SITTING
ARE GONNA BE AN END TO THE USE
OF GETTING DATABASES FROM LAPD
ON WHICH WE DON'T WHICH A LOT
OF DEPARTMENTS ALREADY STOP
STARTING TO NOT USE IT ANYWAY
SO IT'S NOT A CRAZY. INFO JUST
HOPE IT GOES THROUGH WE HOPE
THAT WE CAN STOP USING AT THE
ONE AT THE VERY. THE RIGHT
WINDOW THANK. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS MANUEL LAFONTAINE AND
I'M A CO FOUNDING MEMBER WALLIS
TO DONE I'M ALSO A STAFF AT THE
W. HEY WOULD BRIDGE INSTITUTE
AND MY CONCERN IS IN TWENTY
TWENTY WE'RE STILL USING
LANGUAGE VERY DEHUMANIZING.
RIGHT IF WE LOOK AT THE TERM
GANG. IS IT LOOK IT RISES TO
THREE MORE PEOPLE INVOLVING A
CONDUCTIVITY TOWARD A COMMON
GOAL RIGHT THAT COULD BE A LOT
OF PEOPLE BUT WHEN YOU CODIFIED
INTO LAW ON TWENTY SIX POINT
TWO. THEN IT MAKES IT YOUNG PER
COPY THE SYSTEM THE- WE'RE
GONNA ON A TEN GAME BECAUSE AS
AGAIN. YOU CAN KILL GANG MEMBER
IN KILL FORMER GAMBAR YOU CAN
ALLEGE GANG MEMBER IS HOW TO
KILL SON. IT'S HARD TO KILL
NEPHEW. TO GIVE A GRAND CHILD
IT'S HARD TO REMEMBER THE MOST
ENVIRONMENT AND A SOMEONE ELSE
THE BIBLE THREE ORGANIZATIONS
AND PRESERVATION THAN NOW. AND
COMMITTED TO. POLITICS IN A
DIFFERENT WAY TO MOST PEOPLE
ARE IN THE UNITED STATES I WANT
TO CHALLENGE THE USE OF
LANGUAGE. AND WAS THE FIRST
COPPER PEOPLE HERE ATTY. TO
BETTER BE RIGHT NOW. THE BASE A
SYMPTOM OF A PER. PAUSES
SOMETIME WE HAVE IN A PART TIME
LOOKING AT THE ROOT CAUSES SUCH
AS CAPITALISM OR THE INABILITY
FOR MEDICAL SURVIVE WANTS TO
DONE TIME AND SINCE STEPS
COMMUNITY PEOPLE FACE BEHIND IT
CAN OCCUR SO WE DON'T GET FULL
DIRECTLY INVOLVE THE BEEN
MISTER HIS EIGHT. PEOPLE CALL
GET TO FIGURE OUT REAL FAST WE
SHOULD LOOK INTO TO REVISIT
THIS AND A LOT OF PEOPLE MAKING
MONEY OFF THIS WHAT THE YOUNG
BULL. ARE BEING. PROFILE TO BE
TO THE- HUMANS. SINCE THE
COUNTRY WE COGNITIVE. THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S- THEY'VE I WAS AT
THE CON BELLY DE BURKE SANDALS
A CALIFORNIA SANTA CLARA COUNTY
AS A CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM
ORGAN AND WE'VE BEEN A
CONTRIBUTING TO RESOLVE IT CAL
GAIN CRITERIA ISSUE FOR THE
PAST COUPLE OF YEARS. THIS
POINT IS JUST SILLY TO MAKE
SENSE OUT OF A CRACK IN THE
SYSTEM THAT JUST DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE. DURING THE LAST AUDIT
OVER HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
CHILDREN AND ADULTS WERE
ALLEGHENY. SIXTY FIVE IN OUR
LHASA ALTHOUGH. IT WAS. WERE
SENATE BY 62% COMPARED ONLY
MAKES PERCENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
POWER I ELEVEN THOUSAND IN CDC
SERVER US WITH THE GANG
ENHANCEMENT 68% ARE ASA 24%
WERE BLACK. ATTORNEY GENERAL
ANNOUNCED INDEPENDENT REVIEW OF
THE LAPD'S CAL GANG AS SAID
OTHERS OF FALSE OR INACCURATE
DATA CONTAMINATE SIT WHOLLY
RELIANT ON THE INTEGRITY OF
SUCH DATA SAM'S A SCHOOL
DISTRICT DISTRICT ATTORNEY
CHESS ABOUT BEING- COMMIT ANY
RACIAL. PROP PROSECUTION STOP
CHARGING GANG ENHANCEMENTS
CONDIMENT VIEWS OF RACISM. YES
SAID CAL HANG AND HOW RELEASED
A GANG ENHANCEMENTS CAN'T BE
DENIED I CAN'T BE DENIED HOW IT
RELATES TO MASS IN COSTA. I
DOUBT. BOB CAL KING I GOT A
BASE THEN. RUN A VIRUS OF OUR-
IN PRINCIPLE JUST SYSTEM SO
CALLED THE BURKE IS COMPLETELY
AGAINST GANG AND NOT TYPE CRY.
AND FEEL THE SAME THING ABOUT
THE GANG ENHANCE BECAUSE
BECAUSE WITHOUT ANSWERS THERE
REALLY IS NO REASON TO HAVE A
CAL GAME DATABASE OR ANY TYPE
OF DATA. THANK YOU. HI DONNA MY
NAME IS JAKE OBJECTION FROM THE
YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION. HOME
AND I'M FROM THE CONSOLE
DISTRICT TO. GOING OF LOS
ANGELES ALSO ON. A MOSTLY
BECAUSE I GOT TIRED TO AND YOU
FOR ME I JUST LIKE THIS BECAUSE
OF FROM THE CHRIS ON DISTRICT
MOMENTUM STORY. LOS ANGELES
POLICE STOP. BEFORE I WAS BORN
MY BROTHER BE STARTING WHEN I
BEFORE. ONE TRAUMATIZING THE.
WITH IT BEING SHE WAS VERY TO
HAVE THINGS TO. IN BECAME HIGH
ALERT FROM MY STATE THE GONNA
MY COMMUNITY. I LIVE IN AN
ONGOING AREA BUT SCHEMES TO
NEVER BANG STILL I'M SEEN BY
THE THIS IS A THREAT ALWAYS
GONNA STOP. PATTED DOWN HEAD TO
TOE FIRST CAME OUT. THE FIRST
QUESTION WHERE'S THE GUN AT
WHERE YOU FROM. AND THE STARS
NICE. MANY PEOPLE FROM THE
NEIGHBOR. NOW WHAT I KNOW. THEM
THIS THIS MAKES ME ANOTHER
BLACK AND BROWN HOUSTON I KNOW
IN MY COMMUNITY FEEL AFRAID
NERVOUS AND ANXIOUS ON WHAT DO
AND SAYING. I'M AND WHEN WITH
TO DOING WHAT TO SAY WHEN I'M
GETTING STOPPED BY POLICE IN MY
EXPERIENCE WAS GONNA OVER. ME
TIMES THEY HAD THE GUNS DOT.
THANK YOU VERY. THIS IS WHY.
THE LIP AND LIMóN A ALL THE
CAL GAME DATABASE AND ALL THE
SIR DATABASE THAT FEED INTO IT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. OKAY I
WANT TO THANK YOU DID COME TO
A- SHARE THE INFORMATION- AND
CLEAR WE ARE A- WAYS OFF AND WE
WANT TO BE WITH WITH. THIS LIST
AND IT. AND THE NUMBERS THAT
BENNETT AT THE NOT IT'S
ACCURATE AND WHETHER THAT IS
USED FOR THE PURPOSE SAID IT
WILL DESIGN FOR RATHER THAN UP.
WE DISCOVER. US OUR- COMING UP
I AWARE BUT THEY'VE BEEN IN
CONVERSATION WITH. EIGHTY ABOUT
IT SO WELL SINCE WE KNOW IT CAN
PROGRESS I WANT. THOSE OF YOU
WHO'VE BEEN ATTENDING THE
MEETINGS AND PROVIDING THE
INFORMATION AND SHARE THE DATE
THAT THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE
I REALLY APPRECIATE IT. IT'S
YOUR EYES AND EARS THAT THERE
THAT ARE VERY CRITICAL AND
IMPORTANT TO. IN PARTICULAR
THAT THE- THE- IF YOUR
PERSPECTIVE AND I AND I CAN YOU
TO WORK ON THIS LIST. TO MAKE
SURE THAT IF THERE IS A LIST IT
HAS TO BE THE KIND OF LIST THAT
WE THINK. IS HELPFUL. THING
THAT I'M FALL AND HURT. A IN
OUR COMMUNITY SO ONCE AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME
JUST TO COME AND SHARE. THAT
WITH ME AND GIVING ME THE
INFORMATION AND DATA THAT WE
NEED. OKAY ONE OF. THESE
OFFICER COMING. HERE I DON'T
KNOW IF AT THIS DOCUMENT. HOPE
YOU ISSUE DOCUMENT WITH THE
AG'S OFFICE AS WE CONTINUE TO
DEAL WITH ISSUES OF REGULATION.
AND THOSE THINGS THAT ARE THERE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. IT'S MOVING
NOW TO THE ITEM THREE. OF WHICH
IS THE OUT OF THE BUREAU OF
GAMBLING AND ASSOCIATED BUDGET
CHANGE PROGRAM THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE TE STATE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. A STATE
AUDITOR'S WANTS TO GO FIRST
OKAY ON ISSUE ITEM NUMBER THREE.
TO GET A CHANCE WE SHOULD HAVE
ANOTHER TWO YEARS SOMEONE. TWO
FOUR. OKAY. GOOD AFTERNOON NOT
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS MARK RUN OR DO WITH
THE STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE I
WAS THE SUPERVISOR ON THE
TEANECK UP TO THE AUDIT
RELEASED IN MAY LAST YEAR I'VE
BEEN OUT TODAY TO PROVIDE BRIEF
REMARKS THE KEY OF OUR OP AT.
BUREAU CAMPING CONTROL AS WELL
AS AN UPDATE ON THE
RECOMMENDATION STATUS. AND
FINALLY IN THE CONTEXT OF THOSE
TWO THINGS- A SUMMARY OF OUR
OUR BRIEF REVIEW OF THE- BUDGET
ITEMS BEFORE YOU HERE TODAY SO.
ARE FOR WITH ISSUED IN MAY OF
LAST. AMONG OTHER THINGS THE
UNIFIED ISSUE WITH THE-
EFFICIENCY AND EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE LICENSING REVIEW PROCESS.
FOR GAMBLING APPLICANTS. HE
GAME. ROLL PACIFIC WE FIGHT
THAT THE- HAD NOT. MADE
EFFICIENT USE OF THE TWO. TERM
POSITIONS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAD PROVIDED IT. IN ORDER TO
CLEAR A BACKLOG IN TERMS OF THE
NUMBER THE CASE PROCESS PER
FULL TIME. MY SINCE ISSUE. THE
FISH DECLINED EACH YEAR. THIS
CLEARS FOURTEEN FIFTEEN AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN I A
RESULT OF THOSE EFFICIENCY
PROBLEMS ARE WE DETERMINED THAT
IT HAD MADE ONLY LIMITED
PROGRESS IN CLEARING ITS BACK
OF APPLICATIONS. WHICH PAINT AT
ABOUT ONE THOUSAND
APPLICATIONS. I'M OF OUR IF YOU.
IN TERMS OF THE COST IS FOR
SHOES WE FOUND OUT FLAWS AND
INCONSISTENCIES IN THE GIRLS
LICENSING PROCESS THESE ARE
THESE INCLUDE INEFFICIENCIES
AND HOW THEY PROCESS INCOMING
APPLICATIONS. ARE INCONSISTENT
PROCEDURES FOR VARIOUS TYPES OF
LICENSE APPLICANTS AND SOME
FLOOD OVERSIGHT OF SYNCING
STAFF SPEND THEIR TIME. AND OF
THE MANDATE WE MADE THE- AT SIX
MY AND KERN AS OF TODAY THE
BILL HAS MADE PROGRESS IN
IMPLEMENTING SOME OF OUR KEY
RECOMMENDATIONS SPECIFICALLY IT
HAS FULLY OR PARTIALLY IN. NINE
OF THE THIRTEEN RECOMMENDATION.
I DO A COPY AT THAT BY SAYING.
SOME OF THESE CHANGES THAT THE
BUREAU HAS MADE SOME THE
INTERVENTIONS ARE QUITE RECENT.
BRIGUS PULL IT UP. SOME
LICENSING PROCESS. IT'S TIME
OUR TIME REPORTING OVER
PROCEDURES AS RECENTLY AS A
PERSON EXCUSE ME AS RECENTLY AS
LATE OCTOBER OF TWENTY
NINETEEN. AND AS A- NOT
SUFFICIENT TIME TO A- AN
MEASURE THE AFFECT EFFICIENCY
GAINS THAT DOESN'T BUT THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE INTENDED
TO ACHIEVE. IN TERMS OF THE
TIMES BEFORE YOU TODAY.
STARTING WITH THE REGULATORY-
ITEM FIRST ALTHOUGH THAT ITEM
MENTIONS RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
THE AUDITOR'S OFFICE AND ITS
JUSTIFICATION. THE SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS IN QUESTION ARE
NOT MENTIONED THROUGHOUT THE
BODY OF THE ANALYSIS OF THE
PROPOSAL AND SO I'M UNABLE TO
SPEAK TO TYPICALLY WHICH
RECOMMENDATION. ARE THE
DEPARTMENT IS IT AS SIMPLE WITH
THOSE POSITIONS ARMED. WITH
RESPECT TO THE OTHER ITEM THE
LINK TO OUR SOME OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT THE
EFFICIENCY OF THE PROCESS ARE
MORE AND MORE CLEAR I'M HOWEVER
I WOULD MAKE TWO ONE IS THAT.
THE ACT THAT THE HAS IDENTIFIED
FOR THESE NEW POSITIONS IN TERM
INTAKE OUR ACTIVITIES THAT WERE
ALREADY IN PLACE TIME OF OUR
IF. NOT MANDATE. THE NOT FROM
WHAT TIME BRING IN. AND TIME
NOT IMMEDIATELY APPARENT TO US
WHY IMPLEMENTING A DRUG. WERE
NECESSARY INC INCLUDING THAT
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF STAFF
AT THE AT THE FEAR OF. THE
OTHER THING THAT I. JUST LIKE
TO REITERATE THAT- ALTHOUGH THE
BUREAU HAS MADE PROGRESS IN
SOME OF OUR RECOMMENDATIONS.
SOME OF THOSE PROCESSES ARE
ONGOING. BEING A TIME STUDY.
STUDY THAT WE DIRECTED THE
BUREAU TO PARTICIPATING IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE GAMING
CONTROL COMMISSION TO REALLY
ASSESS HOW IT'S- IN THEIR TIME
HOW MUCH THAT'S GOING TO COST
LONG TERM. AND HOW TO INSERT AS
HOW TO SET UP THINGS LIKE-
APPLICATION- DEPOSIT RATES
GOING FOR WHICH IS A SEPARATE
ISSUE BUT- ALL BEING SAID. IT
APPEARS TO US THAT. ORTON ABOUT
IN INCREASING EFFICIENCY GOING
ON RIGHT NOW THE BUREAU SO.
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. NOTHING CERTAINLY
SEVEN. ONE HI MY NAME'S. THANK
MEMBERS. THANK YOU YEP SHOULD
BE ON YOUR OKAY BEYOND THAT HI
MY NAME IS STEPHANIE SMILES I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF THE BUREAU
FAMILY CONTROL- THINK THE OUTER
IN BRINGING UP YOU KNOW THE
UPDATE WE ARE VERY PROUD WE OF
FULLY MEND HIS OF THOSE RIGHT
STATIONS YOU HAVE MADE A WE
WERE DILIGENTLY TO. TIGHTEN UP
ALL FEATURES TO MAKE SURE WE
ARE MORE EFFICIENT AT THE ISSUE
THE ARM ON RIGHT TOWARD TENSION
I'M. JUST TO COMMENT. REALLY
THE ON THE B. C. PIECE THAT WE
HAVE BEFORE YOU- IN THE AUDIT
THE STATE OUT OF RECOMMENDED
THE BTC ANALYZE ITS
INVESTIGATION PROCESSES AND
IMPLEMENT PROCEDURAL CHANGES TO
IMPROVE ITS TIMELINESS AND
PROCESSING UP. SO LATE THEY HAD
REALLY CONNECTION WITH
SOMETHING SAYS AND WE DID I'M-
LOOK AT THE RECORD. IN POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES. WITH RESPECT TO
THE SIXTEENTH SECTION. BUT TO
BE CLEAR THE LIGHTS PROCESS
ISN'T SOLELY ON THE BILL THE
LIGHTS SUCH THAT THEY DO
COORDINATE AND WORK EVERY DAY
WITH IN THE VISUALS OF THE
COMPLAINTS ENFORCEMENT SECTION
AS WELL AS THE AUDIT SECTION
SAID THEY WERE COLLECTIVELY
TOGETHER. WE'RE ALWAYS TRYING
TO- INSTILL THAT WITH OUR
EMPLOYEES THAT THEY NEED TO BE
TALKING TO WORKING TOGETHER. SO
WHEN REVIEWING DELAYS THAT-
THAT MAY BE CONTRIBUTING THE
BACKLOG WE TOOK IT A STEP
FURTHER AND THEN LOOKED AT THE
ENTIRE ORGANIZATION AND HOW THE
INDIVIDUALS WORK TOGETHER. WHAT
WE FOUND IS THAT ARE SPECIAL
AGENTS OUR FIELD
REPRESENTATIVES AND OUR
INVESTIGATIVE AUDITOR'S. OFTEN
WORK IN MORE OF A REACTIVE
MANNER. SO STAFF IN THESE
ROLES- THE RESPONSE REQUEST
FROM LICENSING. THEY
INVESTIGATE COMPLAINTS FROM THE
PUBLIC AND THEY ALSO RESPONSE
REQUEST FROM LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. MOST
IMPORTANTLY THEY ALSO CONDUCTS
SITE INSPECTIONS AND FINANCE
FOR IS REVIEWS EVERY TWO YEARS
AS THE LICENSE RENEWAL PROCESS
COMES UP SO LICENSES ONCE ARE
ISSUED EVERY TWO YEARS THEY
COME UP FOR RENEWAL. AND DURING
THAT TIME RIGHT BEFORE OR-
RIGHT BEFORE THE BEFORE THE
LICENSING PROCESS. FIELD REPS
AGENTS DO INSPECTIONS THE
AUDITOR'S DEAL FINANCIALLY
VALUATIONS AND WHAT WE FOUND IS
BECAUSE WE FOLLOW WITH CYCLES
SOMETIMES ISSUES FOUND. IT
TAKES TIME SO WE HAVE TO INVEST
EIGHT AND WHAT IT DOES IS THE
LAYS THE RENEWAL PROCESS AND
THE RULES ARE OUR PRIORITY-
WITHOUT THOSE- LIKE THIS IS A
PLACE PEOPLE CAN OPERATE THEY
CAN'T WORK SO THAT WAS OUR OLD
THE FIRST THING. TO GET OUT THE
DOOR. AS LIKE TO. WAS IN. HE
DOES POSE IT. ALL OF OUR
MEMBERS. WHICH IS THE BACK THAT
WE'VE TRYING TO ADDRESS. I DO
WANT TO MENTION THAT WE MADE
REALLY GREAT SONG THE BACKLOG-
AS THE OTHER SAID WE ARE STILL
IMPLEMENTING PROBLEM POLCIES
WE ARE INVITING AS WE GO ALONG
WE SEE ISSUES BECAUSE WE
REALIZE IT'S KIND OF THE-
ONGOING PROCESS. I'M AS ANY
JOURNAL MENTIONED- WE GET THE
NUMBERS BACK IN MARCH THIRTY
FIRST AND INCLUDED THOSE
NUMBERS IN THE INITIAL RESPONSE
OUT OF HER. THOSE AT THE
BACKLOG WAS ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE IF WE LOOK
AT FAST FORWARD TO TODAY OF
THOSE NUMBERS A HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE LEFT. AND AGAIN AS THINGS
ROLLING THE- WE HAVE TO ADDRESS
THEM SO IT'S NOT. GETTING RID
OF THOSE THAT ARE OVER A
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THE BACKLOG IS IF
IT'S IN THE BUREAU FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY DAYS WE CONSIDER A
BACKLOG SO IS TRYING TO REMOVE
THOSE OLD CASES BUT ALSO THAN
KEEPING THE NEW ONES FROM
ROLLING INTO THE- WE LOOK AT.
ALL CURRENTLY. OF OUR PENNY
LICENSES WE HAVE THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY IN HOUSE THAT ARE
OVER SIX MONTHS OLD SO. WE
WOULD LIKE YOU TO BE THERE A
LITTLE WORKING TOWARDS THAT BUT
WE'VE BEEN MAKING REALLY GOOD
PROGRESS THAT'S SOMETHING THEY
WERE PROUD OF. SO THE- ONE B.
C. P. WITH THE- THE REGULATORY
THE LARGER BCP. IT IS TO HIRE
MORE SPECIAL AGENTS MORE FIELD
REPS- MORE INVESTIGATIVE
AUDITORS SO WE ARE DOING MORE
ROUTINE- REVIEWS SO. NOT JUST
ONCE EVERY TWO YEARS BUT YOU'RE
IN THERE EVERY MONTH OR YOU'RE
IN THERE EVERY QUARTER. LEAD TO
ASSIST WITH THE LICENSING
PROCESS BUT TO WORK WITH THE
LICENSEES SO IF THAT WE SEE
PROBLEMS WE CAN DRESS THEM
PROACTIVELY GET PEOPLE BACK ON
TRACK AND NOT HAVE THESE ISSUES
COME UP AT THE END OF THE
LICENSING PERIOD. SO ANALYSTS
VIEW UNIT. THE US THAT UNIT
CURRENTLY LOOKS A GAME APPROVAL
DOCUMENTS THIS IS FOR A WHOLE
DIFFERENT SET OF
RESPONSIBILITIES WE WOULD LIKE
THOSE GAME ANALYST THOSE WHO
HAVE EXPERTISE IN THE RULES OF
THE GAME THAT WE APPROVED TO BE
ACTIVELY OUT THERE GOING OUT
INSPECTING WORKING SPECIAL
AGENTS WORKING FIELD REPS-
SINCE THE EXPERTISE ON ALL OF
THE ACTUAL RULES OF THE GAMES
ARE BEING PLAYED- IN THE CARD
ROOM SO IT IS DIFFERENT- THE
REST. TO OF THE BETWEEN TO HELP
WITH THE WORK LOAD TO ENSURE
THAT EVERYTHING THAT WE'RE
PUTTING OUT TO THE INDUSTRY IS
CONSISTENT LEGALLY SOUND A LOT
OF THOSE- HISTORY
REPRESENTATIVES BRING IT ARNE'S
HOME LIKE TO BE A PART BE A
LOOK SPEAK THE SAME LANGUAGE
AND MAKE SURE THAT EVERYTHING
IS NOW WE DO THINK THAT THE
ADDITIONAL ADVISORY TO THE COME
TO END INTO A- SEE THE LET THE
NOSE AND ADDRESS THEM AND ALSO
PROBABLY SOME MORE REGULATIONS
TO TYPE THING. I WAS UP.
POSITIONS HELPFUL FOR THOSE.
ONE FINAL. YEAH I NEED ONLY
WITH THE LARGEST ANALYST'S
OFFICE WE HAVE COME ON BCP'S
WILL START WITH THE LICENSING
ONE- ON THE LICENSING ONE WE
ARE RECOMMENDING- REJECTING THE
PROPOSAL FOR BEING PREMATURE
FOR TWO REASONS- THE FIRST
THREE IN IS A CONCERN THAT IS
SHARED BY THE AUDITOR'S OFFICE
IN TERMS OF A NUMBER CONCEIT
AND PROCEDURAL JAZZ IN SAID
HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENT QUITE
RECENTLY AND SO THE FULL IMPACT
OF THOSE CHANGES ARE UNKNOWN.
AND FOR THE LETTER TO DETERMINE
THE APPROPRIATE LEVEL ONGOING
RESOURCES THE FULL IMPACT
REALLY SHOULD BE MEASURED AND
CAPTURED THE SECOND IS RELATED
TO THAT IS THAT THESE REQUESTS
FOR NOT ANALYST POSITION INS
SHOULD WE BE CONSIDERED CONCUR
ME THE- FOR PERMANENT ANIL.
JULY COMING DE BECAUSE- FOR THE
EXPIRE. AND THE REASON FOR THE
IS SOME OF THE SOME OF THE
TASKS AND RESPONSIBILITIES THAT
ARE PROPOSED TO BE SHIFTING
INTO THESE NON ANALYST
POSITIONS WOULD OTHERWISE BE
DONE BY THE ANALYSTS. AND SO
THEY REALLY SHOULD BE TAKEN AND
HOLE IN TERMS OF THINKING ABOUT
THE TOTAL LEVEL OF RESOURCES.
AND THE APPROPRIATE TYPE OF
STAFF THAT ARE NEEDED ON AN
ONGOING BASIS. FOR THE
OVERSIGHT PCP WE ARE
RECOMMENDING MODIFYING THAT
PROPOSAL- BY NOT APPROVING
THREE OF THE THIRTY POSITIONS
THAT ARE INCLUDED IN THAT BCP
WE GENERALLY DON'T HAVE A UP-
AN ISSUE WITH THE PROACTIVE
APPROACH. RELATED TO THE
SPECIAL AGENTS IN THE GAME IN
EXETER. THE THREE POSITIONS IN
QUESTION ARE RELATED TO THE IN
HOUSE LEGAL RESOURCES- AND SO
THESE WOULD BE POSITIONS THAT
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR A VARIETY
OF ACTIVITIES INCLUDING
REVIEWING. THE WARNING LETTERS
SITTING IN ON MEETINGS WITH-
LICENSEE ATTORNEYS ETCETERA.
AND WE HAVE THIS RECOMMENDATION
BECAUSE WE GENERALLY FIND OTHER
ALTERNATIVE WAYS OF DEALING
WITH THAT WORKLOAD FOR EXAMPLE.
INCREASED TRAINING FOR IT LESS
THAN THEIR SUPERVISORS COULD BE
USED TO ENSURE THAT LETTERS
ISSUED IN BOTH AN APPROPRIATE
AND CONSISTENT LEGALLY SOUND
WAY. CAN YOU COME IN I'M SURE I
DIDN'T ADDRESS I ONLY JUST ONE
OF THE BC PIECE OF A MAKES BIG
BRIEFLY TO THE LICENSING
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO WE DO
UNDERSTAND YES WE WILL BE
COMING BEFORE YOU NEXT YEAR
WITH THE B. C. P. FOR PERMANENT
FUNDING FOR THOSE THIRTY TWO OR
SOME. NUMBER OF THOSE THIRTY
TWO POSITIONS SO JUST TO BE
CLEAR THAT THIS. IS COMPLETELY
SEPARATE FROM THAT ONE. AND WE
ARE LOOKING FOR THINGS THERE
ARE THINGS THAT THE AUDITOR'S
SUGGEST. THAT THE NEW DUTIES
THAT THE INTAKE UNIT HOUSE CHIU
DOING LETTERS. DOING IMOGENE
AND PUTTING THINGS IN THE
DATABASE SO WE THINK THERE'S
ALREADY CURRENTLY WORK LOW. WHO
WOULD ALSO KNOW THAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO SHIFT MORE NON
ANALYST'S DUTIES TO THAT UNIT-
TO THE CAN BE ABLE TO HANDLE
IT. WE DON'T WANT THE ANALYST-
BE. THE ONE THE CONSTRAINED.
INVESTIGATIONS OF THERE ARE
THINGS THAT OTHER OF LOWER.
CLERICAL SUPPORT LEVEL TYPE OF
POSITIONS CAN DO WE THINK
THAT'S AN EFFICIENT USE OF
RESOURCES TO ENSURE THAT THE
ANALYSTS ARE DOING WHAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO ALSO IN THE
LICENSING SECTION- THERE IS NO
SUPPORT STAFF SEWER ASKING FOR
A COUPLE OF OFFICE TECHNICIANS
FOR THOSE TWO UNITS. SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE EITHER ANALYSTS OR
MANAGERS HAVING TO HAVE SENT
OUT LETTERS AND DOING COPYING
THINGS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET
THE BALL ROLLING TO MAKE SURE
THE AND LET'S GET THE WORK DONE
AND THE MANAGERS ARE ABLE TO
REVIEW IT AND GET IT DONE SO WE
HAD IDENTIFIED THINGS THAT WE
THINK WILL MAKE US MORE.
EFFICIENT IN A SURE THAT- WE
ELIMINATE THE BACKLOG AND ALSO
THAT WE DON'T BACKSLIDE INTO
DOESN'T COME BACK. THE QUESTION.
YEAH OKAY. THANKS VENTURA I
JUST OPENED IT JUST ASK THE
AUDITOR TO ADDRESS THE- ITEM IN
THE AGENDA THAT TALKED ABOUT.
AND THE TEAM'S FINDINGS
REGARDING P. EFFICIENCY OF THE
ORGANIZATION- OBVIOUSLY THE
QUESTION BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
IS. SINCE THE DEPARTMENT HAS
SHOWN- INEFFICIENCY WITH THE
APPROPRIATION WE DID AND
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN IT DOESN'T
REALLY MAKE SENSE TO DO FURTHER
APPROPRIATION NOT US IF LA HAS
A COMMENT ON THAT AS WELL. SO
IN TERMS OF OUR FINDING- AS I
SUMMARIZED- THIS IS THE
STATISTICS SHOW THAT THOSE
POSITIONS HAD MARKEDLY
DECREASING IN IMPACT ON ON THE
CASELOAD AT THE BILL WHICH
RAISE CONCERNS FOR US BECAUSE
THEY WERE REQUESTED. UNDER THE
AUSPICES OF CLEARING THAT
BACKLOG. EQUALLY CONCERNING TO
US IS YOU WOULD READ IN OUR
REPORT IS THAT. ON THE PIER
WASN'T REALLY ABLE TO PROVIDE A
CONVINCING OCCUR HERE AT REASON
AS TO WHY THAT DECREASE IN
PRODUCTIVITY OR EFFICIENCY WAS
OCCURRING- THERE ARE REFERENCES
TO DIFFERENT POOLS OF
APPLICANTS TAKING A DIFFERENT
AMOUNT OF TIME- HOWEVER WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE CASE LOAD AND
THE DISTRIBUTION OF IT THAT.
WASN'T REALLY. LINKS CLEARLY TO
THE PROBLEMS THAT WE WERE
SEEING I'M SO THEY DID SEEM TO
THE PROBLEMS DID SEEM TO BE
INSOFAR AS WE CAN DIAGNOSE THEM
TO BE PROCEDURAL IN TERMS OF.
ANALYZING THE COMPLETENESS OF
APPLICATIONS AS THEY COME IN
THE DOOR AS OPPOSED TO WAITING
FOR ANALYSTS TO DO IT LATER. ON
SOME OF THE OTHER. CLERICAL
QUOTE UNQUOTE TYPE ACTIVITIES
THAT THAT THAT THE DEPARTMENT
IS REFERRING TO NOW. AGAIN I
WOULD JUST REITERATE FROM A
FROM A RESOURCE PERSPECTIVE.
ARE FINDING WAS THAT WAITING TO
DO THOSE THINGS- ACTUALLY MADE
THEM TAKE LONGER BECAUSE
GETTING IN TOUCH WITH SOMEONE
WHAT SUBMITTED AN INCOMPLETE
APPLICATION YEARS PRIOR. WAS A
MORE TIME SINGING ACTIVITY FOR
THE ANALYST ASSIGNED THANK YOU
TO DO SO COMING IN THE DOOR.
INTO THE REFERENCE TO THINGS
LIKE LETTERS THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO BE SENT OUT. THOSE ARE
REQUIRED BY BY LAW SO- I WILL
AGAIN WOULD SAY THAT THE NEW
RESPONSIBILITY THAT OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS PLACED ON ON
THE BUREAU- SO ALL TOLD I JUST
REITERATE THAT. I'M GIVEN OUR
OUR FINDINGS GIVEN OUR- ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE UTILIZATION
OF THIRTY TWO POSITIONS. I
DON'T SEE A CLEAR LINK BETWEEN-
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE NEED
FOR ADDITIONAL POSITIONS
BARRING SOME ADDITIONAL. DATA
THAT MAY OR MAY NOT BE
AVAILABLE. THANK YOU SIR I
DON'T HAVE THE OTHER RUN FOR ME
BUT WHAT WHICH RECOMMENDATION
THAN. SELF IF NOT NEW POSITIONS
WITH THE RECORD. FROM THE
RECOGNITION OF THE BACK WITH
WITH RESPECT TO THE- POSITIONS
WE RECOMMENDED THAT THEY EXTEND
THAT WOMEN ARE NOT IN. TWO
YEARS. TO ALLOW THE PROTON
COMMON OUR MANDATE THEM BUT WE
HOPE WILL. AGAIN XIN C. M. BIG
KNOWLEDGE THE REPORT WE BELIEVE
THAT SO NUMBER OF THOSE TWO BIT.
ARE WARRANT ON AN ONGOING DUE
TO A- WILLIAM SINCE THEY WERE
FIRST OVER TO THE DEPARTMENT.
HOWEVER WE DON'T. GET TO OF.
THIRTY TO A STOP OF HISTORICAL.
IN YOUR AUDIT OF THE OF THE
BEER TO JEFF ANY. THOUGHTS
ABOUT THE QUESTION I RAISED
WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WHETHER WHETHER REALLY MADE
SENSE. TO HAVE BOTH.
ENFORCEMENT AS WELL AS
LICENSING FUNCTIONS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT WHETHER THE DUTCH
REALLY BE SEPARATE. NO THAT WAS
NOTHING THAT WE LOOK AT
SPECIFICALLY AND IN FACT THAT.
ARE THE MAJORITY OF OUR OF OUR
FINDINGS OUR FOCUS WAS IN FACT
ON ON THE LICENSING SIDE WHICH
HAS- AS I SAID NGUYEN IT'S MY
PLACE TO SPEAK TO THE REQUEST
FOR THE ENFORCEMENT POSITIONS.
CANNELLA JIM DID YOUR THOUGHTS
ABOUT THE- THOUGHT OF FINDINGS-
IN TERMS OF THE AUDIT FINDINGS-
WE- THIS ISSUE HAS POPPED UP
NUMEROUS YEARS THROUGH
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE EXCITER
AND IT'S BEEN A PERSISTENT
PROBLEM. AND SO THE ISSUES OF
THE DECLINING PRODUCTIVITY WERE
CERTAINLY IMPORTANT AND I THINK
THAT THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY WE'RE MAKING THIS
RECOMMENDATION IN TERMS OF-
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO THE
LICENSING BECAUSE IT- NON
ANALYTICAL POSITIONS. IN
PARTICULAR YOU WANT TO LOOK AT
THE PROCESS AND HOLE. AND
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE APPROPRIATE
LEVEL OF RESOURCES ARE NEEDED
AND SOME OF THAT INVOLVES
THINKING ABOUT WHAT IS NEEDED
ON EACH PARTICULAR APPLICATION.
SO FOR EXAMPLE WHEN YOU'RE
BACKLOG IS QUITE SIGNIFICANT
YOU MIGHT BE DOING CERTAIN
THINGS TO GET IT DONE AND GET
IT OUT OF THE WAY. BUT THEN
MOVING FORWARD ON AN ONGOING
BASIS THE PROCESS MIGHT LOOK
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT AND REQUIRE.
A DIFFERENT LEVEL OF RESOURCES
AND SO THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY WE'RE RECOMMENDING-
CONSIDERING IT IN HORRIBLE AT
PART OF NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET
LIKELY BUDGET REQUEST. THANK
YOU THE DEPARTMENT OF THE
FEEDBACK I'M JUST REALLY
QUICKLY IN TERMS OF THE M. KIND
OF HAVING THE ENFORCEMENT A
LICENSING TOGETHER I JUST WANT
TO REITERATE KIND OF WHAT THE-
CAN MOTIVATE MOTIVATED US WITH
ONE OF THOSE BCP'S IS THE
INTERACTION BETWEEN OUR
ENFORCEMENT OUR INVESTIGATIVE
AUDITOR'S IN THE LICENSING
SECTION BECAUSE THEY DO RELY ON
ONE ANOTHER IN THEY WORK
COLLECTIVELY TO THAT. MAKE SURE
THE PEOPLE ARE. GET ON THE
RIGHT TRACK AND WE DON'T HAVE
TO TAKE DISCIPLINARY ATION
AGAINST THEM SO THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT I DO I DO WANT
TO POINT OUT BECAUSE I THINK
THAT SOME FOLKS THINK WE'RE
KIND OF SILO TO- AND WHILE THEY
DO HAVE DIFFERENT
RESPONSIBILITIES THEY DO HAVE
TO WORK TOGETHER SO IT THINK
THAT IS ONE THING. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE ALL OF THOSE
RESOURCES AND ONE PLACE-
ESPECIALLY FOR MELINDA
MISTREATED ISSUES TO THEY KIND
OF OVERLAP AND WORK HAND IN
HAND TOGETHER. YEAH AND I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU HAVE A- COMMENT I
THINK IF YOU IF YOU TALK TO
SOME OF THE- PUMP ESTABLISHMENT
TO COME IN FOR LICENSING. THEIR
THEIR FEEDBACK TO- TO US HAS
BEEN THAT THEY FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE THEY'RE SORT OF.
TREATED LIKE CRIMINALS. THAT
THEY- ARE ARE TREATED- AS IF
THEY'RE GUILTY UNETHICAL PROVE
THEIR- THEIR INNOCENCE THROUGH
THAT LICENSING. PROCESS I THINK
AND I THINK JUST THE WAY I
WOULD THINK ABOUT IT IS. IF WE
PUT IN I MENTION THIS WHEN THE
TORNADO CAME. IF WE PUT. THE
CANNABIS LICENSE. IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE I THINK
WE HAVE. ALMOST ZERO
PARTICIPATION JUST BECAUSE OF
THAT POTENTIAL FEAR. ON THE SO
I JUST CURIOUS HOW HOW YOU FELT
ABOUT THAT CUTURE IF YOU'VE
HEARD THAT. SORT OF FEEDBACK IF
YOU HAD HEARD. ON THAT CONCERN
FOR MANY OF THE LICENSEES THAT
HAVE THROW YEAH OVER THE YEARS
I THINK I'VE ONLY BEEN THIS
POSITION FOR TWO YEARS BUT- I
HAVE SOME EXPERIENCE IN THE
GAMING INDUSTRY AND I'VE I'VE
HEARD BOTH I'VE HEARD THANKS
FOR NOT TREAT US LIKE CRIMINALS
I'VE HEARD BY HE TREATMENTS
LIKE CRIMINALS. AND I WILL SAY
THAT WE TRIED TO BE REALLY-
OBJECTIVE WHEN A LICENSING
APPLICATION COMES AND WE HAVE
SPECIFIC- AND SO WE ASK AND WE
DO FOLLOW UP FOR INFORMATION- I
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT IS KIND OF
A- IS A WORKLOAD FOR PEOPLE AND
WHEN PEOPLE HAVE OTHER
BUSINESSES OF THEY'RE RUNNING
BUT WE- IT'S- THE REGULATED
ENGINE. INDUSTRY FOR GOOD
REASON AND I THINK THAT- ALL
THE QUESTIONS THAT WE ASK AND
ALL THE INFORMATION WE GET I
MEAN AT LEAST AS TO WHERE WE
CAN MAKE A GOOD RECOMMENDATION
TO THE COMMISSION US EXCELLENCE
LET IT'S AN NOT. PRICE PEOPLE.
THANK YOU FOR THE REGULATION.
ALSO WHO ARE CONCERNED OF THAT.
THAT THEY'RE DOING THE-
DEPARTMENT TREAT. TO
ESTABLISHED UNFAIR. UNEQUAL SO
THAT SEEMS BE CO NOT SINCE THE-
CA. WITH MY FEEDBACK AS WELL.
I WILL SAY THAT. WE HAD LOOKED
AT REALLY HARD OUR PROCESS IS
WHEN THE AUDIT REPORT CAME OUT
IN TERMS OF- ARE WE TREATING
PEOPLE DIFFERENTLY ARE THEY
HAVING DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES SO
WE'VE BEEN- REALLY HONING IN ON
MAKING SURE THAT. NO ONE GETS
SPECIAL TREATMENT YOU KNOW AND
THAT IS SOMETHING WE ALWAYS GO
TO THAT ONE PEOPLE AFTER
SOMETHING IT'S LIKE. NO WE'RE
TREATING EVERYONE THE SAME AND
I THINK WE HAD BEFORE BUT
REALLY SPEAKING IT OUT LOUD NOW
THAT'S NO YOU DON'T GET BUT
LINE FOR SOME. NO YOU DON'T- WE
DON'T GET I'M HAVE CERTAIN
SPECIAL. INTERESTS THINGS LIKE
THAT- WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WELL
WE'VE ALWAYS FELT THAT WE HAVE
BEEN- OBJECTIVE AND TRY TO
TREAT EVERYONE FAIRLY UP. UNDER
THE PERCENT. OR TRYING TO MAKE.
CERTAINLY ALL OF US IN RURAL
THAT ALSO THE INDUSTRY KNOWS
THAT TO. SHOWING YOUR TEARS YOU
WOULDN'T SAY THAT IT'S BEEN
YOUR EXPERIENCE THAT YOU'VE-
TREATED PEOPLE. BUT BASS AND
NOT LOOK BACK TREAT TREAT
PEOPLE UNFAIRLY. I DON'T
BELIEVE SO. AND HISTORICALLY
BEFORE YOU GOT THERE WOULD YOU
WOULD YOU. I BELIEVE THAT OUR
BELIEF IS THAT THERE'S ANY SORT
OF UNFAIR. UNEQUAL TREATMENT
NOT A NO I AM. JUST HELP ME I
HAD BEEN ON THE GALA CONTROL
COMMISSION FOR SIX YEARS PRIOR
TO THIS I DID IT. AT THE STATE
IN ANOTHER STATE AGENCY BETWEEN
BUT- AS AS KIND OF I GUESS AN
OUTSIDER- WHEN I VIEW THE
BUREAU I DID NOT FIND THAT I
DID NOT HAVE THAT CONCERN THAT
THEY WERE TREATING PEOPLE-
UNFAIRLY. CERTAINLY WE GIVE-
RECOMMENDATIONS PEOPLE DON'T
LIKE AND- WE HAVE TO SUPPORT
THEM AND IF WE DON'T THE
COMMISSION WELL THEN FIND A
DIFFERENT. MAKE DIFFERENT
VERSIONS SO WE'RE ALWAYS- I
THINK IT'S VERY TRUE. AND WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO- YOU KNOW ORDER. THIS
IN SOME WE GIVE. THE THIRTY TWO
LIMITED- TO YOUR POSITIONS FOR
LICENSING WHY WHY THE NEED FOR
MORE. WELL SO THESE ARE I MEAN
THOSE ARE JUST STRICTLY FOR THE
ANALYTICAL POSITIONS THERE THE
SSA NAY GPA LEVEL THE- THE
REQUESTED WE HAD FOR THE- FOR
THE I BELIEVE IT EIGHT
POSITIONS IS STRICTLY FOR THE
NON ANALYTICAL TO SUPPORT WORK
THINGS SAID WE WANT TO WE
RECOGNIZE THAT WE DON'T WANT
THE ANALYSTS TO DO TO TAKE AWAY
FROM THE IMPORTANT BUT THEY'RE
DOING. AND THESE ARE THINGS
THAT ARE MORE ROUTINE THE YOU
KNOW IF USE SETTING UP FILES
AND SENATE REVIEWING SENDING
OUT LETTERS AND DOING ALL THOSE
THINGS THE WORKLOAD IS NOT
GOING TO CHANGE BECAUSE IT'S
JUST THE NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS
COME IT THEY'RE GOING TO DO
THOSE THINGS FOR THESE-
APPLICATION SO WHAT DOES THE
ANALYSTS. THEIR WORKLOAD TO PAY
ON OF TYPE OF THIS HAVE HOW DO
IT WITH THE SEARCH ARE WITH THE
WITH THAT WE COULD THIS IS
PARCEL OUT BECAUSE IT IS
CORRECT I'M GOING WORKLOAD FOR
IS GOING PRES NOT GONNA WAIT
WHAT. OLDER WORKERS. IT IS THE
ONE WHY DO YOU THINK THE
AUDITOR FOUND ON A LACK OF
EFFICIENCY WITH SOME OF THE
SOME OF THE STAFF YEAH I
THEY'RE SAYING THAT THEIR
BELIEF IS THAT. THERE MAY NOT
BE A NEED FOR ANY MORE STAFF
WHICH I ALWAYS LIKE TO HEAR. I
THINK WHAT WE ARE GOING TO BE
LOOKING. DO A HARD LOOK AT WHAT
OUT OF THOSE THIRTY TWO WE NEED
TO COME BACK TO YOU FOR NEXT
YEAR. I MEAN WE ARE STILL
WORKING THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
GAINING EFFICIENCIES AND WE'RE
GOING WE KNOW WE HAVE TO
JUSTIFY THOSE POSITIONS SO THAT
IS SOMETHING WE ARE WILL BE
COMING BACK TO NEXT YEAR TO DO.
SO IT'S NOT AN INCREASE RIGHT
NOW IN THOSE THIRTY TWO ON THE
ANALYTICAL POSITIONS THIS IS
KIND OF A- A NEW WORKLOAD THAT
WE ARE ADDRESSING AND I
SHOULDN'T SAY NEW WORKLOAD
BECAUSE IT THE ART WE ARE DOING
SOME OF THAT RIGHT NOW. IT HAS
INCREASED SINCE WE IMPLEMENTED
SOME THE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS AND WE THINK IT
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO AGAIN TO
KEEP US ON TRACK. MAKING SURE
THAT WE CAN GET THOSE CASES DOT
WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE. A LIVER
ANALYSTS DOING- DUTIES ARE
DIRECTLY RELATED TO THE
BACKGROUND INVESTIGATIONS. THE
AUDITOR HAVE POINTED OUT THERE
WAS. HELLO OF NON CASE WORK
WHICH IS WORK THAT THE AUDITOR
I'M SORRY THE ANALYSTS HAVE TO
DO BUT THEY WEREN'T
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO- A
BACKGROUND INVESTIGATION THEY
HAVE TO TAKE CALLS FROM THE
INDUSTRY THEY HAD TO WORK ON
OTHER THINGS. SO WE'VE REALLY
BE UP. LIMITED AT RISK THE ALL
THE SUPERVISORS HAVE TO APPROVE
ANY WORK OF THAT KIND AND SO.
DOES PLEASE TALK IS A THE NON
PAY OR- TO IT. AND THAT'S WHY
I'M TRYING TO MAKE THE ENDLESS
ARE. THAT BEFORE. THE FALL SOME.
NASTY AND WE HAVE A- LOT ABOUT
WHAT. KIND OF. IS AND WE ONLY
DON'T THE MANAGER. NOW TO SPENT
ALL THEIR TIME DOING. THINGS
BUT THE NEED TO BE OVERSEEN
MAKING SURE WERE. YOU KNOW.
ALTHOUGH NEW. AND GETTING THE
WORK OUT. SOME TARGET TO THE
HOSPITAL SO COULD COULD YOU CAN
YOU. JUST DESCRIBED TO ME IN
SPECIFIC FUNCTIONALITY WHAT
THIS NEW WAR LOOKS LIKE THIRTY
ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT THE SORRY
THE THIRTY POSITIONS OR THE
LICENSING SUPPORT STAFF I THINK
BOTH HERE- YEAH SURE OKAY SO
WILL I THINK WITH THE WITH THE
REGULAR TALKING BEHIND THE
REGULATORY BCP. IT IS A NEW
WORKLOAD BECAUSE RIGHT NOW-
THIS CERTAIN LEVEL OF BASELINE
OF WHAT. OUR FOLKS DO. FOR
FIELD REPS AGENTS AND AUDITOR'S
WE WANT TO INCREASE THE TIME
THAT THEY ARE IN THE CARD ROOMS
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
FINANCIALLY EVALUATION SO THAT
IT'S DON'T. IT'S WORKING ON AN
ONGOING BASIS THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR AND NOT JUST RIGHT BEFORE
WE GET UP TO THE TO YOUR
RENEWAL CYCLE SO THAT IS- AN
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD. OTHER
THINGS LIKE WITH THE GAMES
REVIEW UNIT IT'S NEW WORK
BECAUSE ARE NOT CURRENTLY DOING
IT NOW WE DON'T SEND THEM OUT
TO THE FIELD WE DON'T HAVE THEM
REVIEW. SURVEILLANCE WE DON'T
HAVE WORK SO MUCH WITH THE
AGENTS UNLESS THEY ACTUALLY
NEED COME TO THEM FOR SOME HELP
WE REALIZE THAT IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE REGULAR
INEFFECTIVE IT'S THAT WE TO FOR
THOSE GAME RULES ARE. BEING
FONGBE IN THE CALM THE
ESTABLISHMENTS MORE OFTEN OVER
THAT TWO YEAR PERIOD PERSIST AT
THE END OF THAT TWO YEAR PERIOD.
IT SEEMS LIKE TO BE TO BE THE
SAME AMOUNT OF TIME IN THE
ESTABLISHMENT JUST INSTEAD OF.
DOING ALL THE AND YOU JUST
SPREADING IT OUT OVER TWO YEARS
WHY WOULD THAT BE ADDITIONAL
WORK WELL THEY WOULD GO INTO
THE DO AN INSPECTION LET'S SAY
ONE SECTION LET'S SEE DURING
THAT TO YEAR CYCLE RIGHT NOW
THEY WOULD BE GOING IN. EVERY
MONTH. SO THAT IS AN INCREASE
IN THE WORK LOAD. BOB IT'S NOT
THAT IT'S NOT THAT- WHAT DO YOU
THINK THAT THEY HAVE TO GO IN
EVERY SINGLE MONTH. I THINK IS
BEING PRESENT IN THE CARD GAMES
AND MAKING SURE I MEAN IT IS
OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO. ENSURE
THAT THINGS ARE. WATER SOURCE
ISSUE THAT HAS COME UP TO YOU
WE HAVE. WE HAVE FOUND ISSUES
YES. IT IS SO. AND SO WHY.
WOULD YOU DO THAT ACROSS THE
BOARD VERSES WITH CERTAIN
ESTABLISHMENTS WHICH YOU MAY
HAVE ISSUES. YEAH AND I SHOULD
HAVE GOT THAT WITH THAT IF WE
DO SEE- PROBLEMS IN AN
<c.blue>STABLISHED AND WE HAVE TO</c>
REFER THE LICENSEE OR IF WE
NEED TO DO SOME MORE
ENFORCEMENT WORK THAT- IT IS
MORE THAN. LIKE WILL GO WHEN
THEY'RE DURING TO YOUR REAL
PSYCHO. FOR WE WILL GO BACK.
NOT JUST DON'T ONCE YOU IN. SO
WE DO. TARGET BUT WE IF WE SEE
AN ISSUE WE WILL GO BACK MORE
TO THAT WAY PLACE BUT WE WILL
LIKE TO IN ALL THE MORE BUT I
DON'T THINK THEY WERE GOING TO
GO THERE ONE IF WE DO THE WILL
GO BACK WE'RE TRYING TO WORK
WITH LICENSEE TO GET IN
COMPLIANCE YOU KNOW WE ISSUE
SOMETIMES AND YOU UP TO MAKE
SURE THEIR INCOME. SO WE WHICH
MAKES CA SO BUT ARE USING THAT
YES STOP NEEDS THAT KIND OF
LEVEL OF ATTENTION THE I THINK
WE'RE TO BE TRYING TO BE EQUAL
ABOUT IT TO MAKE SURE THAT
AGAIN TREATING EVERYONE FAIRLY
MAKING SURE WERE IN THERE AND
LIKE YOU SAID SOME STUFF AND
JUST A REALLY SMALL SO THE
INSPECTION WILL BE A LOT MORE
UP. YOU KNOW BRIEF I THINK
WHERE IT IF THERE'S IN THE VERY
LARGE CARDIUM THERE MAY BE
THINGS MORE THINGS TO LOOK AT
THAT WILL SPEND MORE TIME AND
THEY'RE JUST BECAUSE THEY NEED
TO COVER MORE SPACE TO LOOK AT.
THINGS I WOULDN'T. UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S PROBLEM WHICH- TO SOLVE
I STILL ON. THAT I MEAN WE-
WHEN YOU COME THROUGH OUR
COMMITTEE WILL ALWAYS TRYING.
AYE SOLUTION TO. WITH PROBLEM
THAT. YOU MIGHT. THE KNEES.
NEEDS THIS. STAFF RIGHT. I
THINK TO. THAT WERE. THE DELAYS
THAT WE HAD SEEN. OMIT
SOMETHING THEY WERE FOR. WITH
THAT WHEN THAT RUNS. I COME OUT
THE- FINAL. COMES UP. THAT IF
WITH. ISSUE IT'S ALWAYS THIS
GRANT. TRYING TO REDO THE A-
AND AN IT HOLDS THINGS UP. SO
THAT IS A DELAY. REALLY AT THE
ON. RECOMMEND KIND OF BRANCH
OUT FOR. THAT THAT IS SOMETHING
ONE WE WANT TO ELIMINATE THAT
DELAY. AND THEN I THINK SO. IT
IS JUST TO BE MORE PROACTIVE IN
DO OUR JOBS MORE EFFICIENTLY.
AND SO THAT WE CAN WORK WITH
THE INDUSTRY WE DO HAVE. WE DO
HAVE- WE HAVE THERE ARE ISSUES.
THAT WE HAVE FOUND. AND WE WILL
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE ON TOP
OF IT. BUT IT SEEMS IF YOU WANT
TO BE MORE EFFICIENT YOU THIRD
HER. QUESTION BEFORE MORE. AND
THEN GOING BACK TO THE TO THE
FOUR TO THE FIRST REQUEST WHICH
IS IT DOES SEEM ODD BECAUSE IT
SEEMS. TO THE AUDITOR FOUND
WHICH WAS. THAT THERE WAS
SOURCE. SYSTEM ISSUES A LACK OF
PEOPLE. YEAH AND THE IT PEOPLE
THAT WE HAVE A- FOR THE LICENSE
SUPPORT. WAS AS A RESULT OF
WHAT AT THE I. FOR ON AND
IDENTIFY THOSE EFFICIENT.
INEFFICIENCIES AND OF THAT HAS
TO DO WHO'S DOING THE WORK MAKE
SURE THE WORK GETS DONE. IT
DOESN'T IT DOESN'T BACK UP.
YEAH BUT LIKE I SAID IT HI IT'S
ODD DO WITHIN A FEW. BY FOR
MORE OF THE- IN IT'S BECAUSE
IT'S WITH A DE TYPES OF FOLKS
THAT. WE'RE TRYING TO. WITH
THAT. ARE YOU YOU REDUCE THOSE
OTHER OF FOLKS PRODUCTIVE. WHAT
WE WILL LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF
AN- THAT WE NEED. NEXT YOUR
BRING FOR THAT BE BUT THESE.
DESERVES ON AT ANALYST BE.
REDEDICATED TO US MOTHER. TASK
WELL THOSE ARE ANALYSTS THE ARE
AT A AND A LITTLE COLD LET.
RIGHTS WE'RE LOOKING AT THINGS
LIKE AT THE O. TWO THE OFFICE
SAID. LEVEL THE PRO TAKE LEVEL.
THE ARE YOU KNOW. STEPS BELOW
THOSE TO SEE THAT WE CAN HAVE
PEOPLE WHO MAY DON'T HAVE
ANALYTICAL SKILLS WHO CAN DO
THE WORK THAT IS JUST REVIEWING
AN AND A- LIKE. AND THINGS THAT.
THE FOLKS WHO ARE IN AN- LEVEL.
YOU KNOW. WE WANT THEM TO CALM.
ON BACK IN THIS. SO THAT IF
INTO YOUR TOO MANY. MAYBE YOU
NEED MORE TECHNICIANS OF
HEARING. I DON'T WANNA SAY WE
NEED YOUR LIFE THAT WHAT ONE
EVER ARE OUR GUESTS I NEVER GET
THE AND THE SKIN WE WILL WE
DIDN'T REALIZE WE HAVE TO
SUPPORT OUR OUR NEXT YEAR
PERMANENT FOR THOSE THIRTY TWO
OR NOW OF THOSE THIRTY TWO. SO
THAT IS SOMETHING WE'RE LOOKING
AT AFTER IMPLEMENTING THOSE PER
SAY YES PETER JUMP. YEAH LET'S
JUMP IN. MY NAME'S EDWARD BUT
DRAW I'M THE CHIEF FOR THE
DIVISION OF LAW AND I. WANTED
TO SOMETHING OVER WANT TO COME.
AS WE WHAT IS IT WHAT WE TRY.
IT'S ACTIVITIES AT OCCURRING
WITHIN CARD CLUBS AND THAT
INCLUDES ALL VARIOUS FORMS OF.
MONEY LAUNDERING OPERATIONS
WHERE- HIGHLY ENGAGED NOW
WITHIN SAN IN OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS. IN ENGAGING- WITH
MORE PROACTIVE ENFORCEMENT-
INVOLVING. A MONEY LAUNDERING
ARE AT A CASINOS IN
CALIFORNIA'S PRIME BECAUSE THE
NUMBER OF PART OF THAT WE HAVE.
IN CALIFORNIA SO WE
SPECIFICALLY ONE STOP FOR THAT
AND BEING IN CASINOS MORE OFTEN
LOOKING AT THAT. THAT COULD BE
LOOKING AT. A LOOKING. THIS
MISSION ACTIVITY REPORTS
INSURING THAT THEIR- EMPLOYEES
ARE TRAINED TO PREVENT. FACT
ANTI MONEY LAUNDERING. A
PROVISION A PLACE IS VERY
IMPORTANT. THE OTHER PARTIES
ADEQUATE FINANCING WE HAD TO
CLOSE. A DEAL I COULD SEE NO.
NOT THAT LONG AGO BECAUSE-
MINUS WHICH GOT OF THAT SO WE
KNOW WE THIS PROBLEM ARE CAR.
MOVING FOR NOT REACTING TO THEM
EMERGENCY CLOSURE SHOULD BE
LAST AND WE HAVE TO DO IT FOR
IN THERE- ACTING- APPROPRIATELY
NOT PROPERLY BACKING INTO PRO
ACTIVELY- IN IN ENSURING THAT
ALL THESE CASINOS ARE HAVING
ENOUGH PROPER FINANCING ENSURE
THAT WOULD SOMEWHAT TO CASH IN
THEIR CHIPS. THEY HAVE THE
MONEY TO CASH IN THEIR CHIPS SO
THOSE ARE JUST SOME EXAMPLES.
SINCE YOU'VE USED THE
TERMINOLOGY CARDROOM IN CASINOS
INTERCHANGEABLY. SO YOU'RE
SAYING SO IT TOOK THIS IS THIS
IS AN ISSUE THAT YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED- AT CHI CARBONS NOT
AT CASINOS NOPE WE'VE
IDENTIFIED APPLE FOR. BOTH THE-
AND YOUR AND YOUR- I'M LOOKING
AT BOTH. YES HEY ARE YOU SAYING
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING SORT OF.
A CROSS THE BORDER THAT IS
OCCURRING OR JUST AT- SPECIFIC
ESTABLISHMENTS SO CRISTINA IS
BECAUSE OF THE CASH OPERATIONS
IS A PRIME LOCATION FOR THESE
SELECT. WHETHER IT BE A CARTER
MORE CASINO THERE IT'S BOTH
WHETHER YOU WANT TO STRUCTURE
YOU WANTED. HOWEVER YOU LIKE
TO. WANDER THE MONEY THERE'S
NOT. TO DO THAT SO WE BOTH.
DOES THE CARD WELL THIS IS OUR
CONCERN TO ME THIS SOME OF THE
WORST THAT HEARD THAT YOU WERE
SAYING ACROSS THE BOARD AT OUR
GAMBLING IS TO UP AND DOWN THE
STATE THAT YOU VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT MONEY LAUNDERING
HAPPENING AT PRETTY MUCH ALL
WELL I THINK YOU'RE NOT EXACTLY
ALL OF THEM BUT THEY'RE THEY'RE
CERTAINLY 90% OF THEM FIFTY OF
THEM WE TALK ABOUT OUR- BUT
HARD TO PUT INTO JOHN I'M BUT
SICK WILL. I'M IN THE TALKING
PERCENT. NINE FORTY. WHAT WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT WE'RE MEDIA. A
TELL YOU THE ONE. PRETTY
EGREGIOUS FOR EXAMPLE IT
ATTORNEY GENERAL MENTIONED-
HAWAIIAN GARDENS WITHOUT SOME
OTHER ACTIVE CASES GOING ON WE-
WE KNOW THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
ACTIVITY OUT THERE SOME. WOMEN
I I'M NOT. JUST DISAGREEING
RIGHT BED. AGAIN I THINK YOU'RE
MAKING SUPPOSITIONS SO. THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL MENTIONED ONE.
CAR TRUMP BUT IT'S A BIG
DIFFERENCE TO ONE CARD ROOM AND
I DON'T KNOW I FORGET HOW MANY
CARD AND YOU WOULD KNOW BETTER
THAN ME. THE CARD CZAR BUT I
MEAN IT'S A TO TECH IS A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SORT OF ONE
INDIVIDUAL AND- A WHOLE CLASS
OF. TWO THIRDS MORE THAN ONCE
REALLY LATE ALSO OR IS ONE THAT
WE'RE WORKING ON RIGHT NOW- WE
MENTIONED- CASES GET APOSTLE
ROLES IS ONE MARYSVILLE. I MEAN
THERE'S YOU KNOW. IF YOU WANNA
PERCENTAGES BE HARD FOR ME TO
GUESS I WOULD- GIVING US
MISSION IS NOT THE ENTIRE. CARD
CLUB INTERVIEW BY. BY CHANCE
BUT I WOULD SAY FIFTEEN TWENTY
PERCENT. BUT IT DOESN'T REALLY
MATTER HOW WHAT THE PERCENTAGES
I MEAN WHAT WHETHER IT. BE
GREEN JUSTICE OF THE 1% IS VERY
IMPORTANT. MORE NO ABSOLUTELY
DOES BECAUSE- AGAIN. IF THIS IS
AS- IS MASS PROBLEM YOU HANDLE
IT BY. CHANGING YOUR ENTIRE
SYSTEM TO ADDRESS. ALL THE
ESTABLISHMENTS EQUALLY. IF THIS
IS. SOMETHING HAPPENING WITH
ONLY YOU KNOW. TEN OR LET'S SAY
20% OF A POPULATION HE I WOULD
ASSUME THAT YOU WOULD BE A
LITTLE MORE TARGET BECAUSE WHY
WHY WOULD YOU. WASTE RESOURCES
ON THE PORTAL QUOTE OTHER 80%
IF YOU DON'T HAVE ANY. ANY
SUSPICION THAT THERE IS. A
LEGAL ACTIVITY GOING BUT THAT
WOULD ASSUME THAT THAT THE
TARGET SEE STATIC SO I MEAN AS
AS YOU ADDRESS MONEY LAUNDERING
ONE LOCATION- AND EITHER COME
COMPLIANCE WE TAKE SOME KIND OF
ENFORCEMENT ACTION AGAINST
THEM. WHAT WOULD BE THE NATURAL
RESPONSE BY A SOMEONE WANTS TO
HONOR MONIES TO SWITCH TO
ANOTHER LOCATION. SO IF IT'S A
YEAH I PROBABLY SHUTS OUT ATTIC
YEAH RIGHT BUT IF YOU SHUT DOWN
ONE LOCATION THAT'S ANOTHER
QUICK KISS PARTS OF. THE NUMBER
STILL STAYS THE SAME. OR STILL
CHASING THE PROBLEM THAT WE
NEED. I DON'T KNOW WHAT WE'RE
WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT AGREE
DISAGREE WITH THAT BUT- WHAT
WHAT I HEARD FROM THE DIRECTOR
WAS A- ACROSS THE BOARD BROAD
BRUSH APPROACH. TO THE ISSUE.
NOT A- TARGETED APPROACH WHICH
SEEMS MORE IN LINE WITH WHAT.
YOUR FUND AGAIN. COM THAT. I'M
NOT SURPRISED NOW THAT THE
AUDITOR MY FOUND INEFFICIENCIES
BECAUSE AGAIN. IF YOU'RE
SPENDING IF YOU TREAT. WRAPPING
UP PLANS TO RAMP UP ENFORCEMENT
OR LICENSING ACROSS THE BOARD.
AND YOU HAVE. THE SAME NO
LOGISTICS. PERCENT NOT EVEN THE
85% THAT WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
EARLIER. 70% OF. US MISSED
REALLY HAVEN'T EXHIBITED A KEY
PROBLEM MORE. SUSPICIOUS
ACTIVITY BUT YOU'RE SPENDING
ALL THESE RESOURCES TO. AGAIN
ASKED THEM TO SORT OF X. Y. Z.
THAT THE LEASE QUESTION AS- TO
WHAT NO WONDER THERE'S AN
EFFICIENCY GOING ON. AT YOU.
WITH THE TWENTY CHANNELS WHAT
WERE WE DON'T WANT TO BE THERE
THERE'S A WE WILL TO ENSURE
THAT PROBABLY DOES OCCUR AND SO
HOW WE KNOW IF THAT PROBLEM
SHIFTING WE'RE TAKING FORSMAN.
OR WE'RE LOOKING AT ANOTHER
CASINO SO WE HAVE TO ACROSS THE
BOARD BE INSPECTING THESE
LOCATIONS SO WE UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE LEVEL OF THE PROBLEM IS AND
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THAT
PROBABLY IS MIGRATING TO THE
CASINO THAT'S I THINK WHAT US
TRANSIT. PERCENT I GUESS THE
QUESTION. THE LEVEL OF THIS.
RIGHT I'M AND AGAIN- IT. THE IS
THE LEVEL OF INSPECTION TODAY.
HOW OR INADEQUATE AND THAT AND
THAT THAT THAT I THINK THAT'S
SORT OF THE QUESTION THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL SAYS THAT IT'S
INADEQUATE AND HAS HIGHLIGHTED
SORT OF ACROSS THE BOARD
SYSTEMATIC CREASED AS ON THE
LEVEL OF WORK BUT AGAIN I THINK
THAT THE CHALLENGE WITH YOUR
YOUR- PARTICULAR- DEPARTMENT
THAT WE HAD IN THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE. IS EVERY- THEY
GET NOT I WITH THE TRUCK PARTS
PROJECT THE EVERYBODY COMES TO
THIS RIGHT IN EVERY EVERYBODY
SOLUTION TO EVERY PROBLEM WE
SEE IS JUST GETTING GETTING
MORE BCP'S GETTING MORE PEOPLE.
BRING IT OUT AND WE HAVE AN ALL
THAT SAID ON THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE NOT ON ALL THE OTHER
ISSUES ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE
THAT REALLY MAY NOT BE THE
RIGHT SOLUTION. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS WE
HAVE I THINK SOME FOLKS WHO
WANT TO MAKE STATEMENT YOU EACH
HAVE ONE MINUTE I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT BECAUSE WE'RE
REALLY BEHIND IN OUR SCHEDULE
TODAY. WE HAVE A- THREE MORE
ITEMS TO GO THROUGH AND WE'VE
ONLY DONE THREE SO WE'RE
HALFWAY THERE IN TERMS OF THE
ITEM SO YOU EACH HAVE ONE
MINUTE- TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
SOME OF YOU HAVE STATE MATERIAL
WITH ME EARLY SO I'M I'M AWARE
OF THE CONSTRAINTS SO WILL
BEGIN I THOUGHT. THE FIRST
PERSON YES- MADAM CHAIR DR
WEBBER- MEMBERS OF THE-
SUBCOMMITTEE MY NAME IS JOHN
LEVEL IT. ENDING A PLAYER CLUB
INTERNET THEIR BASE IN VAN BUT-
BEFORE I. IN IN ANOTHER LIFE I
WAS- ASSISTANT CHIEF DEPUTY LA
CITY CONTROLLER AND USED TO DO
AUDITS- WHAT I WOULD STRONGLY
COMMAND TO THIS COMMITTEE. IS
THAT BEFORE YOU TAKE ANY ACTION.
APPROPRIATING A NICKEL CUT IN
HALF FOR THESE ACTIVITIES YOU
GO BACK AND YOU REALLY LOOK AT
THE AUDIT AND YOU LOOK AT THE-
TAPE OF THE HEARING I MEAN I
THINK IT'S AT LEAST FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE. THIS IS NOT IN THE
WHEEL HOUSE OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE THE- AGENCY THAT IS
MORE EQUIPPED TO DO LICENSING
IS THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS THAT'S WHAT THEY DO.
AND THEY DO IT THEY DON'T MISS
DEADLINES- AND I WOULD-
SUGGESTS THAT THIS COMMITTEE
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT ALTERNATIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. VENTURE
MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS ED
MANNING WITH KP PUBLIC AFFAIRS
AND I- REPRESENT HAWAIIAN
GARDENS FEMALE. SO I WANT TO
TALK ON TWO LEVELS ONE I'D LIKE
TO ADDRESS THE- SEVERAL
REFERENCES TO LÏNG GARDENS.
BUT FIRST I'D LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT THE BAFFLING ON TESTIMONY
THAT WE HEARD. THE AUDIT
ADDRESSED LICENSING ISSUES AND-
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS
WITH THAT WHICH ARE WELL
ESTABLISHED SOMEHOW THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
MANAGED TO BOOTSTRAP ONTO AN
AUDIT THE RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE LICENSING PROCESS THE
JUSTIFICATION FOR THIRTY NEW.
E. WISE FOR ENFORCEMENT.
LICENSING IS NOT THE SAME AS
ENFORCEMENT ALTHOUGH THEY TRIED
TO CONFLATE TO ARM THE AUDIT AS
IS POINTED OUT IN THE ANALYSIS
BY THE LA OWN STAFF THE AUDIT
MAKES NO MENTION OF AN
ENFORCEMENT ISSUE YET YOU HAVE
IN FRONT OF YOU AND OVER FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET REQUEST
FOR THIRTY NEW PERMANENT HE-
FOR ENFORCEMENT WHICH- IS. NOT
JUSTIFIED AND JUST TO POINT OUT
ONE OF MANY FACTORS ONE YOU'VE
GOT LESS THAN HALF THE NUMBER
CAR CLUB JUDGE TWENTY YEARS AGO
CURRENTLY SO IF ANYTHING BEEN
MOUNTAIN THE PORTS AND SHOULD
BE DOWN SECOND YOU HAVE A
REGULATION THAT WILL ELIMINATE
50% OF THE GAMES BEING PLAYED
IN CARD CLUBS WHICH RAISES
OTHER CONCERNS BUT CERTAINLY
THERE WOULD BE A NEED FOR US
AND FORCE MEANT NOT MORE. UP IF
YOU THE WHOLE THING GUARD AND A
JUST THE ISSUE THAT WAS RAISED
JUST FOR THE COMMITTEES
PERSPECTIVE- VERY QUICKLY YES-
THAT WAS A AND SENATE
MINISTRATION FIND. THIS TO
CLEAR IT'S IN A MINUTE PENALTY
BY IN THE STRAIT OF AGENCY AND
I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION IT'S A RECORD
KEEPING VIOLATION. NOT MONEY
LAUNDERING NOT A CRIMINAL
VIOLATION NOT EVEN A CIVIL
VIOLATION AND I HAVE THAT
COMPLAINT I'M HAPPY TO SHARE
WITH THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. BUT I'M CHAIR TERRY
MCHALE WITH ERIN READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA GRAND CASINO. MADAM
CHAIR WE HAVE HALF AS MANY CARD
CLUBS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TODAY. THERE WE HAD
TWO DECADES AGO. AND IF THESE
ONEROUS NEW REGULATIONS COME
THROUGH WE MAY HAVE HALF. IN A
YEAR FROM NOW THAT WE HAVE IN
PLACE TODAY SO THE IDEA BAGS
THAT WE NEED. LESS REGULATION
AND ARE A LESSON FOR SPENT IN
CERTAINLY WAS BEING CALLED FOR-
BY THE- THE BUDGET REQUEST
TODAY. OF USE MY THIRTY SECONDS
TO SAY THIS. IN THE TWENTY FIVE
YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN DOING
THIS. IT IS RARE THAT I'VE EVER
SEEN SOMEONE COME TO THE
LEGISLATURE. TO ASK FOR THIS
MUCH. REINFORCEMENT THESE KINDS
OF P. WISE WITHOUT FIRST
EXPLAINING WHAT THEY ARE
ALREADY DOING WITH WHAT THEY
HAVE. AND SECOND OF ALL CLEARLY
DELINEATING WHAT THEY WOULD DO
WITH WHAT THEY WERE GIVEN. A
PREMATURE AND IT'S UNNECESSARY
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON-
CHAIRMAN- WEBER IN MEMBERS-
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ADDRESS YOU ON TODAY'S ITEM
I WILL BE VERY BRIEF BECAUSE
THE OVER IS GETTING LONG. MY
NAME IS TASHA SIR TO AND I'M
THE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
CITIES GAMING AUTHORITY OF THE
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY I'M ALSO
THE MAYOR OF THE CITY OF
GARDENA. I JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY STRONGLY OPPOSES THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THE
BUREAU OF GAMBLING CONTROL
BUDGET REQUEST FOR THIRTY NEW
POSITIONS THIS REQUEST IS
UNNECESSARY BECAUSE BROKE DOWN
THE CONTROL CURRENTLY HAS
THIRTY FOUR VACANT POSITIONS.
THE BUREAU OF GAMBLING CONTROL
ONLY AS I'M SORRY HIS OWN
FILLED A HUNDRED NINETY TWO OF
THE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY FUNDED
POSITIONS THE BILL HAS MADE NO
ATTEMPT TO EXPLAIN WHEN OR HOW
THEY WILL FEEL THE THIRTY FOUR
VACANT POSITIONS. LET ALONE
THIRTY ADDITION MISSIONS WHICH
IS ASK FOR WHICH WILL ONLY
INCREASE THE BUDGETS VACANCY
SIXTY FOUR POSITIONS WITH THE
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS INCREASE
PRESSURE. NOT LEGISLATOR HAS
PREVIOUS APPROVED EMBRACE.
THIRD TO A POSITION. WHICH MORE
THAN TWO THE BEER SLICES STAFF
STAFF. DESPITE THE INCREASE
STAFFING THE STATE AUDITOR'S
REPORT IN MAY OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN REVEALED THAT THE
PRODUCTIVITY ACTUALLY
DIMINISHED- WITH THE HIRING OF
THE ADDITIONAL STAFF AND THE
BACKLOG INCREASED. ARE THESE
POSITIONS EVEN NECESSARY. NO I
LIKE TO ALSO REFERENCE THE FACT
THAT THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA HAS ONE EMPLOYEE
PERK. NINE HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT
LICENSEES. ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE
CONTROL BOARD HAS ONE KHLOE PER
A HUNDRED NINETY SIX LICENSEES
SO AGAIN OUR POSITIONS PLEASED
TO KNOCK IT DEFINING THIS. VERY
MUCH MA'AM THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OF A NEW WAVE SHORT ON TIME SO
HOPEFULLY THOSE OF YOU WHO WANT
TO LAWS THAT. WE DON'T NEED THE
POSITIONS WE'VE HEARD YOU LOUD
AND CLEAR. YOU CAN SEE A LITTLE
SHORTER OKAY BUT THE OTHER IDEA.
ABOUT MAKE JEWEL IT YOU ALLOW.
TEND TO MY H. THAT MY THE
PATTERN ON. BEHALF AGAIN ASIAN.
THANK YOU. REPORTED A DISH
FUNNY FROM THE PAST AND I'M
HERE TO SAY THAT WERE TO THIS
ADDITIONAL WITHIN WE NEED TO
TAKE A STEP BACK IN A- NOW THAT
THE BACK SCHOOL AND ALSO THE
AUDITOR'S HAVE IN A WRECK OF
AND- ALLOW THEM TO DO THE WORK
AND SEE HOW THAT'S GONNA WORK
OUT FOR A GIVE THEM MORE
POSITIONS ALSO TO DATE SINCE
THE REALLY HOT IT WE HAVEN'T
HAD OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH
THE B. L. AND IS AN EMPLOYEE.
PLEASE BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO DO SO
NOT OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU. I'M
CHAIRING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MEGAN LOPER ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA COMMERCE CLUB
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION TODAY
AND THAT. AN ANALYSIS DONE B
THE STAFF THE AUDITOR ENDS AT
THE LA- AND THE DISCUSSION HERE
TODAY THE QUESTIONS RAISED BY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I'M
TALKING ABOUT THE DEBATE THAT
YOU ALWAYS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WHEN IT COMES TO PERMANENT
FUNDING VERSUS TEMPORARY.
FUNDING AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
THOUGHTFUL DISCUSSION HERE WE
ARE VERY CONCERNED. I WITH THIS
CURRENT REQUEST THANK YOU THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DANIELLE GARDEN HERE
REPRESENTING CASINO MERCED. I
WAS TELLING A FRIEND THIS
WEEKEND ABOUT THE BUDGET
REQUEST SEEKING TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF SWORN PEACE OFFICER
POSITIONS TO FIFTY EIGHT. WHEN
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS DEPARTMENT
INVESTIGATIONS THE COVERS THREE
POINT SIX MILLION PROFESSIONALS
HAS SIXTY SWORN PEACE OFFICERS.
THE BUREAU HAS ABOUT THIRTEEN
THOUSAND LICENSEES YOU CAN
IMAGINE MY FRIENDS CONFUSION
AND OUTRAGE. THE FUNDAMENTAL
FACTORS THE BUREAU'S BUDGET
REQUEST IS OUT OF PROPORTION
OTHER STATE AGENCIES AND TO
OTHER STATES. GAMBLING CONTROL
IN CALIFORNIA IS NOT IN NEED OF
MORE FUNDING TO AN INEFFICIENT
BUREAU IT NEEDS RESTRUCTURING.
A SYSTEM WHERE COSTS ARE
PROPERLY ALIGNED BETWEEN
LICENSING AND REGULATORY FEES
AND REDUCE BY GREATER
EFFICIENCY IS NEEDED. WE ASK
THE BUDGET REQUEST BE DENIED
AND ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONSIDER CONSOLIDATING THE
CURRENT PRICE FOR KIDS
STRUCTURE INTO AN EFFICIENT
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCY THAT SERVES
LICENSEES AND THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN A JUROR
PLANNING ON BEHALF OF LUCKY
CHANCES CASINO- ECHO THE
SENTIMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES AND
STRONGLY URGE YOU GUYS TO
CONSIDER- OF RECONSTRUCTING
THIS THIS AGENCY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ANY
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS. OKAY I
THINK WE'VE HEARD OF. BOTH ALL
SIDES AND WILL OBVIOUSLY TAKE
THAT IN CONSIDERATION WHEN WE
GET READY TO TALK ABOUT
BUDGETING AND MEETING THOSE
NEEDS IN THE REPORT TO COME
THE- THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THOSE OF YOU CAME. THAT THEN
BRINGS US TO OUR FOURTH ITEM
WHICH IS THE BUREAU OF FORENSIC
SERVICES. FUND AND EQUIPMENT
REFRESH. OKAY DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND THE LA. MANAGER CHRIS RYAN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
SO KEEP IT BRIEF- WE ARE ASKING
FOR A- PROPOSAL TO ASSIST WITH
THE BACK FILL IT WAS SOMETHING
THAT WAS DISCUSSED LAST YEAR-
IT WAS APPROVED LAST YEAR. FOR
ONE TIME ON A ONE TIME BASIS-
SO THE BACK FILL AMOUNT IS
THIRTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS-
GENERAL FUND. AND THERE'S ALSO
A SEVEN POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLAR EQUIPMENT. REFRESH
THAT'S ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
PROPOSAL AS WELL- I THINK LA-
HAS MAY HAVE SOME OTHER. ITEMS
TO DISCUSS BUT THAT'S OUR THAT
PROPOSAL. OKAY IN. BUT FOR
FINANCE ANY COMMENTS HELLO
HEAVILY WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE ARE
RECOMMENDING APPROVAL- THERE IS
THAT THERE HAS BEEN
JUSTIFICATION HOWEVER WE WOULD
NOTE THAT IT IS NOT A PERMANENT
FUNDING SOLUTIONS TO
SUPPORTING- THE BUREAU AND
SPECIFICALLY THIS ISSUE OF THE
DECLINE AN ON GOING CRIMINAL
FINE IF YOU REVENUE DEPOSIT
INTO DENIED IDENTIFICATION FUND
TO SUPPORT THEM. HAS BEEN
REQUIRED TO BACK FILL SINCE
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN SO
IT'S BEEN A NUMBER OF YEARS
THAT WE'VE BEEN DEALING WITH US
SO TO ADDRESS THIS ON A MORE
PERMANENT BASIS WE ARE
RECOMMENDING TAKING A DIFFERENT
APPROACH TO SUPPORTING- THE
BUREAU SPECIFICALLY WE ARE
RECOMMENDING REQUIRING THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO PARTIALLY
SUPPORT THE BUREAU BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BY HAVING
THEM PAY FOR A PORTION OF THE
SERVICES. THAT THEY RECEIVE AND
SO CURRENTLY- THESE LOCAL
AGENCIES ABOUT FORTY SIX
COUNTIES ARE NOT BEING CHARGED
FOR SERVICES AND THAT'S A
SUBSTANTIAL BENEFIT THAT THEY
RECEIVE- AT THE SAME TIME
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT IN CHARGE
FOR THEIR SERVICES THERE REALLY
IS LITTLE INCENTIVE TO THINK
ABOUT- HOW WHAT TYPE OF
EVIDENCE TO CLAPTON KIND
PRIORITIZING WHAT THE COMMITTED
TO JAY BEYOND. ITS CAPACITY AS
WE DO CAN I TAKE TIME TO
IMPLEMENT SO THAT IS WHY WE ARE
MANY ONE YEAR DELAY IN ADDITION
TO THAT ARE RECOMMENDING- THE
LEGISLATURE TO ACT TO BE OJ TO
REPORT PLAN FOR ALL CHELATING.
THE ARE. I'M THE LOCAL WOULD
REPRESENT WERE WRECKED WOULD UP
OF ABOUT 50% OF THE BUREAU'S
OPERATING BUDGETS- AND THIS
WOULD EFFECTIVELY REPLACE THE
AMOUNT OF GENERAL FUND THAT'S
BEING PROPOSED AS PART OF THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET DOJ AND WORKING
THROUGH THE PLAN COULD TALK TO
STAKEHOLDERS AND STRUCTURED IN
VARIOUS WAYS TO- RECOGNIZE YOU
KNOW DIFFERENT DIFFERENCES
BASED ON THE TYPE OF FRIENDS EX
SERVICE THAT'S OFFERED ON THE
SIZE OF THE AGENCY AND ALSO
SPEED OF SERVICE AND SO WE
WOULD RECOMMEND XIN OF THAT
REPORT IN TIME FOR CONSIDER. AS
PART OF MY PEERS BUT AND IF THE
STRUCTURE PER LEE IT WOULD
PROVIDE A PERMANENT FUNDING
SOLUTION TO SUPPORT THEIR
OPERATIONS I'M JUST ONE LAST
PIECE- THERE IS A SEPARATE
REQUEST FOR NINE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME FOR
THIS CONSOLIDATED FORENSIC
LABORATORY THAT WAS REFERENCED
PREVIOUSLY THIS NEW APPROACH
COULD CHANGE DOJ'S WORKLOAD IN
OPERATIONS AND SO TO THE EXTENT
IT DOES WE JUST RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECT DOJ TO MAKE
SURE THAT ANY FUTURE FUNDING
FOR REFLECT THOSE CHANGES. WE
HAVE. COME ANY QUESTIONS
MEMBERS. OKAY ONLY ONLY
QUESTION I HAD WAS AND THIS IS-
AND MAYBE YOU CAN REASSURED ME
THAT THAT WOULD BE FINE THAT IF
WE START CHARGING SOME OF THESE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FOR SERVICES
THAT THEY MAY WANT FEWER
SERVICES IN A TIME WHERE WE
PROBABLY NEED GREATER SERVICE
IS GIVEN THE NUMBER OF ISSUES
THAT ARE BROUGHT UP AND PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN- SOMEHOW ANOTHER
EXONERATED BECAUSE OF DNA
EVIDENCE AND SO FORTH AND SO
ON. HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT
THEY'LL BE FAIRNESS AND EQUITY
FOR ALL PERSONS IF WE YOU KNOW
IN SOME JURISDICTIONS CHOOSE
NOT TO USE YOU AS MUCH BECAUSE
IT ON THE RESOURCES A MAN CHAIR
BERRY MILLER FROM THE
GIRLFRIEND SIX SERVICES AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT ON THAT QUESTION- WE
THE SHORT ANSWER IS WE DON'T-
THAT'S OUR CONCERN AS WELL IS
THAT. IF WE DO START TO- PUT A
FINE ON LOCAL AGENCIES FOR
FORENSIC SERVICES THERE WILL BE
HARD CHOICES THAT HAVE TO BE
MADE ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
SOMEBODY CAN AFFORD TO SUBMIT A
PIECE OF EVIDENCE THAT MAY OR
MAY NOT LEAD TO. A ANALYSIS
THAT ACTUALLY PROVIDES CLOSER
TO A CASE WE'RE ALSO VERY
CONCERNED WITH THE FACT THAT-
THERE WOULDN'T BE EQUAL ACCESS
TO THAT JUSTICE WITH THE
VICTIMS OF CALIFORNIA THAT
ACTUALLY DO WANT THEIR EVIDENCE
ANALYZED. AND WE DID PROVIDE A
REPORT TALKING A LOT ABOUT
THAT- IN AN ASSESSMENT OF WHERE
WE WERE IN THE BUREAU OF
FORENSIC SERVICES RELATED
SPECIFICALLY TO- MANY OF THOSE
QUESTIONS. YES MADAM CHAIR
EDWARD MACHADO. SO PRIOR TO
THIS POSITION I WAS PLEASE SHE
FOR ELEVEN YEARS AND CITY
MANAGER FOR TWO AND I CAN TELL
YOU THAT WHEN WE START LOOKING
AT MAKING DECISIONS- OF WHAT TO
SEND IN BASED ON WHAT AN ITEM
WAS GONNA COST TO BE PROCESSED
BY A FORENSIC LAB WILL
DEFINITELY BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION BY NOT ONLY
PLEASE CHOOSE BUT CITY MANAGERS
WHO HAVE TO DO SO LOCAL CITY
BUDGETS. AND IT WAS AS THE LA-
SAID YOU KNOW THEY'RE GOING TO
MAKE SOME DECISIONS ON
PRIORITIZING WHAT EVIDENCE TO
SEND TEN- THE PROBLEM WITH THAT
IS WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT
EVIDENCE WILL PRODUCE IN TERMS
OF SENDING SOMETHING AND THAT
IS OF HIGH VALUE OUR LOW VALUE
CONNECTS THE DOTS TWO OF THE
CRIMES THAT WE DON'T KNOW- THAT
COMMITTED HOW CAN IT HELP US.
MAKE A CASE FOR EXAMPLE OTHER
INDIVIDUALS IT'S HARD TO TELL-
THE MORE INFORMATION THE MORE
SAMPLES WE HAVE THE MORE
EVIDENCE THAT'S TURNED ON I
THINK. MORE PEOPLE ARE SERVED-
IT IN TERMS OF THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM. THEN IF FOR MAKING
DECISIONS ON HOW MUCH IT COST
TO SEND SOMETHING IN. ANYONE
ELSE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I THAT
THAT'S MY MAJOR CONCERN WITH
THE WITH THE PROPOSAL- MAYBE
I'VE BEEN- INUNDATED WITH
READING THE BOOK JUST MURPHY
JUST MERCY. AND KNEW MOST OF
THE STUFF BUT I WAS AS ONE ONCE
AGAIN. AS THE GOVERNOR SAID
IT'S BETTER TO BE GUILTY AND
RATES THAN TO BE POOR AND THE
SECOND CALIFORNIA. SO THAT'S
ALWAYS A CONCERN OF MINE THAT
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT WHAT
WE DO. I SERVICES PROVIDED FOR
EVERYONE AND SOMETIMES PUTTING
FEEL ME SERVICES- THEY'LL MAKE
A DECISION NOT TO GO THAT WAY
IN A MAYES TOLERATE THE PERSON
OR THEY'LL MAKE SURE THAT THEY
WERE THE ONLY PUTTING THE
THINGS THAT I WANT TO CONVICT
SOMEBODY BUT NOT EXONERATE
PEOPLE SO. IT'S AN ONGOING A
BATTLE I GUESS WITH THE
QUESTION OF BECAUSE EVERYONE
DESERVES THE SAME LEVEL OF
JUSTICE. AND THAN OTHERS YOU
KNOW AND I THINK EVERYONE
DESERVES A LAB THAT'S REALLY
FUNCTIONAL AND REALLY SUPPORT
IT. AND THAT'LL BIG SEATS CAN
DO THAT A LITTLE BIT BETTER
THAN WELL CITIES AND- SOLD IT
BUT THAT'S ALWAYS A CHALLENGE
OKAY. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. OKAY
WILL TO HEAR FROM. OVER THE
LAST THREE GROUP THAT WOULD DO
HERE. OF PUBLIC COMMENTS AND
ONCE FOR THOSE TWO GROUPS WOULD
NOT AT THE FIFTH ITEM WHICH IS
UPDATE- I'M SORRY TO. CATCH ME
EITHER. TO ANY WHO TURNED YOU
OWN. LARA. I THINK THESE THINGS
OF US AROUND A- YOU KNOW RECALL
ALL I THOUGHT MIKE. OH MY
GOODNESS MAKES PARANOID UPDATE
ON INTEGRATED SUBSTANCE- USE
DISORDER TREATMENT PROGRAM. WE
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS CDC ARE FROM THE
FINANCE AND THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S TALKING UPDATED ON
INTEGRATED SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT PROGRAM YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MY
NAME IS- DOING READER I WORK
FOR CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
HEALTH CARE SERVICES- WE'VE
BEEN ASKED TO COME FORWARD AND
GIVE AN UPDATE ON THE
INTEGRATED SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT PROGRAM SO I
HAVE WITH ME HERE LISA HINES
THE- THE PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR
THAT PROJECT. AND SHE'S GONNA
GET SOME UPDATES ON SOME OF THE
NUMBERS AND WHEREAS. THANK GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
FOR GIVING US THIS OPPORTUNITY
AND I SHE DE PROGRAM IS A
DEPARTMENTS COMPREHENSIVE
INTEGRATED RESPONSE TO BOTH AS
SHE DE AN OPIOID CRISIS FACING
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATION THE
PROJECT IS SUPPORTED AT THE
HIGHEST LEVELS WITH SECRETARY
DHEAS AND RECEIVER KELSO
SUPPORTING AND ENSURING THAT WE
CAN OVERCOME ANY BARRIERS TO
IMPLEMENTATION ARE TUG TARGET
POPULATION FOR THIS PROGRAM IS
THOSE THAT ARE LEAVING FIFTEEN
TO TWENTY FOUR MONTHS PRIOR TO
RELEASE FROM STATE PRISON WHO
MAY HAVE A SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER. THOSE WHO ARE AT HIGH
RISK OF SUBSTANCE USE OR
OVERDOSE WHY THEY ARE
INCARCERATED NCDC ARW AND THOSE
THAT COME TO US ON MATT ALREADY
FROM I COUNTY JAIL FACILITY THE
PROGRAM OVERVIEW AT THE HIGHEST
LEVEL IS AND- UNIVERSAL
SCREENING FOLLOWED BY
ASSESSMENTS BASED ON THE LEVEL
OF AS AS SCREENING OUTCOME
FOLLOWED BY A REFERRAL TO THE
MEDICATED ASSISTED TREATMENT
PROCESS. AND COGNITIVE
BEHAVIORAL AND INTERVENTIONS
THAT LAST UP TO TWELVE MONTHS
AND THE PROJECT ALSO HAS A
ROBUST PRE RELEASE PROCESS
ATTACHED TO IT AS WELL AS A
TRANSITION TO OUR COMMUNITY
PARTNERS FOR THE 50% PLAN THOSE
THAT LEAD TO A COUNTY IS BANK
BE AT RECEIVING PARTICIPANTS
WHO ARE ON MEDICAID ASSISTED
TREATMENT- THE PROJECT TIMELINE
YEAH I. THE FUNDING. THANK YOU
THAT AND WITH IMMEDIATE AND- OF
TWENTY NINETEEN WITH PLANNING
AND IMPLEMENTATION PROCESSES
ARE PLANNING. HAS A TRANSITION
FOR AT LEAST THE INITIAL WE ARE
STE CURRENTLY SERVING CLIENTS
AT ALL THIRTY FIVE PRISONS AND
THE AT LEAST FROM SCREENING
THAT STARTED ON JANUARY TWENTY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY. WITH
OUR COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL
INTERVENTIONS COMING ONLINE FEB
YOU WERE AT THE END OF
FEBRUARY. AT TO DATE WE HAVE
68% OF OUR POSITIONS FOR CCH
YES FILL. OF WE HAVE A TOTAL OF
50% OF THE AUTHORIZED POSITIONS
FILLED FOR THIS PROJECT. AND
THE ANNUAL GOAL IS TO PROVIDE
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND OF ARE RELEASING
INMATES PLUS THOSE WHO ARE IN
OUR INSTITUTION HI RESTORE CITY
AT HIGH RISK FOR OVERDOSE. AND
THOSE WHO COME IN A MATCH WITH
THIS PRODUCT PROGRAM- AS OF
FEBRUARY TWENTY NINTH SIX WEEKS
INTO THE PROGRAM WE HAD A
EIGHTY ONE SS 81% OF OUR
ELIGIBLE. OF INMATES LEAVING
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR MONTHS-
WE HAD ALSO MOVED APPROXIMATELY
15% OF THOSE ONTO THE
ASSESSMENT PHASE. WE HAVE A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE NEW
INMATES ON MEDICATED ASSISTED
TREATMENT. AND WE HAVE SEVEN
ACTIVE CLASSES OF COGNITIVE
BEHAVIORAL INTERVENTIONS. I'M
HAPPY ANY COMMENTS FROM
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. LA NEWCOMER.
NUMBER SEVEN COMMENTS. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO THE
FLOOR. ALL THAT WILL THEN MOVE
US TO OUR FINAL ITEM WITH THE
SUICIDES IN PRISON. WE'RE GOING
TO INVITE OF TIFFANY JOHN
THOMAS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION STEVE DONE N. THIS
IS THE DRUMS GIVE THIS IS PANEL
ONE IN CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION AS
WELL AND THEN WE'LL HAVE PANEL
TWO OF THAT WILL COME UP AFTER
THAT OKAY PANEL ONE. TIFFANY
JOHNSON AND STEVE THERE HAVE.
TOM THOMAS YEAH WHAT IS A
JOHNSON. MY BRAIN IS GONE FIFTY
DOLLARS A OKAY. SO GOOD MORNING
FIRSTLY MADAM CHAIR AND ARE
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
ALMOST LEAVING YEAH. I'M
TOMATOES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA- CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION I'M ALSO
SITTING BOARD MEMBER AT THE
CHAPTER PRESIDENT OF SAN CLIMB.
AND FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU
OFFER LET MUST BE HERE THIS IS
MY FIRST TIME DOING SOMETHING
LIKE THIS SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE TIME YOU'RE
GIVING US. I'VE BEEN A
DEPARTMENT FOR APPROXIMATELY
NINETEEN YEARS AS A
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER. DURING
THAT TIME COMING AND IT
BASICALLY THE TURN OF THE
CENTURY I'VE BEEN A PART OF THE
BEGINNING STAGE OF THE CHANGE
WHERE WE WENT FROM THE OLD WAY
OF DOING THINGS. TWO ONE ALL
THE NEW PROGRAMS CAME ON AND I
THAT I CAN SEE A LOT OF
POSITIVES AND HOW IT HELPS THE
COMMUNITIES AND THINGS LIKE
THAT BUT THERE ARE ALSO SOME
ISSUES. IN REGARDS TO HOW THAT
AFFECTS US AS OFFICERS BECAUSE
WE'VE KIND OF BECOME THE
FORGOTTEN ONCE. I LEARNED EARLY
IN MY CAREER THAT MY POWER OF
OBSERVATION. WAS ONE OF THE
MOST POWERFUL TOOLS IN MY TO
ABOUT. HAVING THE TIME AN
ABILITY TO LEARN THE INMATES
HABITS AND ROUTINES. I BECAME A
GREAT PREDICTOR OF EVENTS AND
PRO ACTIVELY SAVE A LOT OF
LIVES. STAFF AND INMATES ALIKE.
HOWEVER THE DECREASING STAFFING
LEVELS. IN THE FACE OF
INCREASING PROGRAMS. NO LONGER
AFFORD THIS THE TIME TO OBSERVE
WE'RE ESPECIALLY TAXIS GETTING
ONE IN MAY TWO POINT AB AND C.
AND THEN RE ACTIVELY RIAGE IN
ALONE IN AN INCIDENT THAT COULD
HAVE BEEN PREVENTED. RESULTING
IN INCREASING VIOLENCE AND
OFFICER EXPOSURE. TO TRAUMA AND
CRITICAL INCIDENTS. LET ME
REITERATE I WILL NOT GRIPE
ABOUT THE PROGRAMS. I'M FROM
THE BAY AREA AND I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THAT THOSE INMATES.
WILL BE COMING OUT ON THE
STREETS AND THEY WILL BE MY
NEIGHBORS. THEY WILL BE THE
PARENTS OF THE CHILDREN. IN OUR
SCHOOLS. THEY WILL BE IN OUR
GROCERY STORES IN OUR CHURCH
WITH US. THE ISSUE IS THAT WITH
THE AND- OF THE PROGRAMS.
YOU'RE DECREASING STAFFING
LEVELS. AND INFLICTING SOME
WOUNDS THAT HAVE YET TO BE.
IDENTIFIED OR ACKNOWLEDGED. FOR
THE STAFF THAT ATTEST TO CARRY
OUT THAT JOB. THE FIRST DECADE
OF MY CAREER I SPENT SEVERAL
DAYS A WEEK MANDATED TO WORKING
SIXTEEN HOUR SHIFT DURING THE
STREET EIGHT AND SIXTEEN HOUR
SHIFTS SPENDING MORE TIME IN
PRISON THAN AT HOME. I WAS TAX
WAS THE MOST CHALLENGING
CONDITIONS IN DEALING WITH THE
POPULOUS THAT HAS BEEN
CONDITIONED TO THINK THAT WE
ARE THE ENEMY WHICH IS IN
DIRECT OPPOSITION TO
MAINTAINING THEIR SAFETY AND
SECURITY AS WELL AS OURS. WE
WITNESS EXTREME I WAS A
VIOLENCE OVER THIRTY PLUS YEAR
CAREER. THAT IS A DRAMATIC
IMPACT ON A PHYSICAL HEALTH.
AND MENTAL ILLNESS. WE'RE
DEALING WITH A POPULATION OF
TRAUMATIZED PEOPLE. THAT
INFLICT INFLICT TRAUMA OR OTHER
INMATES AND STAFF. AND THEN WE
ARE EXPECTED TO GO HOME AND
MANAGE THAT TRAUMA. WITH
OURSELVES. AND TRYING NOT TO RE
TRAUMATIZE THEIR FAMILIES. BY
EXPLAINING WHAT WE SAW DURING
THE DAY. MUCH LIKE INMATES WE
GET INSTITUTIONALIZED. IT'S NOW
REFER TO AS CORRECTION FATIGUE.
WITHOUT GIVING IT A NAME BUT WE
STILL LACK THE RESOURCES TO
ADDRESS IT. THE LACK OF
TENDERNESS MEETING IN
CONNECTION THE ENVELOPES THE
PRISON CULTURE AFTER CONTINUE
TO EXPOSURE DOES SOMETHING TO
OUR MINDS BECAUSE I AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER WE SPEND MORE
TIME IN PRISON. THAN WE DO AT
HOME. IF YOU INCLUDE THE PREP
TIME TO COME TO PRESENT. AND
THE DEBRIEFING PROCESS THAT WE
HAVE TO DO THERE ARE COMMUTE SO
THAT WE DON'T COME HOME A
BECOME APATHETIC ROBOT STORE
FAMILIES. PERSONALLY THAT
REALIZATION CAME TO FRUITION
SEVERAL YERS AGO. AT A SOCIAL
FUNCTION WITH MY FAMILY WHEN I
EXPERIENCE THE ARTS THE STATION
OF BEING A SPECTATOR IN MY OWN
LIFE. AS IF I'M WATCHING THE
WORLD HAPPEN AROUND ME VERSUS
ENGAGING. AND PARTICIPATING I
NOW UNDERSTAND WHY THERE'S A
HIGH LEVEL SUBSTANCE ABUSE
AMONG THE RANKS IT TAKES THAT
TO TAKE THE CHILL OFF. WITH
RESPECT TO TIME OF SHARE A
COUPLE OF EXPERIENCES IF YOU
DON'T MIND. WHEN AN INMATE
JUMPED TO THEIR DEATH FROM THE
FOURTH HERE. EVEN THOUGH THEIR
BRAIN APPEARS TO BE UNCONSCIOUS
THEIR ARMS AND LEGS CONTINUED
MOVED IN A FAILED ATTEMPT TO
GET UP. WITH THEIR SHATTERED
FACE AND TORSO STUCK TO THE
GROUND. DID YOU KNOW THAT WHEN
THE OXYGEN IS DEPLETED FROM THE
BRAIN ONE ONE HANGS THEMSELVES.
THEIR BODIES FOUGHT VIOLENTLY
LIKE A FISH. WHAT WERE TASKED.
TO TRY TO CUT THEM DOWN SAFELY.
I FORGOT TO MENTION THEIR FACES
BLOW UP TWICE THE SIZE THAT'S
AN IMAGE YOU CAN'T GET OUT OF
YOUR HEAD BUT YOU'RE NOT GONNA
COME HOME AND TELL YOUR SPOUSE
YOUR CHILDREN ABOUT THAT. FOR
ONE YOU DON'T WANT TO
TRAUMATIZE THEM BUT NUMBER TWO
YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
YOU EVERY DAY WHILE YOU'RE AT
WORK. THAT IS OUR NORMAL THAT
WE EXISTING HENCE WHY REGULARLY
GET CAUGHT PHONE CALLS FROM MY
PARTNER STRUGGLING BETWEEN THE
HOURS OF MIDNIGHT TO AM. THERE
TOO AFRAID TO CONTACT THE PEER
SUPPORT TEAM. BECAUSE THEY'RE
AFRAID OF CONFIDENTIALITY.
AFRAID THAT ONE WRONG WORD
WOULD RESULT IN A WEAPONS
RESTRICTION THAT WILL TAKE
THEIR JOB FROM THEM. IT WILL BE
FURTHER UP THE CREEK WITHOUT A
PADDLE. I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT WE
GRACIOUSLY RECOGNIZE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN VERY
SUPPORTIVE. IN OUR ENDEAVORS TO
CULTIVATE EXPAND WELL THIS TOOL
FOR STAFF SUCH AS PEER SUPPORT
ME P. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU TO IMPROVE
THOSE CONDITIONS WITHIN THE
WALLS AND THOSE PROGRAMS. AND
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT WE WANT TO
COLLABORATE WITH YOU. BECAUSE
WE REALLY DO APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'VE DONE AS FAR THAT
CORRECTIONAL FATIGUE THAT'S
COME ONLINE. IS THE FIRST STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION WE WANT
TO WORK WITH YOU TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT. ACTUALLY WORKS FOR A
MEMBERS. THANK YOU YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MY NAME
IS STEVEN TERMS I HAVE BEEN
EMPLOYED AT THE CITY I CATCH ME
FOR TWENTY TWO YEARS AS A
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER. OVER MY
CAREER I'VE WITNESSED MANY
EXTREME EVENTS OR VIOLENT ACTS
IN SUICIDES NOT ONLY WITH MY
PARTNERS BUT MY- BY. INMATES
EARLY IN MY CAREER IS WORKING A
UNIT AND WE WERE FEEDING THE
EVENING MEAL. OUR PARTNER YELLS
OUT THAT WE HAVE A HANGER. TWO
OF US WENT INTO THE CELL AS I
WRAP MY ARMS AROUND THE INMATE
AND CARED LIFTED THEM UP. MY
OTHER PARTNER JUMPED UP AND
TOOK THE NEEDS ARE. THAT WAS
NINETEEN YEARS AGO AND I STILL
SEE THE ENEMY IN MY MIND. OKAY.
START LIKE AFTER THE INCIDENT
WE'RE OFFER PEER SUPPORT IN
BEING A YOUNG THE NEW OFFER I
BELIEVED I WAS SUPERMAN I
REFUSE AND WHEN I GOT HOME THAT
NIGHT I CLOSED MY EYES AND
COULD SEE THE INMATE WHO HAD
DIED. NO MATTER HOW LONG AGO
WAS SIGNIFICANT EVENT OR
INCIDENT HAS HAPPENED IN OUR
CAREERS. WE CAN RECALL ALMOST
EVERY SENSE OR A LITTLE DETAILS.
THAT'S CORRECT LAUNCHERS WE SEE
THINGS THAT NO PERSON SHOULD BE
SUBJECTED TO. WE HAVE BEEN WE
HAVE SEEN AN INCREASE OF STAFF
SUICIDES THAT HAS BECOME AN
EPIDEMIC. IN HIS LEAVING THOSE
ALL SCRAMBLING TO UNDERSTAND
THIS IS. I BELIEVE FIRST WE
MUST LOOK AT WHAT HAS CHANGED
IN THE DEPARTMENT DURING THIS
TURN. WE SAW AN INCREASE OF. IN
SUICIDES DURING THE FURLOUGH
TIMES AS MANY OF OUR PARTNERS
WERE LOSING EVERYTHING THEY OWN
AS WE LOST 15% OF OUR PAY.
AFTER THAT WE SAW IN A
SIGNIFICANT DECREASE IN
STAFFING STANDARDIZED STAFFING.
THAT THE STATE HAS ATTEMPTED TO
USE A STANDARD STANDARDIZE RULE
WHEN EACH AND EVERY PERSON IS
DIFFERENT BASED ON LAYOUT AND
DESIGN OR PROGRAM. THIS
REDUCTION IS LEAVING OUR PRISON
STAFFING LEVELS SO LOW THAT IT
IS ALL BUT IMPOSSIBLE TO GET
THE JOB DONE. MOST EMPLOYEES IN
THE DEPARTMENT YOU DON'T WANT
TO FAIL IN THEIR TAX BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THEY ARE. THIS IS
WHAT THE STAFF CUTTING CORNERS
JUST TO GET THE INMATES TO THE
PROGRAMS. WHICH OPENS OURSELVES
UP FOR DISCIPLINE TO THE
DEPARTMENT. ANOTHER ISSUE THAT
HAS CHANGED. IN THE DEPARTMENT
HAS BEEN THE RELEASE A LOWER
LEVEL WITH OFFENDERS AND THIS
IS LEFT US WITH THE MOST
VIOLENT INMATES REGULATION
STRANGERS DEBTORS TIED THE
DEPARTMENT'S HANDS IN DEALING
WITH A MADE TO FILL THE PROGRAM
AND ARE IN A MORE VIOLENT
TOWARDS STAFF AND OTHER
INMATES. MOST OF OUR LEVEL FOUR
YARDS IN THE STATE HAVE SEEN AN
INCREASE IN VIOLENCE IT IS
ROUTINE FOR OUR STAFF TO DEAL
WITH MULTIPLE BY THAT THE VENTS
THROUGHOUT THE DAY. WOOD
NOBILITY THAT THE COMPRESS OR
EVEN WRITE A REPORT BEFORE THE
NEXT VIOLENT EVENT. THE CYCLE
CONTINUES SOMETIMES INTO THE
MAKESHIFT OR THE NEXT DAY. THE
LEVEL OF VIOLENCE THAT STAFF
FOR BEING SUBJECTED TO IT'S
CAUSING AN INCREASE IN THE
CASES OF PTSD. ADDING TO THIS
PROBLEM IS THE FACT THAT. WHEN
AN OFFICER NEEDS TO TAKE A DAY
OFF. FOR THEIR OWN MENTAL WELL
BEING ANY OVERTIME THAT THEY
HEARD GETS CONVERTED TO NORMAL
PAY. THIS GREAT FEAR THAT THEIR
PAY WILL BE REDUCED AND MEANS
OFFERS ARE LESS LIKELY TO TAKE
THE TIME OFF THAT THEY NEED TO
RECOVER. THE DEPARTMENT HAS A
PEER SUPPORT PROGRAM. AN EDP
HOWEVER MOST EMPLOYEES WILL NOT
UTILIZE IT. OUT OF FEAR WORST
FEARS DERIVED FROM HELP QUICKLY
DEPARTMENT TRIES TO DISCIPLINE
STAFF FOR THE SMALLEST
INFRACTION AND THAT MOST
EMPLOYEES FEEL THAT THESE
PROGRAMS WILL PUT THEIR CAREER
RISK. SO STAFF WILL PUSH
THROUGH. AND DEAL WITH. AND
PTSD CONTINUES TO CREEP UP.
THIS COULD BE IN THE FORM OF
SELF MEDICATION ALCOHOL OR
OTHER FORMS RATHER THAN TRULY
DEALING WITH THE ISSUES
ULTIMATELY EVERY PERSON HAS A
BREAKING POINT AND IS DIFFERENT
FOR EVERYONE. FOR SOME THAT IS
IN THE FORM OF SUICIDE FOR
OTHERS THEY RESOLVE. BOTH OF
WHICH HARM THE DEPARTMENTS OVER
ON YOUR HOUSE. ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS. STILL FIFTH. THANK
YOU BOTH FOR SHARING THAT
INFORMATION I MEAN WE ARE TRULY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE- NOT ONLY
THE INMATES WITH THOSE WHO WORK
IN OUR IN OUR FACILITIES AS
WELL AND THEIR WELL BEING
THAT'S WHY WE ASKED YOU TO
COME. OF IT. THERE ARE. THE
VICTIMS IN AN ON A ALL SIDES
WITH REGARDS TO WHAT IS
HAPPENING WHEN YOU HAVE A
SYSTEM LIKE WE HAVE. PEOPLE
TRYING TO WORK FOR HARDEN SO
MANY AND IF CONFRONTED WITH SO
MANY ISSUES THEMSELVES- SO- I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR AT LEAST-
SHARING THAT WITH US AS WE
BEGIN TO LOOK FOR SOLUTIONS. TO
SOME OF THE PROBLEMS WE FACE
WITH OUR OF OUR EMPLOYEES AS
WELL AS WITH THE INMATES. OF A
AND MAKING SURE THAT. WE DO
WHATEVER WE CAN IN SUCH A VERY
INTENSE. PROFESSIONS AND
SOMEONE THANK YOU BOTH FOR. OF
FOR THE WORK THAT YOU DO. THANK
YOU YOU KNOW AND- AND BEING
ABLE TO OF. CONTINUE TO WORK
AND THAT'S THAT'S DIFFICULT I
KNOW WE LOSE A LOT OF FOLKS NOT
ONLY IN IN THE PRISONS BUT ALSO
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT ITSELF THERE
THE YOU KNOW WHEN SOMETHING
HAPPENS HORRIBLE- IT AFFECTS
EVERYBODY. IN SO THAT'S WHY WE
DO WHAT WE CAN TO TRY TO
MINIMIZE THE OF THE IMPACT. AS
WELL AS PROVIDE THE SUPPORT AND
SERVICES THAT PEOPLE ME IN ON
SO THAT'LL BE IMPORTANT IN OUR
IN OUR CONSIDERATION OF THE
THINGS WE'RE LOOKING AT BUT WE
ARE GREATLY CONCERNED GREATLY
CONCERNED. QUE WE HAVE ANOTHER
PANEL- THAT'S MADE UP OF A
PRISONER SUICIDES AND THIS WAS
SOMEONE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. ALSO MICHAEL
BEHAN ROSEN BIEN GALVAN AND-
ROME FELL THE CO COUNSELS ON
COLD ONE VERSE NEWSOME AND
ARMSTRONG VERSUS NEWSOME- AS
WELL AS DOCTOR LAVERICK. NOT
FREAKED. WHO'S A SENIOR
PSYCHIATRIST AND SPECIALISES
CDC OCT OKAY. FIRST OKAY. YOU
CAN. GOOD AFTERNOON- MADAM
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR INVITING
ME TODAY- I'VE BEEN
REPRESENTING PEOPLE WITH
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS AND CART
INCARCERATED IN CALIFORNIA'S
PRISONS MORE THAN THIRTY FIVE
YEARS MY NAME IS MICHAEL BEING.
MY OFFICE IS CO COUNSEL FOR THE
COLEMAN PLAINTIFF CLASS ALL
PRISONERS OF SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS IN THE C. D. C. R. A
CASE THAT'S BEEN PENDING BUT OR
NOT SINCE NINETEEN NINETY.
SUICIDES ARE THE ULTIMATE
FAILURE OF A MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM AND SEE YOU SEE OURS
THIRTY EIGHT SUICIDES IN TWENTY
NINETEEN WAS A TRAGIC RECORD.
THERE'S BEEN A MULTI YEAR TREND
OF WORSENING RATES OF SUICIDES
IN OUR PRISONS. CCAR'S TWENTY
NINETEEN RATE OF SUICIDE WAS
THIRTY POINT THREE PER HUNDRED
THOUSAND ALMOST DOUBLE THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE OF SIXTEEN PER
HUNDRED THOUSAND. THE RATE OF
SUICIDES AND SEIZE YOUR PRISONS
HAS SUBSTANTIALLY INCREASED
EACH YEAR FOR THE PAST SIX
YEARS. OF THE RATE WAS SIXTEEN
POINT NINE PER HUNDRED THOUSAND
AND TWENTY FOURTEEN. CCAR'S
HOMICIDE RATE IS ALSO FAR
HIGHER THAN THE NATIONAL PRISON
RAPE. TWENTY SEVEN OF THE
THIRTY EIGHT PERSONS WHO
COMMITTED SUICIDE IN TWENTY
NINETEEN WERE COMMON CLASS
MEMBERS SUFFERING FROM SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS. MANY HAD BEEN
MOVED TO HIGHER LEVELS OF CARE
SUCH AS PSYCHIATRIC CRISIS BEDS
IN HOSPITALS AND MONTHS BEFORE
THEIR DATHS AND THEN
DISCHARGED PRIOR TO THEIR
SUICIDES. TEN OF THE SUICIDES
RUN SEGREGATION. THE RATE OF
SUICIDE SINCE IT'S CCR
SEGREGATION UNITS REMAINS
EXTREMELY HIGH. TWO HUNDRED
ELEVEN PER HUNDRED THOUSAND.
WELL CECE ARE SHOULD BE
COMMENDED FOR REDUCING ITS USE
OF SEGREGATION IN THE AST FEW
YEARS COLEMAN CLASS MEMBERS
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO SAID YOU
SEE OUR CONSIDERS THE MOST
SERIOUSLY ILL. ARE FAR MORE
LIKELY TO BE IN SEGREGATION AND
OTHER PRISONERS AND OUR OUR
FARM PLEADED DIED OF SUICIDE
AND SEGREGATION. IN TWENTY
NINETEEN SEVEN OF THE TEN
SEGREGATION SUICIDES WERE BY
COMMON CLASS MEMBERS. CSP SACK
EXPERIENCED NINE SUICIDES IN
TWENTY NINETEEN FAR ABOVE ANY
OTHER SINGLE PRISON IN THE PAST
TWENTY YEARS. BUT ZACK HAS HAD
A BAD RECORD FOR SUICIDE OVER
THE LAST TWENTY YEARS LEADING
ALL CALIFORNIA PRISONS. SAC
ALSO EXPERIENCED FIVE HOMICIDES
IN TWENTY NINETEEN AND ONE SO
FAR IN TWENTY TWENTY. AS WELL
AS NUMEROUS STAFF ASSAULTS
INCLUDING SOME VERY SERIOUS
STABBINGS OF OFFICERS. THIS IS
AN EXTREMELY DANGEROUS PRISON
IN A DANGEROUS PRISON SYSTEM.
HERE ARE SOME MORE DETAILS
ABOUT THIS TWENTY NINETEEN
SACKS SUICIDES ALL INE WERE
COMMON CLASS MEMBERS AND EIGHT
IN THE NINE RIGHT THE E. O. P.
LEVEL OF CARE MEANING THEY
NEEDED A VERY HIGH LEVEL OF
MENTAL HEALTH CARE AND
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT UNIT. SIX
OF THE NINE WERE IN SEGREGATION
OR SOLITARY CONFINEMENT UNITS
FOR EACH FOR. PEAS FIVE IN IN
UNIT CALLED THE PS YOU AND ONE
IN THE E. O. P. A. S. U. UNIT.
ALL TREATMENT IN THESE UNITS
ARE PROVIDED AND TREATMENT
MODULES CAGES. WE PROVIDED
PHOTOS OF TREATMENTS IN CAGES
TO THE COMMITTEE WHICH WERE
REPRODUCED IN THE AGENDA. WHILE
SOME PATIENTS IN THESE UNITS
HAVE TV'S. THE CABLE SYSTEM
NEEDS REPAIR PLACEMENTS OF THE
TV'S ARE USELESS. FOR THE NINE
SUICIDES AT SAC INVOLVE RECENT
DISCHARGES FROM A LICENSE
PSYCHIATRIC CRISIS OR HOSPITAL
UNIT WITHIN A FEW WEEKS. AND AS
LITTLE AS FIVE HOURS BEFORE THE
SUICIDE. SIX OF THE NINE
SUICIDE HAVE BEEN RECENTLY
HOSPITALIZED AT C. H. C. F.
STOCKTON PSYCHIATRIC INPATIENT
PROGRAM. A NINE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR FACILITY. WHICH IS
COMPLETELY. WHICH IS
TRANSFERRED FROM THE DEPARTMENT
STATE HOSPITAL TO SEE YOU SEE
ARE OUT RECENTLY IN IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN I THINK. THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THESE SUICIDES WERE
FORESEEABLE ARE PREVENTABLE
EACH OF THESE MEN AND WOMEN ARE
VALUABLE HUMAN BEINGS NONE OF
THEM WERE SENTENCED TO DEATH
AND NON DESERVE TO DIE. I WANT
TO SHARE WITH YOU OUR OPINION
AS THE MAIN CAUSES OF THE HIGH
SUICIDE RATE AND SHE'S HERE
TODAY. AND SUGGEST SOME
INITIATIVES OF THE LEGISLATURE
COULD TAKE TO BEGIN TO ADDRESS
THE ONGOING PROBLEMS. FIRST
DESPITE CDC OURS OVERALL
COMPLIANCE WITH THE TWENTY
ELEVEN UNITED STATES SUPREME
COURT DECISION AND PLAZA.
REQUIRING A REDUCTION
OVERCROWDING TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SEVEN POINT 5% THE
COLEMAN CLASS REMAINS IN
DANGEROUS IN OVERCROWDED
CONDITIONS TODAY. THAT IS
BECAUSE THE COMMON CLASS HAS
NOT SHARED EQUALLY IN THE
POPULATION REDUCTION
CALIFORNIANS PRISONS. THERE ARE
MORE CALIFORNIA. THERE ARE MORE
COLEMAN CLASS MEMBERS IN OUR
PRISONS TODAY THAN THEY WERE IN
WHEN THE SUPREME COURT MADE ITS
DECISION IN TWENTY ELEVEN. AND
THEY ARE AT HIGHER ACUITY
MEANING THEY REQUIRE MORE
CLINICIANS AND MORE SPECIALIZED
HOSPITAL BEDS. SINCE THE
OVERALL PRISON POPULATION HAS
DECLINED BY MORE THAN FORTY
THOUSAND. THE COMMON CLASSES
NOW A FAR GREATER PERCENTAGE
THE PRISON POPULATION WERE NOW
ABOUT 30% CITIES YOUR MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS I FELT
PRESSURE TO PREMATURELY
DISCHARGE COMMON CLASS MEMBERS
FROM HOSPITAL BEDS AND TO LOWER
THE LEVELS OF CARE TO REDUCE
THE BURDEN. ON THE OVER CROWDED
SYSTEM. SUICIDES HAVE RESULTED
AT SAC AND ELSEWHERE IN THE
SYSTEM FROM THIS DANGEROUS
PRACTICE. THERE ARE SIMPLY TOO
MANY SERIOUSLY MENTALLY ILL
PEOPLE IN THE PRISON SYSTEM
WELL BEYOND THE CAPACITY OF CGC
OURS LIMITED CLINICAL
RESOURCES. IT WILL TAKE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AT LEAST SEVERAL MORE YEARS TO
CONSTRUCT. SUFFICIENT
SPECIALIZED PSYCHIATRIC BEDS TO
MEET CURRENT DEMANDS. NOT
INCLUDING THE REPLACEMENT OF
INADEQUATE TEMPORARY EMERGENCY
PSYCHIATRIC BEDS THAT REMAIN IN
USE TODAY. MORE THAN 25% OF THE
ALLOCATED PSYCHIATRIST
POSITIONS REMAIN VACANT. AND
THEIR HIGH LEVELS OF VACANCIES
IN OTHER CLINICAL DISCIPLINES
SUCH AS SOCIAL WORKERS. THE
SYSTEM IS IN A DANGEROUS SPIRAL
CAREENING TOWARDS CATASTROPHE.
THE CHARGES OF CLINICAL STAFF
AND SPECIALIZED BEDS PUT MORE
STRAIN ON THE EXISTING STAFF
WHO ARE UNABLE TO TIMELY
DELIVER CARE. BURN OUT AND
TURNOVERS HIGH AND RECRUITMENT
RETENTION OR OF REPLACEMENTS IS
DIFFICULT. TO MAKE THINGS WORSE
THE DELAYS MISTAKES MENTAL
HEALTH CARE BECAUSE PATIENTS
WHO SHOULD BEEN STABILIZED BE
MORE PRONE TO DECOMPENSATION
PSYCHOSIS AND HOSPITALIZATION.
THE MORE STRAIN ON THE ALREADY
OVER CLINICAL STAFF. SECOND
LIFT AND SHIFT THE TRANSFER OF
RESPONSIBILITY FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
THE CDC ARE FOR PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITALS AND THREE PRISONS
SALINAS VALLEY STOCKTON'S
VACAVILLE. HAS BEEN IN MY
OPINION A FAILURE NUMEROUS
PATIENTS REQUIRING THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF PSYCHIATRIC CARE
RECEIVE LITTLE OR NO TREATMENT
IN THE C. C. R. RUN PSYCHIATRIC
FACILITIES IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
SOME OF THEM DIED AS A RESULT.
AS WE FEARED CCAR'S TURNING
THESE EXPENSIVE LICENSE
HOSPITALS INTO SEGREGATION
UNITS WERE THE CLINICIANS ARE
UNABLE TO BUY TREATMENT TO THE
PATIENTS. CDC ARTS CURRENT PLAN
IS TO INTRODUCE WHAT THEY CALL
TREATMENT MODULES AND WE CALL
CAGES INTO THE LICENSE
HOSPITALS MAKING CONDITIONS FOR
THE ACCU LEO PATIENTS EVEN
WORSE. CAGING MENTALLY ILL
HUMAN BEINGS FOR TREATMENT A
PRACTICE THAT SHOCKED THE
SUPREME COURT SO MUCH. THAT IT
ATTACHED PICTURES OF THE CAGES
TO ITS PUBLISHED OPINION TWENTY
ELEVEN HAS NOT STOPPED IN FACT
CAGES ARE NOT REQUIRED BY
SHOULD YOU SEE OUR FOR EVERY
MINUTE OF TREATMENT FOR EACH
AND EVERY PATIENT. HOUSE IN
CERTAIN SEGREGATION UNITS
RESERVE FOR PRISONERS A SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS. THE SOLUTION IS
MORE TREATMENTS SUPPORTED BY
APPROPRIATE STAFFING. TO ASSURE
THE BOTH PATIENTS AND STAFF FOR
SAFE. NO OTHER LICENSE
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITAL USES CAGES
FOR TREATMENT. THIRD CDC ARE
HAS STILL NOT STILL FAIL TO
COMPLETE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
NUMEROUS RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
SUICIDE PREVENTION
MODIFICATIONS PROCEDURES. THAT
AGREED TO DO IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
DESPITE REPEATED ORDERS OF THE
COURT. THESE INCLUDE FOR
EXAMPLE FAILURES AND ROUNDING
AND OBSERVATION BY COSTS THE
OFFICERS IN NURSES YOURS AND
SUICIDE RISK VALUATIONS AND
SAFETY PLANNING BY CLINICIANS
AND REPEATED FAILURES BY
CLINICIANS AND CUTS THE
OFFICERS TO RESPOND
APPROPRIATELY. TO PATIENTS
EXPRESSING RECITAL FAUCHER
MAKING SUICIDAL GESTURES.
PLAINTIFF'S COUNSEL IS
ADVOCATED FOR TRANSFERRING
ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBILITIES FOR
MENTAL HEALTH CARE FUNCTIONS TO
THE PLOT A RECEIVER FROM C. C.
R. AS A PATH FORWARD. TO YOU
SEE OUR SEEM SIMPLY INCAPABLE
OR UNWILLING TO FULLY IMPLEMENT
ITS OWN COURT APPROVED MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAM. FOURTH AS JUST
EXPLAIN TODAY BY
REPRESENTATIVES OF
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE CCPOA.
CITIES YOUR CUSTODIAL STAFF FOR
OPERATING UNDER EXTREME
STRESSORS. ARE THEMSELVES
EXPERIENCING HIGH RATES OF
SUICIDE. COSTLY OFFICERS
SERVING IN OVERCROWDED AND
UNDERSTAFFED SEE SEE OUR MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS HAVE NO
CLINICAL TRAINING BUT
RESPONSIBLE FOR NUMEROUS DAILY
FUNCTIONS. FOR ACUTELY ILL
PATIENTS EXPERIENCING
DECOMPENSATION. AND PSYCHOTIC
SYMPTOMS AND BEHAVIORS. THE
EXTREME BRUTALITY AND ABUSE BY
CUTS THE OFFICERS DOCUMENTED A
DONOVAN PRISON AND BY THE WAY
IT'S A SMALL GROUP OF PEOPLE.
ADDRESSED BY THIS COMMITTEE IN
LAST WEEK'S HEARING WHEN MY
COLLEAGUE DON SPECTER
TESTIFIED. IS TO BE EXPECTED IN
A DYSFUNCTIONAL AN OVERCROWDED
PRISON SYSTEM. THE VICTIMS OF
ABUSE DONOVAN OUR PRISONERS
WITH DISABILITIES SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS AND OTHER
MEDICAL AND PHYSICAL
LIMITATIONS. AT SAC PRISON
LEVELS OF SUICIDE VIOLENCE
AGAINST PRISONERS AND CUSTODIAL
STAFF ARE COMPLETELY OUT OF
CONTROL SIMILAR PROBLEMS ARE
BEING REPORTED OTHER HIGH
SECURITY PRISON SUCH AS
CORCORAN SALINAS VALLEY IN LEC
OVERCROWDING FIELD FEEDS A
VICIOUS SPIRAL OF STRESS
VIOLENCE LOCKDOWNS CANCEL
PROGRAMMING ACTIVITIES LEADING
TO MORE STRESS AND VIOLENCE
EXACTLY WHAT THE CBO IT WAS
TESTIFYING ABOUT. IN THESE
CONDITIONS SYSTEMS A MENTAL
ILLNESS WILL GET WORSE
INCREASING DEMANDS ON BOTH
CLINICAL IN CUSTODY STAFF AND
THE NEED FOR PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITALIZATION. UNNECESSARY
AND AVOIDABLE DEATHS BY SUICIDE
AND HOMICIDE HAVE RESULTED.
FINALLY FAR TOO MANY PRISONERS
A SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS ARE
HOUSED IN HARSH AND INHUMANE
SEGREGATION UNITS FOR FAR TOO
LONG WITHOUT OF CELL TIME
AVERAGING LESS THAN THREE HOURS
A DAY. THESE UNITS EVEN THOSE
DESIGNED FOR COMMON CLASS
MEMBERS ARE PRIMARILY PLACES OF
PUNISHMENT AND CONTAINMENT NOT
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT. CDC
ARE STILL FAILS TO PROPERLY
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT IN ITS
DISCIPLINARY PROCESS BEHAVIOR
RELATED TO SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS. BOTH THE BEHAVIOR AND
THE MENTAL ILLNESS ARE
EXACERBATED BY HER SEGREGATION
HOUSING. SACKS TWENTY NINE.
TEEN HORRIFIC YEAR OF TRAGEDY
IN DEATH AS A RESULT OF THESE
POLICIES. THESE ARE SEVERAL
THERE ARE SEVERAL INITIATIVES
THAT THIS COMMITTEE IN THE
LEGISLATURE CAN DO THAT WE
RECOMMEND. FIRST CAMERAS MUST
BE PROMPTLY INSTALLED AT ALL
CALIFORNIA PRISONS BEGINNING
WITH A HIGH SECURITY PRISONS.
BODY CAMERA SHOULD BE PURCHASED
REQUIRED TO BE WORN USED BY
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS. HAMMERS
ARE PROVEN TO REDUCE VIOLENCE
HELP CONTROL THE SALE AND
DISTRIBUTION OF ILLEGAL DRUGS
AND REDUCE OVERDOSE DEATHS.
CAMERAS WILL ALSO BRING
FAIRNESS THE DISCIPLINARY
PROCESS FOR PRISONERS AND ALSO
PROTECT CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
FROM UNFOUNDED ACCUSATIONS. IT
IS INEXCUSABLE THE CALIFORNIA'S
PRISONS REMAIN VIRTUALLY CAMERA
FREE. SEE C. R. NUMBER TWO C.
C. R. AS BEING PENNY WISE AND
POUND FOOLISH AND IT'S
INEFFECTUAL EFFORTS TO RECRUIT
AND RETAIN CLINICAL STAFFERS
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS. THE
LEGISLATURE MUST REQUIRES CDC
ARE TO FILL ITS VACANT
POSITIONS. ESPECIALLY
PSYCHIATRISTS. BY SUBSTANTIALLY
INCREASING SALARY BENEFITS
IMPROVING WORKING CONDITIONS
TARGETED BONUSES LOAN
FORGIVENESS AND OTHER CREATIVE
STRATEGIES MUST BE CONSIDERED.
THIS IS A COMPETITIVE MARKET
THE CDC OUR PEERS STEP GIVEN UP.
THREE LEGISLATURE SHOULD DEMAND
A REPORT FROM CDC ARE AND IT'S
INPATIENT PSYCHIATRIC PROGRAMS
THAT TOOK OVER D. S. H. AND
MAKE CLEAR THAT IT WILL NOT
FUND OR PROVE THE INSTALLATION
OF CAGES FOR TREATMENT IN
LICENSE PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITALS.
FOR CBC ARE MUST BE REQUIRED TO
IMPROVE CONDITIONS IN HARSH
SEGREGATION UNITS IN HIGH
SECURITY HOSPITAL UNITS. BY
ASSURING ACCESS TO WORKING
ENTERTAINMENT DEVICES SUCH AS
TV'S AND RADIOS AND PERSONAL
PROPERTY. ADDITIONAL STEPS MUST
BE TAKEN TO REDUCE OR BANNED
THE USE OF SEGREGATION FOR
PRISONERS ARE SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS. SHE'S HERE OFFICIALS
HAVE RECENTLY VISITED NORWAY TO
OBSERVE AND STUDY A PRISON
SYSTEM THAT TRULY FOCUSES ON
REHABILITATION NOT PUNISHMENT.
LEGISLATURE SHOULD FIND
MEANINGFUL CHANGES TO
SEGREGATION POLICY THAT FLOW
FROM THIS LEARNING PROCESS.
FINALLY LEGISLATURE SHOULD FUND
AND ENCOURAGE YOU SEE ARE TO
INCREASE EVIDENCE BASED
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING AND
RE ENTRY SERVICES FOR THE
COMMON CLASSES DURING FOR
EXAMPLE THAT HEALTH CARE
BENEFITS ARE IN PLACE BEFORE
JUST CHARGE. AND THAT WE PUT
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY THERE'S
A PLACE FOR THEM TO GO THAT
SAFE AND APPROPRIATE AT WITH
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH CARE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
DIANA TASHA. OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. AND I THINK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU THIS AFTERNOON ON THE
SUPPORT AND TALKED TOPIC. AT
CDC ARE SUICIDE AS A MATTER OF
FACT HE TAKES SERIOUSLY BOTH AS
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND AS
HEALTHCARE PRACTITIONERS IN
CALIFORNIA'S CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES. AND WE TAKE
SERIOUSLY THE CARE OF ALL OUR
PATIENTS. I WANT TO REITERATE
CLEARLY ON BEHALF OF THE
DEPARTMENT. THAT ONE SUICIDE
ALONE IS ONE SUICIDE TOO MANY.
AT CDC ARE CONTINUES TO
CAREFULLY EXAMINE EACH INCIDENT
FOR LESSONS AND INSIGHTS ON HOW
WE CAN PREVENT THESE TRAGEDIES
FROM HAPPENING IN THE FUTURE.
SUICIDE IS A CRISIS OUT IN THE
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS INSIDE
OUR PRISONS AND SUICIDE IS
REACHING EPIDEMIC LEVELS IN
MANY PARTS OF THE COUNTRY
INCLUDINGIN MANY INSTITUTIONS
SUCH AS THE MILITARY. THE MOST
CONCERNING FOR US. BEAN HAS
MENTIONED THAT TO SIDE HAS
STEADILY INCREASED OVER THE
LAST FOUR YEARS IN CALIFORNIA
STATE PRESS. REGARDLESS OF
WHERE TO SAID OCCURS EACH
SUICIDE AND SUICIDE ATTEMPT
CREATES A SIGNIFICANT RIPPLE
EFFECT. THAT IMPACTS STAFF.
OTHER INMATES. I DO IN
ADDRESSING THE ROOT CAUSE OF
SUICIDE DEALING WITH THE
AFTERMATH AND IMPLEMENTING
MEASURES TO PREVENT IT FROM
HAPPENING AGAIN. THE DEPARTMENT
CONTINUES TO BE PROACTIVE IN
ADDRESSING SUICIDE IN PRISON
AND I WOULD LIKE TO TALK ABOUT
A FEW THE INITIATIVES. CITIES
HERE CONTINUES TO STRIVE TO
MAKE IMPROVEMENTS. OVER THE
LAST THIRTY YEARS. OKAY THANK
YOU SHORT OVER THE LAST THIRTY
YEARS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN DEDICATED TO
DEVELOPING A ROBUST SUICIDE
PREVENTION PROGRAM EMPLOYING
NATIONALLY ESTABLISH BEST
PRACTICES AND COMPREHENSIVE
SYSTEM OF QUALITY MENTAL HEALTH
CARE FOR OUR PATIENTS. UNLIKE
BEFORE WE PROVIDER STAFF BOTH
HEALTH CARE AND CUSTODY WITH
MANDATORY SUICIDE PREVENTION
TRAINING EACH YEAR WE ENSURE
ALL POTENTIAL FIRST RESPONDERS
ARE TRAINED IN EMERGENCY
PROCEDURES AND LIFESAVING
SKILLS SUCH AS CPR AND BASIC
LIFE SUPPORT AND WE EXTENSIVELY
TRAIN OUR TALENTED AND
DEDICATED MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS IN SUICIDE RISK
ASSESSMENT AND RISK MANAGEMENT.
SORRY AND WE HAVE SYSTEMS IN
PLACE FOR IDENTIFYING AT RISK
INMATES AND REFERRING THEM TO
RECEIVE PROPER CARE WE
REGULARLY REACH OUT TO OUR
INMATES VIçT VIDEOS PAMPHLETS
AND INSTITUTIONAL EVENTS TO
ADDRESS ISSUES THAT INMATES
MIGHT BE HAVING AND EDUCATE
THEM ABOUT THE SUBSTANTIAL
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO THEM IF
THEY'RE HAVING DIFFICULTIES. IN
AN INSTANCE. OF AN INMATE'S
SUICIDE THE DEPARTMENT
COMPLETES A COMPREHENSIVE MULTI
DIPS DISCIPLINARY REVIEW BY
HEALTH CARE AND CUSTODY STAFF.
FROM OUR HEADQUARTERS
OPERATION. THIS PROCESS IS
MONITORED BY THE FEDERAL COURT
AND THE DEPARTMENTS POST
SUICIDE REVIEWS ARE RIGOROUS
RESOURCE INTENSIVE.
COMPREHENSIVE AND CONSIDERED
THE GOLD STANDARD OF SUICIDE
REVIEWS. THIS REVIEW INCLUDES A
THOROUGH EVALUATION OF THE
PROPER APPLICATION OF CURRENT
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES WITH
THE GOAL OF DETERMINING WHAT
IMPROVEMENTS ARE NECESSARY TO
PREVENT FUTURE OCCURRENCES OF
SUICIDE IN SOME INSTANCES. WE
FIND THE NEED FOR PROOF LOCAL
TRAINING. IN OTHERS REVISION TO
LOCAL PROCEDURES AND WE WERE
DESPERATE WE DIRECT THE
INSTITUTION. TO COMPLETE A
MONITOR TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE IN
OTHER INSTANCES WE FIND AREAS
OF POTENTIAL STAFF MISCONDUCT.
AND REFER REFER THOSE TO OUR
OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS FOR
DIRECT DISCIPLINARY ACTION OR
INVESTIGATION. AS YOU KNOW IS
MISTER BE MENTIONED CSP SACK IN
PARTICULAR HAS SEEN IN
EXTREMELY DISTRESSING
INCREASING IT INCREASE IN
SUICIDES. AS A JUST IN FEBRUARY
CDC ARTS CENTER MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM TO PERFORM AN
INSTITUTIONAL REVIEW OF
EXISTING OPERATIONS AND
PROGRAMS AND ALSO INCLUDED IN
THIS REVIEW WHERE MEMBERS OF
THE FEDERAL SPECIAL MASTERS
TEAM AS WELL AS- A MEMBER FROM
MR BEANS LAW FIRM. THIS TEAM'S
GOAL WAS TO AND CONTRIBUTORY
FACTORS THAT WERE LEADING TO
THE INCREASED SUICIDE THAT SOCK
AND TO THEN DEVELOP AN ACTION
PLAN TO ADDRESS THOSE FACTORS.
A NUMBER OF INITIATIVES WERE
IDENTIFIED TO HELP IMPROVE
SEIZE THE SACK SUCH AS HAVING
GREATER SOCIALIZATION FOR
PATIENTS AND CHANGES TO MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAMMING. I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO DISCUSS CD ZERO
SIX THAT THE PROVIDER
PREVENTIVE MEASURES AS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED THERE'S AN
ANNUAL SUICIDE PREVENTION
TRAINING FOR ALL STAFF ACROSS
ALL DISCIPLINES. INCLUDING
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS. THIS
TRAINING HAS RECENTLY BEEN
RECENTLY UPDATED WITH APPROVAL
AND INPUT FROM THE LONG TIME
FEDERAL COURT MONITOR. CDC ARE
HAS IMPLEMENTED CRISIS.
INTERVENTION TEAMS WHICH ARE
MULTIPLE MULTI DISCIPLINARY
TEAMS CONSISTING OF CUSTODY AND
HEALTH CARE STAFF. THE GOAL OF
THE CRISIS INTERVENTION TEAM IS
TO PROVIDE TIMELY. AND RESPONSE
OF CRISIS INTERVENTION
STRATEGIES TO HELP QUICKLY
RESOLVE PATIENT ISSUES BEFORE
THEY ESCALATE. ISSUES CAN
INCLUDE FOR EXAMPLE MEDICATION
ISSUES PROPERTY ISSUES AND
CHANGES TO HOUSING FOR THE FOR
THE INMATE ADDRESSING THESE
ISSUES BEFORE THEY ESCALATE
OFTEN PREVENT THEM FROM
ESCALATED TO CRISIS LEVELS.
ALSO WHEN A PATIENT WHEN AN
INMATE IS PLACED IN SEGREGATED
HOUSING THERE TO BE PLACED IN
RED OF RETRO FITTED INTAKE
CELLS WHICH ARE MODIFIED TO
PREVENT LEGIT LITERATURE TYPE
POINTS. THIS PRACTICE WAS
INSTITUTED AT THE DIRECTION OF
THE FEDERAL COURT EXPERT ON
SUICIDE PREVENTION AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
ADDITIONAL CELL RETROFITS AT
FOURTEEN INSTITUTIONS. FOR
STAFF WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
INITIATIVES A HEALTHY STAFF
WILL HELP MAINTAIN HEALTHY
PATIENTS AND SO WE HAVE THE CDC
OUR PEER SUPPORT PROGRAM IS
CURRENTLY BEING STANDARDIZED
ACROSS THE SYSTEM. AND GOALS
FOR THE STANDARDIZATION IS TO
TRAIN CITIES ARE EMPLOYEES TO
CARE FOR FELLOW EMPLOYEES AFTER
SIGNIFICANT EVENT AS WELL AS
FOR DAY TO DAY CHALLENGES THAT
INDIVIDUAL SPACE. WE ALSO HAVE
STRESS RESILIENCY TRAINING
WHICH IS A ONE HOUR ON THE JOB
TRAINING FOR STAFF TO PROVIDE
COPING AND RESILIENCY TOOLS TO
EXIST IN MITIGATING THE IMPACT
OF STRESS ON THE BODY. AND WE
ALSO HAVE ENGAGE WITH DOES OUR
WATERS A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION.
TIME TO THE SYSTEM WELL OF
CORRECTION STAFF BY PROVIDING
EVIDENCE EVIDENCE INFORMED
RESOURCES. AND SUPPORTS. SO AS
YOU KNOW THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR ISSUED A REPORT IN
AUGUST TWENTY SEVENTEEN. AND I
FOUND THAT CDC ARE NEEDED TO
INCREASE ITS EFFORTS IN
PREVENTING AND RESPONDING TO
INMATE SUICIDES IN AMONG THE
INITIATIVES IDENTIFIED THAT
NEEDED ATTENTION IMPROVEMENT
WERE. TRAINING AND MENTORING OF
STOPPED TO SUPPORT THEM IN
RESPONDING TO SUICIDES. THE
DEVELOPMENT OF KEEP POLICIES TO
DIRECT STAFF IN HOW TO DO
SUICIDES AND REGULAR AUDITING
TO ENSURE OUR STAFF COMPLY WITH
RISK EVALUATION AND TREATMENT
PLANTS. ARE KEY TO HOW WE'VE
BEEN DEVELOPING AN IMPROVING
OUR PROCESS SEES. BUT WE DO
RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR
CONTINUED PHILIP VIGILANCE AND
INCREASED IMPROVEMENTS IN OUR
PROCESS SEES AND ARE COMMITTED
TO MOVING FORWARD TO ADDRESS
THOSE DEFICIENCIES. AND IS
PENSION PREVIOUSLY AS A STATE
WE NEED TO ADDRESSMENTAL
HEALTH IN THE COMMUNITY. AS
WELL AS IN PERSON. AND TO SAY
PREVENTION BEGINS IN
COMMUNITIES IN HOMES NOT AFTER
AN INDIVIDUAL COMES TO PRESENT.
THERE MUST BE A MULTI PRONGED
EFFORT AT ALL LEVELS INSIDE AS
WELL AS OUTSIDE OF PRISON TO
ENSURE WE'RE ABLE TO TREAT
THOSE SUFFERING FROM MENTAL
HEALTH DISORDERS WHILE IN THE
MIDST OF THEIR DESPAIR. AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TAKES BOLD
STEPS TO MAKE SURE COMMUNITIES
HAVE THE TOOLS AND RESOURCES
THEY NEED FOR SUICIDE
PREVENTION AND HELPING
INDIVIDUALS MANAGE THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH DISORDERS. SO MEDI CAL
HEALTHIER CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
INITIATIVE THIS INITIATIVE
SEEKS TO COORDINATE AND
INTEGRATE HEALTH CARE DELIVERY
SYSTEMS MORE EFFECTIVELY AND
PROVIDE MORE SERVICES. THAT
SUPPORT PATIENTS WITH COMPLEX
POSITION THE STATE TO BETTER
CONNECT INDIVIDUALS INCLUDING
CHILDREN AND YOUTH IN FOSTER
CARE AND INDIVIDUALS%
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS. AND
THE JUSTICE INVOLVED WITH THE
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED MAKING
THESE CONNECTIONS WILL HAVE
SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS ON THESE
INDIVIDUALS HEALTH AND QUALITY
OF LIFE. IN ADDITION THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM WILL FIND
COUNTY OPERATED COMMUNITY
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SYSTEMS. THIS WILL
HELP SPEARHEAD SYSTEM CHANGES
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL INCLUDING
DATA SHARING FOR CARE
COORDINATION TO ENSURE QUICK
RESPONSE TO ADDRESSING MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES BEFORE THEY MEN'S
MANIFEST INTO SUICIDE SUICIDAL
TENDENCIES. AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ALSO PROPOSES A RADICAL
SHIFT IN ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS IT LAUNCHES A NEW
STATE FUND FOR DEVELOPING
ADDITIONAL AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS AUGMENTING RENTAL
SUBSIDIES AND STABILIZE
IMPORTANT CARE HOMES. AND THE
GOVERNOR IS ASKING THE
LEGISLATURE TO TAKE EARLY
ACTION ON ESTABLISHING THIS
FUND SO THAT THE CONTRACTS AND
INVESTMENTS ARE READY TO BE
DEPLOYED IN THE SUMMER. CITIES
YOUR VIEWS THESE MEASURES TWO
WAYS. FIRST IS A SYSTEM THAT
CAN CARE FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
SERIOUSLY MENTALLY ILL IN THE
COMMUNITY SO THEY DON'T COME TO
PRESENT. AND SECOND AS A SYSTEM
THAT CAN SUPPORT OUR PATIENT
POPULATION AFTER BEING RELEASED
SO THEY DO NOT HAVE TO RETURN
TO PRISON. THANK YOU. I'M GOOD
EVENING THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK HERE MY NAME'S INNOVATE
MON I MISS. OF WORK FOR SEIZE
THEIR FOR NINE YEARS I HAVE HAD
VEGAS BUT WITH CITY SEE OUR
WORK DEADLINES BY DIRECT
PATIENT AND ALSO INVOLVE IN
POLICY DECISIONS AND
DISCUSSIONS- ABOUT HEADQUARTERS
SO WANT TO START BY TELLING
EVERYONE PSYCHIATRISTS- ARE
MEDICAL DOCTORS WHO HAVE
COMPLETED MEDICAL SCHOOL JUST
LIKE YOUR PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS YOU'RE A
CARDIOLOGISTS- YOUR
PEDIATRICIAN'S. FOLLOWED BY FOR
YOUR SPECIALTY TRAINING IN
PSYCHIATRY. AS YOU'RE ALL AWARE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND CDC
ARE HAVE BEEN GUIDED BY THE
NINETEEN NINETY TWO COLEMAN
FEDERAL COURT CASE LAST OCTOBER
FEDERAL JUDGE MILLER MADE A
STATEMENT THAT TRULY CAPTURED
SOME OF THE MAJOR ISSUES AND
CITIES ARE MENTAL HEALTH. SHE
SAID THAT CITIES HERE ADOPTED A
LASER FOCUS IN AN EFFORT TO
OBTAIN TERMINATION OF COURT TO
THE PENSION AND IT APPEARS TO
HAVE LOST COMPLETE SIDE OF THE
REASONS THAT THE MEDIATION WAS
REQUIRED IN THE FIRST PLACE. TO
REMINDED US THAT LEGAL CASES
HAVE HEARTS AND SOULS ABOUT
MENTALLY ILL PATIENTS HOUSE
BEHIND BARS HAVE THE UNDENIABLE
RIGHT TO CONSTITUTIONALLY
ADEQUATE MENTAL HEALTH CARE.
SUICIDES AND CDC ARE JUST THE
TIP OF THE ICEBERG CD SALES
FOCUS ON FROM UNDER FEDERAL
OVERSIGHT HAS LED TO SOME
WARPED PRIORITIES. THE POLICY
AND WILL FIND TO MAKE NUMBERS
GOOD COVER UP THE DEAL IT'S
SUCH AS INADEQUATE. IS THAT FOR
STAFF TO MAKE BACK DECISION. I
ABLE ON. STAFF TO MAKE MEDI
TREAT AND MEDICAL STANDARD OF
TO SAYS. MEANT THAT BALL.
MOMENT IN AND THESE POLICY
ENABLE TO MINIMIZE OF PHYSICIAN
INVOLVEMENT IN PATIENT.
STAFFERS SAID I FOR FAILURE CDC
ARE NOT KIND OF FINE PROBLEM
POLICY AND FOR. THAT ARE FREE
MISS AND TO. THEY WERE THIRTY
EIGHT COMPLY SO IT'S AND SEE
YOUR INTO NINETY AS MY- IF AN
ALARM THESE ON INCREASE. I
RECENTLY. TO FIVE OF THINKING
BECAUSE I THOUGHT TIME FOR ALL
OF THEM OCCURRED WITHIN DAYS TO
MY AFTER THE PATIENT'S MOUTH
LEVEL OF CARE. MOST WOULD HAVE
BENEFIT FOM C. AFFECT SOONER
THAN WAS REQUIRED BY PAUL. I
BELIEVE THE ARKANSAS HAVE BEEN
TO IF THE MAKING THE TRIP
DECISION DIDN'T FEEL PRESSURE
TO DO THE BAY MINIMUM. AND IF
WE FOLLOW COMING STANDARD I WON
A DOG BREED ABOUT THE COUNTRY'S.
EIGHTEEN INCOMPETENT CONSCIENCE
PSYCHOTIC. IS OUR VIEW PROBLEM
NOT. THEM WE CANNOT RETAIN
PSYCHIATRIST BECAUSE HE YOUR
ALLOWS NON MET STAFF OVERRULE
PHYSICIAN DECISION I WORKING
FIRST SANTA CHOIRS IF DEGREE OF
COUPLE. THAT ALLOW OF SECOND
JUST CANNOT HANDLE ORDER CHOIRS
WITH TO FIGHT SYSTEM WHICH OCT
BONE MOST OF OUT AND HAS
POTENTIAL FOR IT WITHOUT A
DONALD VIGILANCE THE SYSTEM
REVERTS TO UNSAFE PRACTICES CDC
ARE BLAMES THE AS SO ON INTO.
JUDGE MILLER IDENT. LAST YEAR
AGAIN BUT THE EXTRA. AND IT.
ADDITIONAL X. IN. THE WOULD BE
FOR HER. AND I'M- THIS WORK.
THAT DOES NOT VALUE THE
ESSENTIAL PRESS THAT PSYCHOLOGY
HAVE TO. AND CREATES AN
ATMOSPHERE WHERE MORAL IS LOW.
THE ON PORTS REALITY IS FOR
OVER TWO FIVE YEARS OF PEACE
THAT SUFFER AND STATE HASN'T
SAVE ANY MONEY. WE NEED CHANGE
OUR CULTURE AND AMID A INTO TO.
WE MUST ADDRESS THE SCOPE OF
BACK IS TO THAT AND GOT IT ON
CALL STAFF TO OVER TEN MEDICAL
DECISION. WE NEED TO EMPOWER
TOOK OUR- AND TELL IN POLICY
DECISION WHICH THEY IN OP. TO
EXISTING STANDARDS FOR SO
PREVENTION AND PSYCHIATRIC
CARE. UNLESS WE ARE ABLE TO
TAKE THESE ACTIONS ARE PATIENTS
WILL CONTINUE TO SUFFER AND WE
WILL CONTINUE HAVE FOR PATIENT
OUTCOMES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR TIME. OKAY. YES SO I WHEN I
WAS TO OF THIS COMMITTEE I
REMEMBER TRYING TO GET BODY
CAMERAS OF FOR ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND WE DID- WE DID
A STUDY THERE WERE ONE YEAR TWO
YEAR STUDY SO THAT WE CAN
DETERMINE HOW MANY HOW MUCH THE
COST OF DATA- AND- WE STILL
DON'T HAVE. H. P. WOOD WOOD
BODY CAMERAS AND I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE PROBLEM IS THAT AND-%
IT'S A I DON'T THINK. STE OF
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
HAS COME HERE TO YOU TO ASK FOR
BODY CAMERAS I DON'T KNOW IF
CDC OURS COME TO THIS COMMITTEE
ASKED FOR BODY CAMERAS AS A
PART OF IT IS YOU GOT ASK. AND
YOU HAD A WARNING. AND SO I
WOULD I WOULD SUGGEST THAT THAT
DISCUSSION GOES TO HEADED
DEPARTMENT SAID A WEEK IF THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT IS NECESSARY
TO NEEDS NEEDED ONE YOU'VE GOT
YOU GOT ASKED FOR TO BE ABLE TO
GET IT- UP TO I. DID THE WHOLE.
SYSTEM OF SUICIDES IN THE WHOLE
PROBLEM OF IT BUT DO YOU YOU
HAVE MORE DATA ON- THE
CORRECTION OFFICERS TODAY HERE
IT IS A SPIKE. BUT IN A NUMBER
OF CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
THEY'RE ALSO HAVING IT'S
SUICIDE WHICH TELLS YOU THAT
IT'S JUST IT'S NOT JUST THE
INMATES IN GIVING THEM WHAT
THEY NEED. ALL THAT THEIR
SUPERVISING THEM KEEPING THEM
SAFE FROM PROTECTION PRODUCTION
FROM EVERYBODY ELSE. BUT HAVE
WEEK EVERYFULLY. GONE INTO
MAYBE LOOK AT INNOVATIVE WAYS
TO DEAL WITH IT BECAUSE WHEN
YOU'RE LAW ENFORCEMENT. ARM THE
HAVE THE STIGMA OF GOING TO SEE
OF A METAL MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL- MIGHT NOT BE GOOD
FOR YOUR CAREER MIGHT NOT BE
GOOD. FOR YOU TO WORK WITH
SOMEONE ELSE M. THE TRADITIONAL
WAY OF DOING THINGS WE MAY HAVE
TO DO SOMETHING OUT OF THE BOX
AND NOT JUST A STANDARD WHAT.
THIS PERSON IS AN ADULT AND
THAT IS DONE OTHERWISE. YOU'LL
SEE YOU YOU MAY START TO SEE
THE END MAYES GO DOWN IN NUMBER
SUICIDE BUT I THINK IT'S JUST
AS APPALLING. THAT WE HAVE THE
NUMBER OF- CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS- SUICIDE THEY'RE GOING
UP AND SO HAVE. AND WE REALLY
ADDRESS THAT COULD THERE'S
SOMETHING GOING ON. THERE THAT
WE- WE DEFINITELY NEED TO
ADDRESS. OKAY YEAH I BECAUSE I
KNOW WE'RE JUST TIME SO TEN AB
I THERE MAY A FEW OF YOU WANTED
TO PUBLIC ON THE SURE IF LEFT.
ONE WE HAVE TWO PEOPLE. SOUNDS
GOOD. OKAY I'M SO YEAH NO I DO
THE WANT TO A LITTLE BIT AND-
YES OUR PRESENCE IS IN JAIL SO
CALIFORNIA BECOME CA OF A TO
MEADOW HOUSES WHICH IS WHICH IS
INEXCUSABLE. BUT I CAN'T HELP
BUT THINK THAT A LOT OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT ABOUT THE LACK OF
REHABILITATION IS PART AND
PARCEL TO THIS CONVERSATION WE
HAVE I THINK YOU SERIOUS
CULTURAL ISSUE WITHIN CDC ARE
THAT PROBABLY LEADS TO A LOT OF
THE OUTCOMES ULTIMATELY THAT
WE'RE- THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
I THINK INCLUDING. DOCTOR YOUR
COMMENTS ABOUT. PHYSICIANS OR
PSYCHIATRISTS WHO ARE TRYING TO
BE A PART OF THE SYSTEM. AND TO
GET OVER RULES ARE OVER RUN BUT
I JUST. SO THERE'S REALLY A LOT
HERE TO THAT I THINK FOR US TO
CONTINUE TO EXPLORE AND LOOK
FOR. BUT JUST IN THE TESTIMONY
AND THE STUFF THAT IT'S COME
COME ALONG FOR CDC ARE. WHAT IN
THE WORLD COULD BE THE
THERAPEUTIC BASIS FOR. THE
CAGES AND FOR TRYING TO. EVEN
TEMPORARILY PUTTING SOMEBODY IN
A CAGE AS PART OF THEIR
TREATMENT PROGRAM AND DOESN'T
THAT ABSOLUTELY AND DO WHAT
EVER ELSE MIGHT BE BEING TRIED
TO BE ACCOMPLISHED IN THAT
SESSION AS I'M ASSUMING THAT
THEY'RE NOT THERE FOR THAT'S
NOT THEIR PERMANENT PLACE BUT
THERE THERE IT ACCORDING TO THE
DOCUMENTATION HERE. FOR THEIR
THERAPEUTIC. APPOINTMENTS OR OR
ENGAGEMENT AT HOW IT ALL. IS
THAT CONDUCIVE TO ADDRESSING
ANY OF THE ISSUES THAT THAT IN
MAY MAY HAVE. SO WE HAVE WE CDC
ARE HAS UTILIZED THE
THERAPEUTIC TREATMENT MODULES
FOR. A NUMBER OF YEARS I DON'T
KNOW HOW LONG THEY'VE BEEN IN
EXISTENCE AND- WE CONTINUE TO
EXPLORE WITH THE PLAINTIFFS AND
SPECIAL MASTER ALTERNATIVES
FOR- TREATMENT. AND THEY WERE
WERE USED THEM TO KEEP THE BOTH
THE INMATE AND THE STAFF SAFE
IN CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE- IT'S
NOT SAFE FOR OTHER FOR OTHER
ENGAGEMENTS. I UNDERSTAND THAT
BUT I CANNOT FOR THE LIFE OF ME.
SEE HOW ANY PROGRESS CAN BE
MADE WITH AN INDIVIDUAL WHEN
THEY'RE RECEIVING TREATMENT.
AND IF IT'S IN A CAGE LIKE THAT
I'VE SEEN THOSE I DON'T THINK I
COULD EVEN STAND UP IN ONE LET
ALONE NECESSARILY EVEN SIT IN
ONE. JUST GIVEN MY SIZE SO IT'S
REALLY ASTONISHING TO ME TO SEE
THAT SOMETHING LIKE THAT IS
CURRENTLY BEING USED AND IS
CURRENTLY A MAJOR PART OF HOW.
TREATMENT AND I SORT OF EVEN
HATE TO USE THE WORD GETS
DELIVERED. EVEN IN A DIFFICULT
CITING LACK OF PRESENCE SO I
DID I THINK THIS REALLY
UNDERSCORES WHAT WE'VE HEARD
FROM THE GUARDS WHAT WE HEAR
FROM THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE. IN
CUSTODY IN OUR PRISONS AB YES
THERE IS A SERIOUS MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUE ACROSS SOCIETY AND
THINGS THAT WE HAVE TO DEAL
WITH BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO LOOK
AT HOW WE'RE TREATING PEOPLE IN
OUR CUSTODY IN OUR CARE. IN
WHAT WAS IS SUPPOSED TO BE A
THERAPEUTIC ENVIRONMENT AND IT
LOOKS TO ME LIKE CITY SEE ARE
BECAUSE OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES
GIVEN UP ON THE THERAPEUTIC
COMPONENTS SO I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE HERE
INCLUDING SOME SIGNIFICANT
CULTURAL CHANGES. WITH WITHIN
THE SYSTEM SO I JUST FOR ME I'M
IN. I CAN'T SAY THAT I'M HAPPY-THIS IS COME TO US AND THAT
WILL BRING IN UP BUT I AM GLAD
WE'RE ASKING QUESTIONS WE ARE
LOOKING AT THIS. BECAUSE THIS
IS THE SYSTEM WE ARE FUNDING.
AND I DON'T SEE HOW WE CAN
EXPECT THINGS TO CHANGE WITHIN
THAT SYSTEM EVEN AS WE TRY TO
WORK ON A LARGER SOCIETAL
ISSUES. WITH THAT THE CURRENT
CIRCUMSTANCES THEY EXIST. I
MADE SOME HOW EFFECTIVE BUT LET
ME BILLS WOULD STAY WE CAN BE A
ONE MINUTE. THANK YOU MAY CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS DOUGLAS
CHIP OUT ON BAIL OF THE AFTER
LOCAL A SIX UNION AMERICAN. AND
DENTISTS GIVEN LATENESS OF THE
HOUR WE NUMEROUS PHYSICIANS
HERE AND SECOND. PROVIDED TO
PREPARED TO THE PUBLIC. I JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE
COME STORE MAY TODAY BECAUSE
REALLY COOL MISTER TALK ABOUT
AT STAFF FOR PSYCH. A
SUPPLEMENT STONE TALK TO
MINIMUM. AND UNDERMINING
PHYSICIAN INPUT AND DOES A
REALLY CRITICAL THINGS-
CONTRACT POSITIONS BY THE WAY.
DO NOT UNDERTAKE OF SUFFICIENT
TRAINING COMPARABLE TO RANK AND
FILE PSYCHIATRY. CONTRACT
POSITIONS DO NOT UNDERTAKE
COMPARABLE TRAINING TO
PHYSICIANS FROM AND A WHOLE
TREATMENT JUST THINK ABOUT
THAT. SO I THINK WE REALLY HAVE
TO TAKE A SERIOUS HARD LOOK. AS
MISTER- READY JOHN SORES
ALLUDED TO TALKING AND SPEAKING
AND LOOKING TO BEING OUTSIDE
THE BOX AND CONTEMPLATING
THINGS THAT WE HAVEN'T DONE IN
THE PAST. WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND VISIONS ARE HERE TODAY
IN SOLIDARITY AND WE SUPPORT
PATIENTS THEIR FAMILIES HAVE
LOST A LEVELS. WE THANK YOU.
ARE YOU DOING LET AND MY NAME'S
MYSTIC AT. I'M A RETURN IS IT
ISN'T. OWN I JUST CAME HOME IN.
200-019-2000 A FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN ARE PARTICIPATING IN A
MASS SO WE STRIVE. DOING THAT
TIME CDC WHEN A SMALL OR ARE
RICHER. YOU'D FORCE AGAINST
PRISONERS LIKE MYSELF AS A
OTHERS A LIFE PARTICIPATING IN
A MASS ALWAYS TRY. SO I SAY
THAT TO SAY DID YOU HAVE
INDIVIDUALS THIS SUBJECT WE
SUBJECTED TO OUR RETALIATION
WHEN THEY SPEAK OUT AND SAY OH
WELL YOU KNOW I'M HAVING
SUICIDAL IDEOLOGIES OR- YOU
KNOW I FEEL LIKE YOU KNOW I'M
HERE DAY SENIOR DAYS WHAT THEY
DO TO USE MEDICATION TO PUNISH
THE PRISON. SENESCENT THERE WE
NEED TO TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW IN
TWO THOUSAND AND THIRTEEN OR
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN YOU HAVE
BEEN THE SOUTH HE COMMITTED
SUICIDE DOING A HUNGER STRIKE.
YOU GOT A MAYES THESE BEEN
THERE FOR A LONG TERM SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT IN A WITH AN AYE
AYE UNDER ASK VERSES GOVERNOR
CASE AND WE DON'T TALK ABOUT
THOSE IN MAYES THAT WAS IN
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT FOR THIRTY
OR FORTY YEARS THERE WAS DE
COMPENSATE. YOU KNOW SO COMB IN
CLASS I. COMO VERSES. IS THE
GOOD QUE BUT THERE'S MORE PRO
IN MORE SOME NEEDED FOR THESE
TOP HIM HE'S BECAUSE PRESS IS A
PRISON IS OUTSIDE. IT'S NOT A
PRISON. YOU KNOW SO WE YOU
THINK OF OKAY YOU GOT A
LIBERATES CASE VOICES TRYING TO
OUT. THE OFFICE DON'T YOU KNOW
HAVE AN ADEQUATE RESOURCES
SOMETIME EVEN HAVE FAMILIES. SO
WHEN YOU. SOME OF THE TO ME
PART HE SAID WHAT I SAID TO BE
THAT'S OURS. SOME OF THE SIR.
OKAY SO. I SUM IT UP WHAT I
STAND. WE ALL THESE. ASK OF ALL.
VOTE OUT VOTE ALL YOU ARE. IT
WITH. COMPLETE A CONDUCTOR OF
DONE PUT INTO COMPLETE. UP I
WANT TO SAY. THAT SURE. ORDER
SAID THE SHORTAGE OF
PSYCHIATRIST. IT'S CALLED THE
RIPPLE EFFECT IN THE MENTAL
HEALTH SHORT THANK GOD FOR NOT
DOWN PATIENTS ON UP GOOD
PROPERTY MENTAL HEALTH GET
AFFECT UNNOTICED OFTEN
EVERYBODY WHEN IT WAS BOBBY
EIGHT BEFORE THE CITY SAID OVER
THE DS SUCH BEFORE THE BECOME
PHP WE HAVE ALMOST TWO HUNDRED
PATENTS. WITH STUFFING A
PSYCHIATRIST TO STOPPING Vì
DIDN'T HAVE ANY SUICIDE ATTEMPT
OR I AM THE HEAD WHOSE HARD BUT
NO SUCCESSFUL THROUGH SIDE AND
THAT FACILITY OFF THEIR LOST
YOUR REQUEST TO. THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING I'M NOT A DOCTOR
SUSAN B. ANDREWS AND I ALSO
WORK AT CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
FACILITY I'M A PSYCHIATRIST
THERE I'VE BEEN OF POSITIONS
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE. I
WOMEN TO CDC ARE IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN. I HAVE NEVER WORKED IN
SUCH CONDITIONS. IT IS THE
WORST POSSIBLE PLACE FOR
ANYBODY CUSTODY AND STAFF TO
WORK WHAT I FEEL YOUR SOLUTION
IS IN PHOEBE FEE ARE PEOPLE
PROMOTE. UP TO HEADQUARTERS WHO
HAVE NO CREDENTIALS IN BEING
THERE AND WHEN THEY SCREW UP
LIKE THEY DE IT WITH- THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE FOR
MILLIONS OF FACILITY THEY GET
LATERALLY MOVED TO ANOTHER
POSITION OF POWER. THEY DON'T
GET REMOVED THEY GET LATERALLY
MOVED AND EVERYBODY UP THERE.
EVERYBODY JUST ABOUT IF NOT A
PHYSICIAN. THERE ARE
PSYCHOLOGISTS AND SOCIAL
WORKERS WE HAVE ONE FIVE HIGH
INTEREST THERE WHO'S TOTALLY
QUIET IT EVERY TIME HE SPEAKS
UP ON OUR BEHALF AND HE'S NOT
EVEN IN AN EXECUTIVE POSITION
WHERE HE GETS TO HAVE A VOICE
ONE ANYTHING THAT AFFECTS WITH.
SO AT THE VERY TOP YOU DON'T
HAVE ANYBODY REPRESENTING US AT
THE FACILITY LEVEL WE ARE
CONTROLLED BY PEOPLE WHO HAVE
TWO YEAR DEGREES AFTER HIGH
SCHOOL. HI MY NAME IS KEN
POLLACK AND THE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA PRISON FOCUS WE GET
A FIVE TEN LETTERS A DAY AND
MANY OF THEM ARE. DESCRIBING
THE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES ONE IS
THAT. SEVERAL PEOPLE WOULD WANT
SOMEBODY YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN
CALLED A SUICIDE BY CDC. LITTLE
ARE- OTHER PEOPLE IN THE- IN IN
THE TIER WILL WRITE US IN AND
ARE TELLING US THAT THEY WERE
CALLING A MAN DOWN MAN DOWN FOR
HELP FOR HOURS. AND MORE
RECEIVING THE HELP. THERE IS
THE- OTHER ISSUES WE HAVE
VOLUNTEERS FOLKS COME THROUGH
WHO WHO WORKED A PSYCHIATRIST
IN C. C. R. AND SOME OF THE-
YOU KNOW THEY- ALSO DESCRIBE US
HOW THEY CARED AND IF YOU CARE.
YOU'RE GONNA BE PUSHED OUT OF
THERE IF YOU TREAT. EMAIL FOLKS
WITH ANY SORT OF HUMANITY THERE
THEY'RE GONNA BE PUSHED OUT BUT-
IT'S EVER SO YOU KNOW WE'RE
GETTING LETTERS FROM. ALL THE
DIFFERENT PRISONS ALL OVER
DESCRIBING THE SITUATION SO
IT'S NOT ONE PERSON ONE LETTER
ONE PRESENTS ALL OVER THE
STATE- PEOPLE IN THE PS YOU
UNITS ARE WRITING TO US AND
SAYING WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
GETTING EXTRA PROGRAMMING IT.
THEY HAVE WILL HAVE A- THE THEY
SAY WHAT WERE REALLY JUST GET
NOW THEY'RE WATCHING TV SO THIS
DOESN'T SOUND LIKE PROGRAMMING.
WELL THE SO. THE IS THE DON'T
WE'RE NOT SEEING ANY
IMPROVEMENTS OR HERE IN A LOT
OF TALK BUT WE'RE NOT SEEING
MANY IMPROVEMENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY THANK ALL OF YOU WHO CAME
TODAY. AND YOU KNOW IT IT- AND
I'VE SEEN THE CAGES AT THE END
WHEN I WAS A DONOVAN RECENTLY.
WE I CALL FOR THIS HEARING
BECAUSE OF- MY DEEP CONCERN AS
I WATCHED THE NUMBERS RISE. OF
THAT WHILE WE WERE DRESSING A
LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS IN
TERMS OF REHABILITATION AND-
VARIOUS OTHER KINDS OF- ISSUES
REGARDING STAFFING OR WHATEVER
WAS. THAT WE WERE ONCE AGAIN
MISSING SOME CRITICAL ELEMENTS
AS TO WHY THIS WAS OCCURRING
AND HOW ARE WE GOING TO PREVENT
IT- END OF MY COLLEAGUE IS MR
STONE IS ABSOLUTELY CORRECT
WE'VE GOT A CULTURAL. ISSUE
THAT EXIST IN OUR SOCIETY WITH
REGARDS TO INCARCERATION. AND
EVEN WITH OUR BEST EFFORTS THAT
WE'RE PUTTING FORWARD TO REDUCE
THE POPULATION AND DO A VARIETY
OF THINGS WE STILL HAVE. OF
SOME ENORMOUS CHALLENGES- THAT
ARE SO EMBEDDED IN OUR SYSTEM-
THAT IT IS A TOXIC ENVIRONMENT
THAT ONLY FOR OUR- INMATES BUT
ALSO FOR EMPLOYEES. AND WE HAVE
TO SOME POINT ADDRESS THAT YOU
KNOW. TALKED ABOUT PEOPLE DO
AROUND THE WORLD BEING SOMEWHAT
SUB ON TO OTHER PLACES AND LOOK
AT PRISON VITAMINS. AND SEE
SOMETIMES A VERY DIFFERENT KIND
OF REALITY YOU KNOW THE LENGTH
OF STAY PEOPLE ARE SAYING OUR
PRISONS ARE SO LONG THAT IT.
DRAMATICALLY AFFECTS THEIR
THEIR MENTAL STATE IN THE KINDS
OF THINGS THAT ARE THERE- I.
YOU KNOW IT'S SO IT'S REALLY
I'M IT'S BOTHERING ME
PERSONALLY BECAUSE I THINK THAT
WE GET IN OUR MENTALITY WE
PROMOTE CERTAIN THINGS WITHOUT
ACTUALLY SAYING SO. YOU KNOW I-
WHEN I WAS DEALING WITH THE
ISSUE OF LETHAL FORCE- I BEGAN
TO NOTICE IN SO MANY WAYS HOW
WE PROMOTE. OF PHYSICAL
VIOLENCE IN IN IN LONG. OF IT
WAS JUST LOOKING AT TV GRAMS
LIGHT THE BLUE BLOOD IN SOME OF
THESE OTHERS WERE. IT IT BEEN
COPLEY THE IS ONE BE BEAT UP
GET IN FOR OUT OF THEM OR WHAT
IT MAY BE AND WE WHAT'S THAT IS
IN A TWO WITHOUT OUTRAGE AND SO
THE AND SOMEHOW ANOTHER THE SUB
CONSCIOUS LEVEL. WE SUPPORT
THAT KIND OF ACTIVITY THAT
OCCURS IN AN IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AS I SAID THE
OTHER TIME WE HAD A HEARING
LAST WEEK I SAID IT IT BOTHERS
ME WHEN I HEAR PEOPLE SAY
WHOEVER'S BEEN ARRESTED AND
WHOEVER IS GOING TO BE COULD
BE. SENT TO PRISON THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO BECOME JONES
GIRLFRIEND. NOW THAT PROMOTE
SEXUAL VIOLENCE IN PRISONS I
MEAN AND PEOPLE LEARN TO EXPECT
THAT. AND TOLERATED- I WAS.
MEETING WITH ONE OF OUR OUR
SERGEANTS AFTER MY LAST HEARING
AND HE WAS TELLING ME HE HAD A
MEMBER OF HIS FAMILY THAT WAS
INCARCERATED. AND THE BRUTALITY
THAT THIS YOUNG MAN HAD IN
DOOR. AND EVENTUALLY JOINED A
GANG TO PROTECT HIMSELF YOU
KNOW IN THIS ENVIRONMENT AND SO
HE'S TELLING ME THIS STORY. AND
HE'S HE SAID LISTEN TO SOME OF
THE THINGS IN AND HE WAS
DRIVING ME I EITHER TO THE
AIRPORT OF YET OR FROM THE
AIRPORT WHEN I DON'T REMEMBER
LAST WEEK. BUT IN IN ANY EVENT.
HE HE'S HE'S SEEING IN HIS OWN
FAMILY THE KIND OF. OF TRAUMA
THAT EXIST WHEN A PERSON IS
INCARCERATED. AND WAS SAYING TO
ME YOU KNOW WHAT THE THIS YOUNG
MAN RIGHTS. MY MOTHER'S LETTERS
AND SAYS IT WAS IT WAS A STEP
BROTHER HE SAID. AND I'M JUST A
SHAME OF THE THINGS I'VE HAD TO
DO IN HERE TO SURVIVE. YOU KNOW
SO WHEN YOU START TALKING ABOUT
WOMEN'S NOT WANT TO TALK ABOUT
STUFF SOMETIMES THAT THINGS ARE
SO EMBARRASSING. THAT THEY AS A
PERSON HAS ALLOWED THIS TO
HAPPEN TO THEM. JUST TO STAY
ALIVE THAT- IT WE HAVE IT MAKES
IS WE HAVE TO RETHINK OUR
INCARCERATION WE HAVE TO
RETHINK. THE CULTURE THAT'S
THE- YOU KNOW. I WAS LOOKING AT
SOME MOVIE THE OTHER NIGHT IN
THE SO. THEY HAD THEY WERE
BEATING UP ON THIS GUY- AND-
AND THE GUARD WAS IN AT HIS
DESK HEARING IT. NOT STOPPING
IT BUT HEARING IT. BECAUSE
THAT'S THE EXPECTATION THAT
THOSE FOLKS WILL BEAT UP ON
EACH OTHER AND SO THE WHOLE
ISSUE OF. OF VIOLENCE IN AND
FEAR AND ALL THESE THINGS THAT
THEY'RE IN SO YOU CAN ONLY
IMAGINE THE MENTAL STATE THAT A
PERSON. LIVES IN WHEN THEY'RE
IN THAT KIND OF ENVIRONMENT AND
THAT WE SAW THE REPORT TO CAME
OUT AND SO. WE'VE GOT YOU KNOW
WE'VE GOT A SERIOUS ISSUE AND I
CAN CITY PERSONALLY BOTHERS ME.
SO WHEN I THINK ABOUT THE
SUICIDE SOME THINKING WELL. YOU
KNOW WE'RE WHATEVER WE'RE DOING
IS SUPPOSED TO MAKE LIFE BETTER
FOR FOLKS NOT WORSE. YOU KNOW
OF THESE OF FOLKS WALKED THE
STREETS EVERY DAY AND WOULDN'T
COMMIT SUICIDE. THEY GO ON TO
OUR PLACE. AND THEY DO OR
MEMBERS. FEAR COULD NOT AS THE-
CO. THAT THERE IN AND AS A
RESULT IT'S TEARING THEM APART
INSIDE. BECAUSE IT'S NOT WHO
THEY WANT TO BE AND MANY A
MARTY ARE QUITTING OR DOING
WHATEVER THEY'RE GOING TO DO.
AND IT'S A DIRECTLY AFFECTING
THEIR FAMILY THEIR FAMILY LIFE
FOR ME. THIS IS NOT A HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENT I MEAN YOU KNOW SO.
AS WE LOOK AT HOW WE HAVE
INCARCERATED PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THE HUGE
NUMBERS AND THE FACILITIES AND
HOW THEY LOOK IN ALL THESE
THINGS. IT IS REALLY- IT'S
ALARMING YOU KNOW AND
INTERESTING TO ME I HAVE BEEN
TO. ALMOST A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF NOT HOME WAS ALL THE PRISON
IN CALIFORNIA. NOT AS A
LEGISLATOR BUT WHEN I WAS A
TWENTY TWENTY YEAR OLD SINGER I
USED TO GO SING IN PRISONS. AND
IT BOTHERED ME THAT YOU KNOW TO
THE GOAL BUT I'D GO BECAUSE
THESE GUYS ARE SO HAPPY TO SEE
FOLKS COME. AND GIVE THEM SOME
ENTERTAINMENT DURING A AND
THOSE WHO WERE- HAD BEEN GOOD
GOT A CHANCE TO GO BUT- BUT I
SAW ALL THE YOU KNOW THE CAJUN
OF INDIVIDUALS AND EVENTUALLY
IT WORKED ON. I GOT TO PROVIDE
LIKE TO GO BUT I WOULD GO
SOMETIMES- BECAUSE IT IS A IT
IS NOT A HEALTHY PLACE TO BE.
AND THAT WAS YEARS AGO WHEN WE
DIDN'T INCARCERATE AS MANY
PEOPLE BEEN CARS RIGHT NOW. IS
WHEN I WAS IN COLLEGE SO THIS
IS A TOTALLY AND SO YOU GO IN
THERE NOW. AND IT IS. I MEAN
IT'S NOT A WELCOMING
ENVIRONMENT. AND NOT THAT HE
WOULD WANT TO SET REALISTIC
PRISON SO ONE FOR ABOUT ONE
GOAL NO ONE WANT TO GO ANYWAY.
BUT AT LEAST IT CAN BE A PLACE
WHERE YOU GOAL. AND YOU'RE NOT
OF. FOR YOUR LIFE. EVERY DAY.
YOU KNOW AND I'VE HAD. MOTHERS
SO IN CHURCH COME IN ASK FOR
PRAYERS BECAUSE SON TO GOING TO
HAVE TO. MAJOR SURGERY. ALL WAS
SOMETHING THAT HAVE. AND THEY
WILL BE TRANSFERRED TO ANOTHER
PRISON AND SO. AND WATCH THESE
PEOPLE WHO WERE THERE NOT. THIS
WE PEOPLE COMING TELL ABOUT THE
GLADIATORS AND THE WHATEVER
BLANKS AT THE- ORGAN I IN THE
PRISONS. WHAT KIND OF CRAZY
THIS IS THIS YOU KNOW I- AND
YET WE KNOW THESE THINGS HAPPEN.
AND LET THEM COME. IT'S VERY
ALONG TO I'M AND I'M NOT SURE
HOW YOU DISMANTLE. SUCH A
SYSTEM AND REBUILD IT BUT
SOMEHOW ANOTHER WE HAVE TO. WE
HAVE TO BECAUSE EVEN IF WE
REDUCE OUR POPULATION IF THE
FOLKS WILL COMING OUT HAVE BEEN
A PART OF THIS KIND OF WORLD.
IT CHANGES WHO THEY ARE IN THE
WORST KIND OF WAY RATHER THAN
THE BEST KIND OF WAY. AND I'VE
I'VE I HAVE GREAT CONCERN FOR
OUR EMPLOYEES WHO ALSO NOW
EXPERIENCING THE KIND OF TRAUMA
THE PTSD OR WHATEVER IT IS
WORKING IN THAT ENVIRONMENT AND
HAVING TO MAKE PEACE WITH
THEMSELVES OUT LOOKING AT THE
WOMAN WHO WAS HERE AND WAS
ALMOST IN TEARS JUST TO DISCUSS
WHAT SHE HAS SEEN. OVER THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS OF AS AN AND
A GENTLEMAN AS WELL I MEAN YOU
YOU ENJOY THAT KIND OF VISION
AND YOU IMMEDIATE I THINK OF
THOSE WHO'VE BEEN IN
AFGHANISTAN AND WHO'VE BEEN IN
VIETNAM AND THE NIGHTMARES THAT
THEY HAVE AND THE THINGS THAT
OCCUR IN THEIR LIVES THAT WE
HEAR ABOUT. SO WE HAVEGOT TO
DO SOMETHING AT YOU KNOW AND I
I'M NOT SURE. WHAT IT IS BUT AS
TO YOU KNOW WHAT I'M CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE WHICH WE'VE GOT
TO FIND SOME SOLUTIONS WE'VE
GOT TO GO SOME OTHER PLACE AND
SEE WHAT THE PEOPLE DUE. TO
PROVIDE A SAFE AND PLACES WILL
WHERE ARE SO RIGHT TO DO THAT.
AT ROLE AND GET BETTER. READ
THESE FEARFUL TRAPS THAT ARE IN
I GET THE SENSE THAT ARE YOU'LL
PLEASE IF YOU COULD SURVIVE
PRISON PROBABLY CORRECT BUT BUT
OBVIOUSLY THAT INVITE BUT
THEY'RE PUTTING BOOKS IT IS
REALLY. REALLY TOXIC FOR EVERY
ONE AND I'M WE'VE GOT TO FIND A
SOLUTION. WE'VE ACT OF SOLUTION
THERE IS NO CARRYING ON FOR THE
NEXT FIFTEEN YEARS WE ARE THE
FINAL XIN WHAT I'M DOING. OTHER
IS THE SOLUTION. WE HAVE. AND
THAT. BOTHERS ME THE THIS IS
THAT IT'S NOT. ONLY NOT SIGN GO
THE OTHER PLACE IS. IT IS BAD
IT IN EVERYTHING THEY WHETHER
FROM. FROM LA SCHOOL OF UP AND
HOW THEY TREAT EACH OTHER AND
THOSE WHO IN TROUBLE AND ALL
THOSE KIND OF THINGS WE HAVE
JUST GOT TO DO A BETTER JOB AND
THIS IS TRULY. NOT A GOOD
REFLECTION ON CALIFORNIA OR
EVEN ON THIS NATION. IT IS SET.
THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING
APPRECIATE IT HAVE A GOOD DAY
THIS MEETING IS THE CHAIR.